الإنسان الحداثي هو إنسان مُهان
غير أنه فارغ من الداخل
نحن لا نعرف كل أنواع الحرية التي أنتجها التاريخ البشري
نحن نعرف فقط الحرية السياسية التي أنتجتها الدول الغربية لنا
لأن تاريخ الحرية الذي لا نمارسه اليوم
وقد مارسته البشرية بأنواع عديدة قبل القرن التاسع عشر
قد مات
قُتل من قِبل الحرية الغربية
هل تشوف أن الفتوحات الإسلامية كانت احتلال؟
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبومالح
أتذكر مقولة تقول: أن كل شيء حولنا نسميه الحياة
من صنع أشخاص مثلنا مو أذكى مننا أبدًا
وأؤمن بهذه الفكرة
لكن المشكلة الآن، واللي عليها فُتحت هذه الحلقة وبتعالجها بشكل أو بآخر
هي أن كل هذه الحياة ومفاهيمها هي منتجات غربية
الحرية اللي نعرفها هي بتعريف غربي
الإنسان من هو؟ ولماذا هو موجود؟
تعريف غربي
العمل، التقاعد، المساواة
ومثل ما يقولون عِد واغلط
ضيفي لديه مشروع ضخم
هدفه زعزعة الخطاب المهيمن على الدراسات الإسلامية في الغرب
لأنه يعتقد أن الغرب فهمنا، ونظر إلينا بعدسة إستشراقية
فجاب بالعيد
يقول درست التاريخ الأوربي لأفهم التاريخ الإسلامي
التاريخ الإسلامي كما نعرفه اليوم ليس تاريخنا
فما هو التاريخ الإسلامي؟
كيف نشأت وتطورت الشريعة الإسلامية من بداية الخلافة الراشدة
مرورًا بالدول الإسلامية، حتى ظهور الدولة الحديثة؟
وما أن تفتح باب الدولة الحديثة والحداثة
إلا وتفتح معها أبواب وأسئلة فلسفية، أخلاقية، جوهرية
وهذه الأسئلة والنقاشات والنقودات هي ما يطمح إليه ضيفي
أن تُطرح في أروقة الجامعات والأكاديمية العربية والغربية
ضيفي هو الدكتور «وائل حلّاق»
أستاذ العلوم الاجتماعية في جامعة كولومبيا الأمريكية
في قسم الدراسات للشرق الأوسط
رسالته للدكتوراة كانت بعنوان «هل انسد باب الاجتهاد؟»
نتيجةً لأرق وأسئلة محيّرة ساقته لهذا السؤال، وصارت رسالته للدكتوارة
والحلقة دسمة ومليئة بالأسئلة المحيرة
والأجوبة اللي تقود لمزيد من الأسئلة
قبل أن نبدأ
الحلقة هذه، كما هي كثير من حلقات فنجان
مليئة بالمواد والمراجع اللي تتعلق بمواضيع
طرحها ضيفي في سياق الحديث
أو من معلومات مهمة من رحلة البحث والإعداد
جمعناها لكم على شكل رسالة بريدية
فإذا كنت مهتم
رابط الاشتراك في نشره فنجان البريدية
موجود في صندوق وصف الحلقة
أما الآن، لنبدأ
أيش بتتوقع يكون طول المقابلة؟
ما في وقت محدد في بالي، يعني ممكن...
أيش الطول المثالي؟
الطول المثالي هو اللي أنت تكون وصّلت فيه
فكرتك بشكل مثالي. صدق
لأن فيه حلقات تكون ساعة وتكون كافية
وفيه حلقات إلى أربع ساعات وتكون...
أيضًا ناجحة كثير
ناجحة
أنا سمعت قلت لواحد من ضيوفك
أن فيه حلقة كانت ثلاثة أكثر من ثلاث ساعات وجابت كم مليون مشاهد
صحيح
فيه حلقة ثلاث ساعات وشوي
جابت الآن 50 مليون
ما شاء الله، عن العلاقات
عن العلاقات
وفيه حلقة برضه...
بس هذيك ممكن تقول أنها تمس الناس كثير
بس فيه حلقات غريبة، يعني ما عاد صرت أعرف الأرقام حقيقةً
فمثلًا ما أعرف ليش صار مثل كذا
في حلقة مع «جورج صليبا»
أيوه زميلي
فيعني نخبوية مفترض
والحلقة وصلت إلى الآن 7 مليون
أيوه لاحظت
فغريب قبول الناس
ما تعرف مسبقًا
ما أعرف مسبقًا أبدًا
يعني مثل كتابة الكتب، يعني تكتب الكتاب
ولا تعرف. الكتاب ربما يكون عادي
وربما يشتهر، وكله من نفس المؤلف
فعلًا
والمؤلف لا يعرف
هي تمشي على كل الأشياء سواءً الكتب، الأفلام
يعني أنت تكتب...
صحيح، فيه نوع من الخلطة الكيماوية
اللي صعب الواحد يتنبأ لكل مركباتها
وكل ما زادت رغبتك في أنك تصنع مادة للانتشار
كل ما قلّت أعتقد
أنت إذا صنعت المادة لأجل المادة
أيوه صح
إذا كان نبغى نأخذ استراحة ممكن؟
أي وقت
وساعتها كم ممكن أنه تقطع
إيه نقطعها ونضبطها
المشاهد لا يعرف أنه انقطعت
لا، ما يعرف، فأي وقت يناسبك...
لكن فيه مشكلة أنا ودي أعرفها منك
هل تتوقع أن الناس تعرف أو تفهم مشروع «وائل حلاق»؟
لأن كل ما سألت ترى يعني...
طبعًا يتوقف على نوع الكتاب تحت البحث
أو إذا كان المشروع هو المشروع الكلي لـ«وائل حلاق»
من ناحية كتب، بتصور فيه اختلاف وتفاوت كبير بين تجاوب الجمهور
«الدولة المستحيلة» بالذات
قد خلقت ضجة كبيرة
وأستطيع أن أقول أن هناك نخبة معينة
التي فهمت الكتاب بشكل دقيق وممتاز
حتى بعض المسلمين في أمريكا هنا
قد استطاعوا أن يغوصوا في معاني الكتاب
وقد فهموا هذا الكتاب بشكل دقيق
وأحيانًا أشعر وأقول يا ليتني قد ندبت لهم بأن يتكلموا بالنيابة عني
ولكن في أحيان أخرى
فكان فيه إساءة للكتاب
إساءة من نوعين: إساءة بنية طيبة؛ لمجرد أنهم لم يفهموا الكتاب
أو أنهم ليس لهم الخلفية الضرورية لفهم الكتاب
وهذا شيء طبيعي، لا تلوم أحد على ذلك
ولكن هناك نخبة صغيرة، صغيرة
قد هاجمت الكتاب بنية غير صافية
لأجل تهديمه وتهديم مشروعه
وهدم حتى نزاهة الشخصية التي كتبت الكتاب
عرب أو غرب؟
لا، كلهم عرب
كلهم عرب!
الغربيين وغير العرب
لهم ردود فعل معتدلة أكثر من بعض العرب
في العالم العربي
«الدولة المستحيلة» قد أثارت ضجة لسبب
وهو بسبب المعارك الفكرية التي قامت حول الكتاب
فأنا لست الطرف الوحيد في الدفاع، أو في تفسير الكتاب
فهناك العديد من الأشخاص الذين يدافعون عن الكتاب
لأنهم يعتقدون أو يؤمنون بنظرة عامة
تشبه نظرتي للمشاكل التي نواجهها اليوم
ممتاز، فأنا بحاول، ما استطعت...
يعني هذه الحلقة ودي أنها تمس أغلب الناس
أنا أعتقد أن فيه الكثير من المفاهيم اللي تطرحها
اللي إذا الناس فهمتها ممكن تنعكس على حياتها بالإجمال
ليس بالضرورة على نطاق الدولة
وإنما حتى على النطاق الشخصي والفكري لأي إنسان
فبنحاول ما استطعنا
تمام
فأقول يارب
فأبغى أرجع إلى نقطة
أنت قلت أنك أنت في بداية بحثك
كنت حاولت بحث التاريخ الأوربي لفهم التاريخ الإسلامي
وتقول: «أن التاريخ الإسلامي كما نعرفه اليوم ليس تاريخنا»
ودي أعرف أيش الأشياء اللي ما نعرفها عن تاريخنا الإسلامي؟
كتابة التاريخ اليوم تختلف تمامًا عن كتابة التاريخ قبل القرن التاسع عشر
التاريخ بما نعرفه اليوم هو وليد الممارسات الأوربية في القرن التاسع عشر
حتى في أوربا ليس قبل القرن التاسع عشر بكثير
بطبيعة الحال، وكأنها معادلة رياضية
ليست بحاجة للبرهنة
هو أن إذا كنا ننطلق من أي خطاب كُتِب في الحاضر
بمعنى القرن التاسع عشر والعشرين
فنحن نقرأ التاريخ من المعطيات ووجهات النظر
ومشاعر وتفكير هذين القرنين
أضف إلى ذلك، فحتى لو لم يكن هناك استعمار
أو لم يكن هناك أي شيء آخر
حتى لو كنّا فقط...
لنقل مسلمين نعيش من غير التاريخ الاستعماري
الذي حدث لنا في آخر 200 سنة، مضبوط؟
فينبغي أن تضيف على هذا، الاستعمار
الاستعمار الأوربي فريد من نوعه في التجربة الإنسانية
وهذا شيء قليل من الأشخاص الذين يفهمونه
طبعًا المسلمون مثلًا احتلوا بلاد كثير ما سُميّ بـ «الفتوح»
ولم تسمى بشيء في اللغة العربية مثل الذي يوازي كلمة
«كولونيالتي» أو «كولوني» أو «كلونياليزم» ولكنها فتوح
فهذا صحيح أنها فقط كلمة: فتوح
ولكن لها دلائل ومفاهيم عميقة
لأن الفتح الإسلامي، مثلًا، كان من نوعية معينة
تختلف اختلافًا تامًّا عن الاحتلالات والاستيطانات
والاستعمارات الأوربية في القرن التاسع عشر
وهي بالأساس حدثت تقريبًا جميعًا في القرن التاسع عشر
حتى لما دخلت إنقلترا على الهند
لم تستطع أن تُخضع الهند لإرادتها
لم تستطع أن تكوّن الهند، إلى ما تظن أنها الصورة الحقيقية للحضارة
إلا في القرن التاسع عشر
من البداية، ولكن بمنتصف القرن التاسع عشر
حدث انهيار الهند تمامًا تحت أقدام الإمبراطورية البريطانية
هل أنت تشوف أن الفتوحات الإسلامية كانت احتلال؟
طبعًا، لما تفتح أرض فأنت تحتل الأرض
ولكن كلمة احتلال كلمة حديثة، بالمناسبة
فتوح كلمة قديمة مثل «فتوح البلدان للبلاذري» وكذا
فتوح تستعمل دائمًا في كل المصادر الإسلامية
ولكن احتلال هذا...
هناك نقطة أخرى، أبو عمر، يجب أن ننتبه إليها دائمًا
وأنا أوجّه هذا الحديث للشباب
أن اللغة هي مفتاح الفهم، والفهم هو مفتاح التصرف ورؤية الحياة
فإذا لم تكن تنتبه إلى اللغة؛ ستضيع
فنحن نفكر اليوم أن ما نستعمله لكلمة مثل احتلال
مثل أي كلمة ثانية
مثل «كلونياليزم» أو مثل فتوح
لا، احتلال تجي مثل ما نحن نشوف الاحتلال الإسرائيلي
ليش بنسميه الاحتلال الإسرائيلي؟
لأن الاحتلال يحل محل الفلسطينيين
ويأخذ تراثهم، ويسرق أرضهم، ويدمر بيوتهم، ويطردهم
هذا الاحتلال
يحل محل
هذا نوع من الاحتلال، هذا النوع الشنيع من الاحتلال
لأنه يُقصي المواطنين الأصليين عن أرضهم
مثل ما صار في أمريكا مثلًا
أقصوا كل ما يسمى بالهنود الأمريكيين
عن أرضهم وقتلوهم وشتتوهم وأبادوهم
يعني 90 مليون مواطن
هندي أمريكي قُتلوا في الاحتلالات الأوربية
والاحتلال الإسرائيلي يحاول أن يمارس ما يسمى بالإبادة الجماعية
ضد الفلسطينيين ولكن بشكل مبرمج وبطيء
هذا نوع من الاحتلال
ولكن هناك احتلالات أخرى تبقي المواطنين
مثلًا بريطانيا في الهند، لأنها لا تستطيع أن تنفي
أو تقتل كل الهنود. فماذا تفعل؟
مثلًا في أستراليا وفي أمريكا وفي إسرائيل
يحاولون تدمير السكان الأصليين. لأنه ممكن، فهم صغار
ولكن في الهند لم تستطع طبعًا
لأن الهنود كانوا أكثر بكثير حتى من الأوربيين كلهم، صحيح؟
فأيش سوّوا؟
إذا أنا ما أقدر أقتلك وأمحيك من الأرض عشان أبغى آخذ أرضك
أبغى أعملك مثلي
لأنك أنت لما بتصير تفكر مثلي
خلاص أنت صرت مني، أنا بآخذك وبسوي فيك اللي أبغى
لأن أنا عندي السلطة السياسية
وأنتم الرعايا، وقد أصبحوا يطيعون ويتقبلون كل المبادئ
والنظرات السياسية والاجتماعية والقيم الأخلاقية للحاكم
فخلاص يصبحوا من السكان
ولكن القوة والقيادة والسيطرة هي في أيدي المستعمرين
فمثلًا بريطانيا حكمت الهند
يعني تقول 150 سنة بشكل فعّال
وقبلها يمكن 250 سنة لم تستطع كثيرًا، ولكنها نجحت في الآخر
ولكن في كل التجربة هذه، 450 سنة
لم يكن هناك هندي واحد قد جلس في البرلمان الإنقليزي في لندن، صحيح؟
ولكن الهنود حتى اليوم...
إذا بتلاحظ تحكي مع الهنود
خلينا نسميهم أخواننا الهنود، بغض النظر عن دياناتهم
كثير متشبعين بالحضارة والعقلية الإنقليزية
منهم من وصل في تقليد الإنقليز لدرجة السخافة
على الأقل عندي تُثير بعض الضحك
وهم لا يعرفون أنهم قد استُعمروا
هذا الاستعمار الحديث
هو عندما تبلور ذاتية المستعمَر على صورة ذاتية المستعمِر
بس مو الآن رئيس الوزراء البريطاني...
هذه من التأثيرات اللاحقة، بعد اللاحقة، بعد اللاحقة للاستعمار
مثلًا إنقلترا اليوم فيها ملايين من الهنود
هذا الشيء اللي لم يستطع الإنقليز أن يسيطروا عليه
وبما أن هناك هنود كثيرون في إنقلترا الآن
فترى أن بعضهم ناجحين جدًّا، ومعهم فلوس كثير
ويستطيعون أن يبنوا ما يُسمى بالقوة السياسية
فواحد منهم نجح أن يصير. ليه؟
لأنه قد استغل هذه الانقسامات في الصخر
واستطاع أن يحوز على هذا المنصب
ليس لأن الإنقليز يحبون الديمقراطية
ومستعدين أن يتقبلوا كل نتائج الديمقراطية، هذا مفهوم خاطئ جدًّا
ليش؟
لأن الديمقراطية تسمح لكل شيء، ما زال ديمقراطيًّا. وهذه دكتاتورية
لأن الديمقراطية الغربية هي مسألة الحرية السياسية الغربية
وهذا موضوع آخر، وإذا بدك بنبحثه ببعض التفصيل لاحقًا
خلاص
لأن معناه أن عندك أنت الحرية السياسية
هي حرية لها معنًى معين، وهي من نوعية معينة
ليست كل حرية هي...
نحن لا نعرف كل أنواع الحرية التي أنتجها التاريخ البشري
نحن نعرف فقط الحرية السياسية التي أنتجتها الدول الغربية لنا
فمثلًا أقول لك
غير مبدأ الحرية بالنسبة للديمقراطية الغربية والليبرالية
أعطني مثالًا، وفسّر لي تفسيرًا كافيًا عن نوع آخر من الحرية
أنا أسأل هذا السؤال دائمًا لطلابي
ولا واحد حتى الآن استطاع أن يجيب عليه
ولا واحد؟
لأن تاريخ الحرية والذي لا نمارسه اليوم، وقد مارسته البشرية
بأنواع عديدة قبل القرن التاسع عشر، قد مات
قُتل من قِبل الحرية الغربية
فنحن نعرف فقط نوع واحد من الحرية
وهذا النوع الواحد هو نوع سياسي، وبالأساس اقتصادي
هو ليس فقط سياسيًّا
وهذا أنت لما بتروح بتصوّت في الإنتخابات
هذا مو فعل سياسي فقط
هذا فعل سياسي طبعًا
ولكنه ليس فعلًا سياسيًّا محضًا، إنما هو فعل اقتصادي
ودي أرجع لنقطة الاحتلال والتعريفات
كنت تقول أن اللي جالس يصير مثلًا في الهند من البريطانيين
أنهم ما قالوا لهم اطلعوا، لكن خلوهم وقالوا صير مثلي
صح
أليس هذا هو نفس اللي حصل في الفتوحات؟
فصاروا كل الدول اللي انضمت تحت الدولة الإسلامية
يعني أصبحوا عربًا، مسلمين
غيّروا هويتهم إلى اللغة والهوية حتى الدينية
وتديّنوا بدين آخر
أيوه، طبعًا
فهذا مو نفس الشيء؟
لا، فيه اختلاف كبير
أول شيء: تاريخيًا، قليل من الناس من يعرفه
أن حتى في القرن الرابع والخامس الهجري
كان المسلمون أقليّة في بلادهم
هل كنت تعرف ذلك من قبل؟
لا، أبدًا
إذن كان المسلمون أقلية؟
أيوه، المسلمون كانوا أقلية في بلادهم
كانوا الحاكمين. وكانت إمبراطوريتهم
لأن ما كان فيه...
لاحظ هنا أنا قلت إمبراطوريتهم، ولكن هذا استعمال خاطئ
لأن هم لم يعرّفوا أنفسهم بأن عندهم إمبراطورية
كان عندهم خلافة أو سلطنة
وأنا قلت إمبراطورية، لأني لازلت متأثرًا بالخطاب الحديث
بس مو اصطلاحات مختلفة ليس إلا؟
لا، كل شيء له معناه. والمعنى يحدد الكمية والكيفية
والكيفية مهمة جدًّا
فخلينا نبدأ في أول حقيقة عن التاريخ الإسلامي
وهذا بدأ من البداية
من عصر عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه، أيش قال؟
قال لما تفتحوا بلد خلوهم، واتركوهم لحالهم
(لَكُمْ دِينُكُمْ وَلِيَ دِينِ)
هذا شيء واضح جدًّا كان لم يُفكر فيه، وكان شيئًا طبيعيًّا
أول شيء عقليتهم كانت تشتغل كذا
والقرآن الكريم أصر عليه
فخلوهم يعبدون أيش ما ودّهم
أعطوهم حريات دينية
اليهود والمسيحيين كان يقدرون يتزوجون ويتاجرون
ويصلون ويعملون أيش ما ودّهم، تقريبًا، حسب عقائدهم ودياناتهم
بس لما تطلع من بيتك أنت في حارة، أو في شارع مشترك للجميع
فيه يهود ومسلمين ومسيحيين وإلى آخره
أنت تحترم قانون أو شرع المجتمع بشكل عام
وهو شرع إسلامي
فلا تستطيع أن تبيع الخمر
ولا يجب أن تتعامل مع المسلمين بالفائدة
الربا
والأشياء المحرمة والممنوعة
هو بالأساس الخمر واللحوم المحرّمة
والخمر كان واحد من المشاكل الكبيرة دائمًا
حتى في التاريخ الواقعي، ليس فقط من ناحية المبادئ والفقه مثلًا
إنما في الحقيقة كانت هناك مشاكل
لأن الخمر كان شائع حتى بين العرب
فكان يسبب مشاكل كثيرة
فهذه المشكلة ودّنا نتفاداها
وأصروا على معاقبة أي شخص يقوم بهذه الأفعال الشائنة
ولكن عاشوا...
أو ندخل في صميم آخر مهم
هو أن اليهود والنصارى وغيرهم من الأقليات
وفي الهند لاحقًا عندما الدولة المغولية احتلت الهند
أيضًا أدخلوا في جياب الإمبراطورية الإسلامية
أدخلّوا الهندوسية والبوذية والجانية وإلى آخره
كان فيه 500 أو 600 أقلية في الهند
كلهم دخلوا تحت الحكم الإسلامي
فأصبحت الشريعة التي تُطبَّق على اليهود والنصارى والزرادتشيين
تمتد تقريبًا إلى جميع الآخرين غير المسلمين
ولكن، والنقطة الحاسمة هنا
أن اليهود والنصارى وغيرهم
ربّوا أولادهم وأنشأوهم على القيم
الإسلامية؟
لا، على قِيَم الملة التي هم منها
فاليهود استمروا في أن يكونوا يهودًا
وليس ذلك فقط، وإنما المسلمون أصروا أن يكون لكل أحد دينه
أنت ودك تكون يهودي؟ سوي أيش ما ودك كيهودي، ويحق لك
أنت من ذمتنا، أيش يعني ذمّي؟
يعني إحنا مديونين لك، ما دام أنت بتدفع الجزية وإلى آخره
مديونين لك أن إحنا نحميك
نحميك على شروطك الدينية
يعني شرائع الكتاب، وإذا كان الكتاب يهودي أو كتاب مسيحي
فشرائع الكتاب هي دائمًا مقدسة سياسيًّا
فاحترام تام لهذه الأقليّات
فلذلك أصبحت الهوية اليهودية والهوية المسيحية
استمرت بكونها نفس الهوية
طبعًا مع تغيّر الأزمان تتغير أشياء كثيرة في أي حال
ولكن هذه العقائد والممارسات اليهودية مثلًا
أنا استعمل اليهودية كمثال
استمرت على مدى القرون
حتى إقامة دولة إسرائيل، عندما كل شيء انتهى
اليهود تركوا البلاد الإسلامية راحوا إسرائيل
والدولة الحديثة دخلت؛ ففكّكت المجتمع اليهودي والإسلامي
هذه قصة ثانية
ولكن اللي ودّي أقوله أنا، أن ما زالت الأقليّات في الإسلام
وأنا ما أقصد ليس أقليات عددية، ولكن أقليات دينية
بمعنى أنّ ليس هم الحكام مثل المسيحية واليهودية
استطاعوا أن يستمروا في توليد أنفسهم على مر العصور
على شروطهم هم، مو على شروط المستعمر
فشوف قد أيش فيه تسامح، قد أيش فيه انفتاح
إذا إحنا بنقول مثلًا في كندا
أنا عشت في كندا أربعة وعشرون سنة
فأعرف هذا اللي بيسموه ثقافة متعددة
يعني مسخرة. عندما تدرس التاريخ الإسلامي
وترى كيف أن المسلمين عاملوا الأقليات تبعتهم
وطبعًا إحنا بس بنحكي من ناحية تغيير الذاتية للمحتل
وممكن نحن نتكلم عن أشياء أخرى
مثلًا أن اليهود والمسيحيين في التاريخ الإسلامي، حتى القرن العشرين
إذا بتنظر لمصر مثلّا أو أماكن ثانية، فيه عندك أقليات مسيحية ويهودية
تجدهم دائمًا في الطليعة، كانوا دكاترة والمحامين والتجار والأغنياء
وعندهم امتيازات كثيرة
ومرات كان عندهم امتيازات أكثر من المسلمين بشكل غير عادل
يعني مرات بصراحة كانوا يطوفوا
زي ما يحدث الآن في أندونيسيا
إذا بتشوف أندونيسيا فهي تكرر نفس التجربة
عندك 3% من أندونيسيا صينين
ويحوزون على 70% من الثروات الطبيعية في أندونيسيا، والأموال
3% من السكان بيدهم 70% من ثروات البلد
كيف تقدر تقرأ هذا التسامح في الحكم الإسلامي مع غير المسلمين
بينما أن برضه نفس التاريخ الإسلامي تلقى العداء
اللي يصير كثير مثلًا مع داخل المسلمين فيما بينهم
مع المذاهب المختلفة، أو اللي عنده أفكار مختلفة
يعني التاريخ فيه الكثير من الأمثلة...
طبعًا كان فيه
مثلًا إذا بعطيك الفترة الصليبية، كان كثير فيه تعدي على المسيحيين
في اللي بنسميه اليوم سوريا، في حلب ودمشق بالأساس
وبعض القرى الأخرى التي كانت في السابق
تحيط بالقلاع
زمان كان القلعة دائمًا حواليها قرى
فهذه كانت دائمًا عرضة للعنف
طبعًا كان فيه. ليش؟
لأن كان فيه تشكك كبير أن المسيحيين في دمشق كانوا يساعدوا الصليبيين
دائمًا لما يكون فيه اضطهاد ضد مسيحي أو يهودي في التاريخ الإسلامي
لم يكن فقط بسبب تزمّت طبيعي
متأصّل في العقلية الإسلامية، هذا لم يكن
دائمًا كان فيه ظروف، خاصة التي كانت تؤدي للحاكم
أو للشعب أن يشدوا الحزام على الأقليات هذه
الفترة الصليبية بدون شك كانت مشكلة للمسيحيين في سوريا
أنا لم أكن هناك، ولا أستطيع أن أقرر في الأمر هل كانوا جواسيس أم لا
ولكن هذا شيء طبيعي
مثلًا إذا بتنظر للأمريكا في الحرب العالمية الثانية، أيش عملت؟
حطت كل اليابانيين في معسكرات مسيّجة
اليابانيين حتى اللي كانوا ولدوا في أمريكا من أجيال
ولم يكونوا يابانيين إلا بالشكل
ولكن حطوهم كلهم في هذه المعسكرات. ليش؟
لأنهم شكّوا أنهم ممكن يساعدوا اليابان
هذا شيء طبيعي، هذا رد فعل لا نستطيع أن نقول، بالرغم من قباحته
لأن هناك أشياء في الحياة، قبيحة ويجب أن تحدث
كما يقولون نحن نولد
لحظة الولادة لحظة جميله جدًّا، ولكن نولد في الدم
صحيح؟
صحيح
فهذا قسم من ما تعنيه محاربة عدو قد غزى بلادك
واحتل أرضك وقتل شعبك وقتل الآخرين
يعني الصليبيين لم يقتلوا فقط المسلمين
قتلوا حتى المسيحيين في القدس، وفي القسطنطينية قبل إسطنبول
غزوا هناك وطبعًا قتلوا البيزنطيين المسيحيين
لأنهم لم يكونوا مثلهم، كانوا يبغوا يخلصوهم، يخلصوا أرواحهم
يساعدوهم أن يوصلوا للخلاص، قتلوهم
أنا ودي أرجع للشريعة
أنت في كتاب «الشريعة» كنت تقول
استطاع الدين الجديد في القرون الثلاثة الأولى
في إنتاج نظام تشريعي راقي
صحيح
ودي تعطيني كيف بدأ؟ كيف تشكّل هذا النظام التشريعي
من بدايته في عهد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم؟
مقدمة إذا سمحت
كل رؤية تاريخية هي خطاب
يعني عندما أقول أن تاريخ الإسلام قد تطور لكذا وكذا
هذا خطاب
وهذا الخطاب يصبح قسم من مكوناتي الفكرية
ولذلك من مكوناتي الذاتية
فالخطاب يكوّني كذات
فهناك على الأقل، سأتحدث فقط عن خطابين
خطاب عن فتره نشوء الشريعة
لنرى الفرق بينهما، ولاحقًا ربما سنبحث في مسائل الاستشراق
فستكون مقدمة لهذا النقاش اللاحق
هناك خطاب استشراقي يقول أن الشريعة تكوّنت
بعد أن غزى أو فتح أو استعمر المسلمون البلاد الأخرى
وقد أتوا من الجزيرة
جماعة بدو، ما في عندهم شيء، لا حضارة ولا حتى تفكير
كل النظرة الاستشراقية لشعب الحجاز
وحتى كل الجزيرة من القسم الجنوبي تبعها وين نشأ الإسلام
أو المنتصف الجنوبي تبعها
هو أنه شعب بربري، قبلي. أيش معناه قبلي؟
قبلي هذه نقطة أخرى ممكن ندرسها بعدين
قبلي يعني ضد كل القيم المتحضرة اليوم
وهذول ما كان عندهم شيء
بعثوا قبائلهم اللي يحبوا العنف
واحتلوا الشمال والشرق والغرب
وبالآخر بعد ما احتلوا الأرض هذه
قالوا أيش نعمل؟ الآن احتليناها، كيف بنسوي؟
ما عندنا شيء
خلينا نأخذ ثروات الشعوب الثانية
مو بس في الأموال والأراضي، لا
الثورات الحضارية بما فيه القانون
فأيش سووا؟
جاء المسلمون، لأن ما في عندهم شيء
عربٌ بجمٌ، هذه النظرة الاستشراقية، وأنا بلخّص لك الآن
يمكن لازم تدفع لي شوي، لأن بلخّص لك حوالي 200 كتاب
هذا الخطاب في 200 كتاب، إذا بتلخصهم وبتختزلهم
في هذه النظرة
وأنا كتبت عنها كثير، بالمناسبة هذه مو انطباعات
هذه تكوّنت من سنوات من الدراسة، لأن قسم كبير من كتاباتي
هي رد على المستشرقين من هذه الناحية
ومن ناحية كيف تكوّنت الشريعة
فأخذوا القانون الروماني والقانون البيزنطي
والقانون اللي قبله اللي هو القانون اليوناني والقانون اليهودي
كل هذا سُرق بالأحرى
هم ما يقولون سُرق، بيقولوا استُقرض
استُعير
أو يقولون دَين، فمثلًا أيش يقولون في الإنقليزي عشان نلخص للشباب
اللي مهتمين بهذه الدراسات
يا أن هي استجلابات، لما بتستقرض
أو أنه دَين
أما استعارة أو دَين
دَين معناته شوفوا أيش أخذوا مننا
والاستعارة هو أخذوا مننا
بالأول ففيه نوع من الضمان لازم تدفعوه
والثاني هو أنه بس أخذوا مننا
صحتين ربما
فهذه النظرة الاستشراقية
هذه النظرة المتطرفة؟ أو هذه النظرة...
هذه النظرة الاستشراقية السائدة
وحتى أقول بعد كل الكتابات التي كُتبت ضدها
بالأساس من عدد قليل من الأشخاص، ما تزال سائدة كثيرًا
لذلك من كبراء المستشرقين في الشريعة الإسلامية، أيش قالوا؟
لما صار الاستعمار في القرن التاسع عشر
شوف كل الحديث عن القرن الأول والقرن العشرين والتاسع عشر
كله نفس الحديث
اللي بيدرس وبيفكر أن هذا كتاب مختص في القرن الأول
ما له علاقة بالقرن العشرين
ولكن إذا بتتطلّع عليه، هذا كله خطاب واحد
بيجي واحد مثل «شاخت» يعد عميد الدراسات الشرعية الإسلامية في الغرب
أيش بيقول؟
أنتوا يا مسلمين عانيتوا من قرون تجمدت ومتجمدة، وأنتو لسّه في مأزق
في القرن التاسع عشر هذا الكلام، وأول القرن العشرين
والقانون الخاص بكم فشل، الشريعة الخاصة بكم فشلت
فأنتوا ما بتسوّون شيء مو مألوف لكم
أنتوا لما نشأتوا أصلًا، أنتوا استقرضتوا القانون الغربي
اليوناني والروماني وإلى آخره
طيب اعملوا نفس الشيء
لأن أيش بيقولوا المستشرقين؟
أن المسلمين أخذوا كل هذه القوانين الغربية اللي هي أصلًا أوربية
نلاحظ مثلًا الفارسي لا يدخل هنا
مع أن الفرس أثّروا على الإسلام كثير، ولكن لا يدخل
لأن كل هذا شغل استشراق، فكله لازم يكون أوربي
أخذتوا كل هذه الشغلات، وبعدين أيش سويتوا أنتوا؟
غطيتوه في أحاديث كاذبة، وفي القرآن
فمثلًا النظرية الاستشراقية حتى حديثًا
تقول أن القرآن أتى ليمضي على الشريعة
كأنك تمضي على العقد
يمضي على الشريعة فقط حوالي الـ 100 هجرية
يعني القرآن لم يكن له تأثير على الإسلام أول قرن
هو أتى لاحقًا بس عشان يكون الغطاء
يسموه «الفينير» في الإنقليزي، يستعملوها كثير المستشرقين
أيش هو «الفينير»؟
هو لما تجيب خشب تعمل منه طاولة
بيكون خشب مكبوس
وخشب من نوعية عاطلة، فأيش تسوي؟
بتحط عليه
طبقة
طبقة مأخوذة من شجرة طبيعية مقصوصة ملي متر واحد
طبيعي وبتلزقه عليه، فلما تلزقه الطاولة بتبيّن أيش؟
أنها كأنها من خشب طبيعي كلها
فهذا اللي المسلمين بحسب الاستشراق، عملوه
جابوا القرآن وخلقوا الحديث
عشان كذا النظرية الكبيرة في الاستشراق
هو أن الحديث النبوي كله مخلوق وتدليس
وهو مشروع تدليس كبير
يعني لما تقرأ الاستشراق أنت تستنتج شيء واحد
أن المستشرقين بشكل أدبي وبشكل أكاديمي
بيقولوا أن هذول المسلمين أكبر كذابين في الدنيا
كل حضارتهم مبنية على كذب في كذب
لأنهم خلقوا كل الأحاديث النبوية، تقريبًا 5,000 حديث حسن
ومستعمل وله فعالية في إنشاء الشريعة
وتقريبًا 700 ألف واحد ثاني
اللي لا تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار بشكل جدي
على الأقل في الشريعة
هذا كله وحتى الحسن، كذب
فهو فيه عندهم شعار
كل حديث هو مفبرك حتى نثبت العكس
قد أقام هذا الشعار «قولد تسيهر»
وهو مستشرق نمساوي يهودي
وأُكمل من بعده العديد من الكبار مثل «سنوك هورخرونيه» اللي هو هولندي
وبالأساس «شاخت» اللي هو ألماني
فهذا القانون الخاص بهم
أن كل حديث هو زائف حتى يثبت العكس
هذه النظرة الاستشراقية لتكوّن الشريعة
في القرن العشرين قالوا اسمع
ما أنتوا عملتوها قبل، اعملوها الحين
خذوا القوانين الأوربية وقولوا أنها إسلامية يا عمي
غطّوها مثل ما تبغوا
قولوا أن الشورى هي الديمقراطية
والديمقراطية، بالضبط زي ما إحنا ودنا إياها
فتصير الشورى ديمقراطية
وبما أن الشورى لها أساس في الخطاب السياسي الإسلامي القديم
فيصبح الخطاب هذا منطبق على الليبرالية الجديدة
هذا الخطاب الأكاديمي الغربي؟
هذا الخطاب...
أكاديمي؟
أيوه، وإذا ودك أعطيك بعض المراجع
هذه النظرة الاستشراقية
بس أيش صار في الحقيقة؟ يختلف تمامًا
أعطني
أول شيء إذا بتقرأ...
مثل ما كل واحد عنده عقل موزون
وغير مبرمج وغير مهدّف كالعقل الاستعماري
إذا نقرأ المصادر الإسلامية نعرف
أن القرآن الكريم من أول يوم نزل
كان له تأثيرًا شديدًا على المسلمين، ليس له أي نظير
حتى في التاريخ البشري
أنا لا أعرف كتابًا واحدًا أثّر على عقول الناس كالقرآن
هذا هو أول شيء
بعدين كما أُثبت حديثًا
من بعد ما الصحابة بدأوا يتوفوا
على طول بدأوا المسلمين يقولوا
إحنا أيش لازم نسوي في هذه الحالة؟
وقعت عندنا مسألة، طيب كيف نبغى نحل المسألة؟
أيش يقول القرآن؟
فبدأت من الأول
بس هذا كله يبغى له دراسة
القرآن هو ليس شريعة، القرآن هو كتاب هداية
ولكن الشريعة شيء، كما أصبحت لاحقًا، والقرآن شيء ثاني
القرآن هو أساس وأساس الشريعة، وأساس كل شيء
والشريعة ما هي؟
الشريعة هي التفسير اللغوي
كما هو المشروع الكبير الذي قام به «ابن إدريس الشافعي» رحمه الله
مشروع ابن إدريس الشافعي كان بس مشروع لغوي شرعي محض
يعني الرسالة خاصّته...
وطبعًا في كتاب «الأم» أيضًا شوي
ولكن في الرسالة خاصّته بالأساس
هي مشروع أنه كيف نفهم ما يريد الله لنا؟
وكيف نفهم ذلك؟
نريد إشارات ودلائل وإلى آخره
نريد الحبل لنمسك به لكي نجرّه
ونصل لأحسن طريقة اللي ممكن توصلنا لمعرفة ما يريد الله منا
وهو أيش؟
هو تقليد الله في حكمته
أنت سألت واحد من ضيوفك
أنا شفت لك هذا البرنامج
أنه أيش الفرق بين العلم الإسلامي و...؟
العلم الإسلامي كله...
إذا كانوا المسلمين لما درسوا الفلك
أو درسوا الرياضيات، أو لما ابن الهيثم درس العين
وكل شيء...
والشريعة
كله كان محاولة لفهم كيف يشتغل عقل الله؟
لأن لما خلق الله الدنيا
خلقها بالعدل والحكمة
عدل
فكل الهدف هو أن نفهم كيف وما هو عدل الله؟
حتى لما ندرس الكواكب
إحنا ندرس مو عشان نحتلها، مثل ما الآن نسوّي
بنروح عشان نلاقي كوكب نستبدله
مثل علبة الكوكاكولا بتشربها وترميها
إحنا بنسوي في الأرض، مثل ما بنسوي في علبة الكوكاكولا
تشربها وترميها من غير مسؤولية، من غير نظرة
من غير إحساس في أن أنت جالس تدمر الأرض
ومبسوط أنت على حالك
ونفس الشيء بنسويه في الكواكب
أيش هدف علماء الهيئة اليوم؟
هو أنه يلاقوا كوكب مثل الأرض
ويدوروا، ويقول لك أحسن حل له
أن نلقى كوكب بعيد عن الشمس
نفس المسافة اللي إحنا بعيدين فيها عن الشمس
فهناك تمتلئ الشروط أو تتكون الشروط اللازمة
أن نحن نقدر نعيش عليها
اتطلّع على الحكمة هذه، ليش؟
هو ما في شيء، إذا ودك تلقى كوكب ثاني بالتوفّيق
بنلاقي كوكب ثاني ما فيه شيء غلط فيه بحد ذاته
ولكن هم ودهم يلاقوا كوكب ثاني
عشان هذا الكوكب إحنا بندمره زي ما شايفين
صحيح
شايفينه كل يوم
عشان الأغنياء والأقوياء يحطوا حالهم بسفينة
ويطلعوا يعيشوا كملوك هناك
والباقيين يبقون هنا، ويعانوا
من التدميرات اللي صارت لهم
وهذه حقيقةً هم يشتغلون على هذا المشروع
هذا اللي بيصير
اللي هو إلى المريخ
طبعًا
فهذا الفرق بين هذا الفرق بين العلم
طبعًا، الفرق العلم الإسلامي يختلف تمامًا بفلسفته عن العلوم الحديثة
مع أنه كان متفوق في العالم عن كل الحضارات الأخرى
ومع أنه حتى ضاهى العلم الغربي حتى القرن الثامن عشر
الرياضيات والعلوم الفلكية والعين والدورة الدموية
حتى بداية القرن الثامن عشر
كان الأطباء المسلمين يضحكوا على الأوربيين
لما يشوفوهم كيف بيشتغلوا
يقولك أيش هذول يسوّون؟ هذول بعدهم عايشين في قرون...
والله عجيب
وإحنا بنبحث ليش صار فيه علم جديد وقوي في الغرب
في آخر القرن الثامن عشر والتاسع عشر
لأن ماله علاقة في التقدم الحضاري، ولا شيء
مطلقًا
أبدًا؟
إطلاقًا، بالعكس، له علاقة تامة بالتدمير والقتل
لا إله إلا الله
تاريخ الطب مثلًا هو تاريخ عنف من بدايته
أنت تشتغل على الكمبيوتر، مو هذا اللي بيدك كمبيوتر؟
إيه
أنت عارف من وين جاء هذا؟
هذا جاء من الحرب اللي قامت بين ألمانيا والحلف الغربي الأوربي
على الكمبيوتر، عشان يحلوا مشكلة أن الألمان
كانوا يعطوا تعليمات لغواصاتهم حتى تضرب السفن اللي جاية من أمريكا
عشان تساعد البريطانيين ضد الألمان
كانوا يضربونها، ومو قادرين البريطانيين يحلوا لغز هذه الإرشادات
عشان يقدروا يقاوموها
عشان يحولوا سفنهم لطريق ثاني
أو يروحوا يحاربوا الغواصات وإلى آخره
فخلقوا الكمبيوتر اللي إحنا اليوم نستعمله
اللي أنا وأنت والكل بنستعمله
خلقوه عشان الشغلة هذه
عشان يقدروا يفوزوا في الحرب ضد الألمان
بس وين المشكلة؟
إذا كانت فيه حاجه تطلبت اختراع
وصار اختراع اليوم مفيد لجوانب ثانية؟
المشكلة أنه يصبح...
سؤال جيد جدًّا
يصبح الاختراع العلمي والتطور العلمي
يصبح هدفه ليس خدمة الإنسان...
لأن تاريخه عنف
فمعناته مربوط بأشياء ثانية إحنا مو شايفينها
فمثلًا لما أقول لك أنا أن كل التطعيم
أول تطعيمات في التاريخ البشري، التطعيمات الصناعية
لأن تعرف أنت الهنود الأمريكان كان عندهم تطعيمات نباتية
ولكنها تختلف وليست فعّالة مثل اليوم، وإنما كان عندهم
ولكن التطعيمات اللي مثل ضد التيفوئيد
والكوليرا والتيتانوس وكل هذا
أنت عارف من وين جاء؟
هذا كله اختُرع بأوربا عشان يقدروا يبعثوا جنودهم
لنهر «النيجر» في أفريقيا
لأن نهر النيجر كان الطريقة الوحيدة اللي يقدروا منه يحتلوا أفريقيا
مو قادرين يحتلوها
لأنه كانوا يبعثوا سفنهم جنودهم
وبخلال جمعة أو جمعتين، كلهم يموتوا من الأمراض
المنقولة من القارص والذباب وإلى آخره
من التيفوئيد وإلى آخره
فلقوا له هذا الحل، اللي هو التطعيم
أيش معناته هذا؟
معناته أنه إذا ودك تبحث...
أنت اكتشفت شيء واحد
هل كنت تعرف قبل أن تاريخ الطب مرتبط مع العنف بهذا القد؟
قليل اللي يعرفوا
وحتى اللقاحات، بحط رابط في وصف الحلقة
لفيديو يشرح بعض اللي حصل
أن أصلًا حتى كانت التجارب وتتم على الناس في أفريقيا، وبالعنف
بالضبط، ودك تبحث أيش علاقة الطب بالاقتصاد مثلًا
لأن الاستعمار لم يكن كذا، لوجه الله
بس نبغى نروح نستعمر، لا كان الهدف الأساسي والأول، في البداية
أن يأخذوا ثروات الشعوب الأخرى
فراحوا سرقوا كل الذهب والفضة من أمريكا الجنوبية بالأساس
ولكن الشمالية أيضًا، جابوه على أوربا
واستغنوا، وسوّوا الكثير بها
راحوا على الهند سرقوا كل البهارات الخاصة بها
والذهب أيضًا، والأحجار الكريمة مثل الياقوت وإلى آخره
كانت الهند مليانة فيها
راحوا على مصر سرقوها
نحن نعرف القصة هذه
ولكن لا نعرف أن الطب مثلًا والذي نفتخر فيه اليوم
أنه كيف اليوم الكل عنده علاج بفضل الطب الحديث وكذا
هذا كله مربوط تام بتاريخ الرأسمالية
اللي هي قسم كبير من تاريخ الاستعمار
اللي هي قسم كبير من تاريخ العنف
وبناء أسلحة مدمرة لم تُعرف من قبل
وقسم من العقلية الأوربية التي تشتغل بهذه الطريقة
أنا كتبت كتاب سميته «قصور الاستشراق»
فأنا هناك أدّعي أن ليست هناك حقيقة أُنتجت من اليد البشرية
مثل الحديقة المركزية في نيويورك
هذا شغل... ما في شجرة هنا إلا مزروعة اصطناعيًا
يعني ما في شجرة أبقوها من قبل
هذا خلق إنساني
ليس هناك أي خلق إنساني إلا ما يفرضه العقل علينا
بمعنى أنه إذا كان إحنا عملنا شيء؛ فهذا نتيجة كيف نفكر
فالتفكير الخاص بنا هو أهم شيء
يعني لما أنت تفكر بطريقة، بتعمله
صح
مثلًا السكين في المطبخ تعطيه لطباخ جيّد وشريف
بينتج لك أحلى طبخة، وبيحط لك إياها
وبيستقبلك أحلى استقبال، ومثل أخوك هو، ومحب وإلى آخره
هذا بيده كان مسكين
أعطيه لواحد سارق، ودّه يسرق بيتك
بيقتلك ويسرق بيتك ويطلع
صح
أعطيه لمجرم، نعرف أيش...
فالسكين مو مهم هنا، هو مجرد أداة
اللي يقرر كيف السكين يُستعمل هو العقل وطريقة التفكير
فأوربا كل تفكيرها من بداية تاريخها
مع أنه طويل ومعقد، يرجع حتى إلى العصور البربرية
عندما نزحت هذه الطوائف والقبائل البربرية
من شمال أوربا إلى أسبانيا وألمانيا
ولاحقًا سُميّ بالفيزكوتس والجيرمانيين والفرنكيين
هذول كلهم من الشعوب الشمالية
هذول غزوا أوربا وملأوا أوربا بالناس
وكان لهم طريقة تفكير معينة
مثلًا إلههم، كان إله حرب
بس هل انتهت أو إلى الآن؟
هذا تفكيرهم إلى الآن؟
لا، أخذت تتطور وتأخذ أشكالًا مختلفة
ولكن المضمون بشكل كبير بقي نفسه
عشان كذا بتلاحظ مثلًا الصينيين كان عندهم البارود
من 1500 سنة، وأول ناس اخترعوا البندقية هم الصينيين
وأول ناس اللي حشوا البارود في البندقية هم الصينيين
طيب ليش الصينيين ما احتلوا العالم؟
في 1422 بنوا أسطول 1000 سفينة
يخوفوا
كل واحدة كانت بحجم أربع أو خمس سفن أوربية في هذاك الوقت
راحوا على أفريقيا
وزاروا أفريقيا، وحاربوا بعض المجرمين في البحر «البايرتس»
ولمّوا النباتات، وجابوا ممثلين عن السلاطين والملوك معهم
عشان ودهم يقدموهم للإمبراطور الصيني، ورجعوا
رجعوا بالفيول والزرافات والحيوانات الجميلة
والنباتات الحلوة وبعض السفراء من الدول
ورجعوا فيها، وحطوا الأسطول تبعهم في موانئ الصين، وعفّنت
أوربا أيش عملت؟
اكتشفت البارود الصيني
واكتشفت أن فيه طريقة لعمل مدفع
على طول من غير تأخر
بدأوا يبنوا، وبنوا أكثر سفن قاتلة في التاريخ البشري
سفن نسبيًا صغيرة، تحمل مدافع تحت
تطلق بشكل ممكن تعمل خزق، ثغرة، في سفينة كبيرة وتغرقها
فأصبح لا المسلمين ولا الصينيين ولا أي أحد
لما نزلوا على المحيط الهندي
البرتغاليين والأسبانيين لما نزلوا ما قدر أحد يقاومهم
عشان كذا سيطروا على البحر الهندي
وتغيّر فيه نمط التجارة تغيّر تمامًا
كان نمط التجارة سائد بين المسلمين والصينيين والهنود وشعوب أخرى
ويتعاملوا بالمناسبة في أغلب الأعراف كانت حسب الشريعة
حتى الصينيين كانوا يتبعون قانون البحر حسب اللي الشريعة فرضته
مو لأنهم شعروا...
لأنه كان موجود، وكان المتعارف عليه فأخذوه واستعملوه
فهذا كله تقطّع
وأصبح البرتغاليون يقولون إذا ودك تمر من هنا؛ لابد تدفع لنا فلوس
وربما إذا كنت أنت حامل ذهب أو شيء
فلوس أو مو فلوس، بنأخذك وبنأخذ ذهبك
أنت للأسر، وذهبك بنأخذه
بنبي فيه قصور في البرتغال وفرنسا وإنقلترا
بس المسلمين نفس الشيء كان عندهم رغبة توسعية
وتوسعوا من الجزيرة العربية إلى أقصى...
فصار حتى «هارون الرشيد» لمّا رأى الغيمة قال
«أمطري حيث شئتِ فإن خراجك لي»
صحيح، الاحتلال كذا، ولكن فيه حدود
إذا تبغى نبحثها بالذات بعد القرن السابع عشر، نبحث ليش صارت كذا؟
وهذه أوربا كانت الاستثناء في التاريخ البشري
هذا اللي لازم نفهمه إحنا
إحنا صرنا عايشين كمجتمع أو مجتمعات
متماسكة وسياسية
يعني كان عندنا المدن الصغيرة اللي هي كانت المدن الدول من 7000 سنة
وإحنا تاريخنا اليوم
تقدر تقول أن تدوين التاريخ اللي نعرفه، بشكل أو بآخر
كثير أو قليل، ولكن نعرف شيء عنه أو نعرف كثير عنه
توقف وين ومتى
أنه يرجع إلى 5000 أو 6000 سنة
في التاريخ البشري هذا المدون اللي بنعرف عنه
الاستثناء الوحيد في هذا التاريخ هو أوربا
فإذا كان فيه عندك رسم بياني
تبدأ من القُرنة وتطلع فيه كذا على البسيط
يعني فوق الخط الأسفل
بعدين ما تشوف إلا فيه قفزة
تقريبًا 2% من طول الخط
ولكن إلى فوق أو إلى تحت
يتوقف كيف أنت تشوف التاريخ الأوربي
إذا كنت تشوفه بطريقة «وائل حلاق» معناته إلى تحت
إذا بتشوفه حسب الناس اللي باعوا روحهم وعقلهم للاستعمار
بيكون إلى فوق
فبرضه بنعرف ليش صار تحت بالنسبة لوائل
لأن أغلب الناس تراه للأعلى
فهذه الحلقة فيها استطرادات، والاستطرادت هنا رائعة
بترك الاستطراد
نقدر نرجع إذا ودَّك
إيه، أنا برجع إلى تطوّر الشريعة
ودي تمشي إلى تطور الشريعة، كيف تطورت الشريعة؟
حلو. شكرًا على الإرجاع
لا، ما عليك
أنا أستطيع أن أقول أن أكبر فعل وأهم فعل
حدث في تاريخ الإسلام لإقامة الشريعة
هو كان في عصر عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه
عمر لعب دور مخيف في إنشاء الإسلام، ليش؟
طبعًا هو أنشأ الدواوين وإلى آخره
ولكن الدواوين كانت نصها فارسية أصلًا
ولكن حطها وبذكاء خارق، حطها واستعملها بشكل ذكي
طبعًا هذا واضح. ولكن أيش عمل؟
من البداية قال أن في كل محل فيه تجمع إسلامي
وعادةً كانت هذه القبائل اللي راحوا للغزو
والقبائل كانت تتناوش من بعضها
فلما وصلوا مثلًا في العراق، أو حتى في مصر في الفسطاط
أصبح بنو فلان يتناوشوا مع بنو فلان
لأن كلهم احتلوا مصر
ولكن بس قعدوا بدأوا يختلفوا على مسائل
لأن جابوا معهم تاريخ قبلي من الجزيرة
فبدأوا يختلفوا مع بعض
طيب هذا عمر ما يبغاه، إحنا ودّنا نحتل البلاد
ودّنا نعمل دولة، نعمل إمبراطورية
فأيش سوّى؟
قال في كل محل فيه تجمع إسلامي، بتبني مسجد حالًا
بس أيش معناته المسجد؟
إحنا بنقول مسجد
بنسمع في التاريخ ونقرأ في التاريخ
«وقد بنى المساجد في الثغور»
«بنى المساجد في الثغور»
بس أيش معناته هذا؟
المسجد مو مبنى بس
أول ما تبدأ في المسجد، هو المبنى
هذه أول خطوة صغيرة، بس أيش يصير في المسجد؟
أيش الممارسات في المسجد؟
صار مسجد فيه إمام ومؤذن
على المصغر، ولكنه كان موجود
وأصبحوا يقرأون القصص
والقصص كان فيها الكثير فيها من الأحاديث النبوية
وكيف أن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يتصرف
ويعمل ولا يعمل، ينهى ولا ينهي
وكثير من الآثار
ماهي الآثار؟
هي الأقوال واللغة التي تكون لنا كنوع من المصدر لتصرفاتنا
أو عِبرة حتى
وما هي العِبرة؟ العِبرة هي أيضًا تقود التصرف
لذلك تسمى عِبرة
فلما بنى هذه المساجد
وهذا إحنا بنحكي فقط في خلال عشر سنوات
أو خمس عشرة سنة بعد وفاة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
بدأ الناس يروحوا على المساجد
بس هذول اللي راحوا المساجد المحتلين
القادة تبعهم كانوا مسلمين على الآخر، بدون شك
كانوا مخلصين للقضية. ولكن القبائل اللي ارتدت، قبل عشر سنوات بس
أبو بكر قبل عمر كان يحارب فيهم
هذول أيضًا اشتركوا في الفتوحات
فهذول كان عندهم نصف قلب في الإسلام
ما كانوا كلهم...
يعني نفترض أن هذول كل المسلمين
اللي فتحوا...
على مستوى الشخص العادي
كلهم كانوا فاهمين أيش الإسلام بالضبط
فيه منهم كانوا بس ودهم...
بس أغلبهم، والقيادة، كانت كلها صافية
عشان كذا فتحوا
كان يروحوا 2000 واحد، يكسروا 20 ألف من العدو
لأنهم كانوا ملتزمين بالقضية
ولكن أيش عملوا هذول؟ هذول كان عندهم أولاد
فبعثوا أولادهم للمسجد
وهذا الجيل، جيل الأولاد، أولاد الذين فتحوا الأراضي اللي فتحها الإسلام
هو الجيل اللي بدأ ينتج الناس اللي عندهم
ليس فقط إيمان في الإسلام
ولكن عندهم التزام بما يتطلبه الإسلام
كحضارة ومفهوم شخصي واجتماعي
الإسلام ليس فقط «أشهد أن لا إله إلا الله وأن محمد رسول الله»
هذه ما تكفي لحالها، هذا ما تخلّيك مسلم صحيح
هي بتقدمك للإسلام، بتدخلك على الإسلام
ولكن لما أنت بتدخل على باب الدار
ما بتوقف عند الباب وخلاص بتقول أنا هنا وما أبغى...
أنا هنا مكاني
لا، لازم تدخل وتشوف أيش...
ولما تعيش في البيت كفاية، بيصير قسم منك
فالإسلام هو أيضًا تكوين ذاتية
عزيزي لازم نفهم شي واحد
أنه ليس هناك فهم لأي ظاهرة اليوم
إن كانت ظاهرة لها علاقة في التكوين الإنساني
إلا أنها ترجع إلى تكوين الذات
فيجب أن نفهم من نحن؟ ومن هم؟
فمثلًا ليش برنامجك أنت ناجح كذا؟
أنا صار لي أفكر في الموضوع كم أسبوع
لو باخذك من البرنامج، لا سمح الله، وأحط واحد ثاني
البرنامج بيتحول تمامًا، ليش؟
لأن ذاتيتك، طريقة تفكيرك، طريقة سؤالك للضيف
طريقة معاملتك للضيف
طريقة كيف بتستجلب كل هذا
أحيانًا صعب فهم أيش بالضبط يدخل في تكوين الذات
ولكن كله مع بعض نجاح هائل والحمدلله
فالذاتية إحنا نقول عنها: والله أنا مو مرتاح معه أبغى واحد ثاني
بس أيش معناته، ليش؟
لأن أنت مو مرتاح مع الشخص بس لأنه كذا
لا، أنت مو مرتاح مع ذاتيته
الذاتية هي كل شيء
هناك كان فيه ذاتية إسلامية
هذول القبائل اللي اشتركت في الفتوحات
ذاتيتهم ما كانت إسلامية محضة
ولكن بس خُلق جيل الأول ونشأ في المساجد
بدأت الذاتية الإسلامية تتكون بالشكل، كأنه تقريبًا كل شيء موجود هناك
فتلاحظ فيه كان...
وين نشأ الفقه؟
هذه حقيقة لا نستطيع أن نقول أنها أقل من حقيقة أهرامية
كيف الأهرام في مصر تقف شامخة وعالية
من أهم الحقائق
لأن الفقه والقانون
لم يكن هناك قانون، ولكن الفقه والشريعة، ما نسميه القانون
قانون الجهاز السياسي وقانون الجهاز الاجتماعي
خُلق تمامًا من قِبل أفراد بسطاء في المجتمع
حتى أحيانًا فقراء. ولم يُخلق من...
يعني لما كان القاضي في مصر أو في دمشق
كان يحكُم بين الناس، أو يحكّم مرات بين الناس
كانت تستعصي عليه مرات قضايا معينة
فكان يكتب، مثلًا خلينا نقول، لعمر
يقول له يا عمي أنا استعصت عليّ هذه المشكلة، ارشدني
فأيش يقول له عمر أغلب الأحيان؟
يقول له اجتهد برأيك
طيب ممكن أنا اليوم مو عارف أيش القانون
وأكتب لمكتب قانوني في الدولة، وهو يجي يقولي اجتهد برأيك؟
اليوم؟
الدولة عندها القانون، ودائمًا عندها قانون
وهي اللي بتحط القانون، ولا واحد ثاني يقدر يتحدّاها
الخليفة لم يشرّع
عمر مثلًا كان عنده مواقف شرعية
لأنه كان صحابي، مو لأنه كان خليفة
أيش الفرق؟
الصحابي وهو يتكلم بما يعرفه عن...
كفقيه؟
كفقيه
بما يعرفه عن كيف كان ممكن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يحل المشكلة
فيقول لك أنا صحابي
أيش معنى صحابي؟ أنه أنا صاحبت الرسول
وصحابة الرسول هي ليست فقط مسألة اجتماعية
هذا اللي إحنا بنفكر فيه دائمًا أن المسألة اجتماعية
في الإسلام الصحابة وصحابة الرسول
هي مسألة ابستمولوجية محضة، ليه؟
الصحابي معناته أنه يعرف عمّا يريده الرسول
والرسول يعرف ما يريده الله
بشكل أقرب من أي إنسان آخر
أو أي إنسان وأي قوة إلهية أخرى
فعمر كان صحابي، وكان ابن مسعود وإلى آخره
ابن مسعود يمكن كان أكثر حتى من عمر
لأن ابن مسعود كان من أكبر القانونيين
إذا ممكن يصح التعبير اليوم «قانوني»
أكبر القانونيين في تاريخ الإسلام في الأول
هذول كيف كانوا؟ ليش كانوا؟
لأنهم كانوا قريبين من الرسول
لدرجة أنهم يكادون أن يعرفوا ما عرفه الرسول
هي المسألة مسألة معرفة
بس مو مسألة أني قعدت مع الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشربت قهوة، وكنت أصحاب أنا وإياه
طبعًا مثلًا عمر وأبوبكر كان يروحوا مع الرسول ويفطروا مع بعض
ويزوروا حتى المدارس اليهودية ويسمعوا
كان مفتوحين، وكانوا يعملوا أشياء كثيرة مع بعض
بس هذا بحد ذاته هي مو علاقة اجتماعية هي علاقة ابستمولوجيه
فهذول الجيل الجديد اللي طلع على المساجد وتعليم المساجد
وما كان يحدث في المساجد، هم كانوا الفقهاء
فالفقه أصبح في يد الناس، وليس في يد الساسة
ومن هنا نبدأ نفهم الفرق الشاسع
بين مفهوم التركيبة السياسية الإسلامية
والتركيبة السياسية الغربية اليوم
فمثلًا واحد يكون عنده مشكلة
يروح وده يستشير أحد في...
يروح لناس عاديين اللي تخصصوا في الفقه
ومثلًا تلقى قصص أخرى
مثلًا واحد بيّاع جلود، تعرف أحذية أو ثياب
بتلاقيه قاعد قدام دكانه في السوق، ويعلّم طلّاب الفقه
نحكي عن 80 هجرية
80 هجرية
في دائرة «حَلَقة» وبيعلمهم الفقه
فبتلاقيه قُطع عليه درسه
لأن جاء واحد وده يشتري حزام من جلد
فقام الأستاذ باع الحزام، وأخذ الفلوس
ورجع وقعد في الحلقة وكمل درسه
هذه في المدينة أو في كل المدن؟
هذه القصة إما من البصرة أو الكوفة، لا أذكر
لأنهم كانوا من مراكز الأساس الأولى لنشأة الفقه
فبدأ في الأول تشكيل الفقه
وهو إجابة سؤال ماذا نفعل في هذه الأحوال؟
أتى من هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين هم من المتوسط الاجتماعي
لم يكونوا قيادة عسكرية أو سياسية
وإنما كانوا ناس مثلهم مثلك، زي ما بيقولوا
يعني ناس تجار صغار، أو تجار كبار يمكن مرات
يعني ناس عاديين، اللي عندهم حياة عادية
طيب تسمح لي أستفسر في نقطة؟
تفضل
مثلًا قد يكون...
لكن في الأخير برضه هذا إذا استشكل عليه أمر
أو أحد منهم صار يفتي خلاف ما بيتفق عليه مثلًا الإسلام
فيه أحد بيرده، صح؟
يتوقف...
في أحد يوقفه ويقوله أن اللي تسويه غلط
طبعًا كان فيه جدالات على الأقوال
لأن هذا قول، هو لما يطلع في قول، هو مجرد قول
ممتاز
وتلقى الوالي معين من عمر بن الخطاب
والي العراق أو والي...
صح؟
لا
هو من أرسله وقال له أنت تكون هناك
قاضي
قاضي، أيوه طبعًا
فأنا عينته كدولة
لا نخليها كدولة، وإنما كحاكم
أنت قبل شوي كنت تقول
أن هذي تصير من الناس، من البسطاء
بينما تجد في حقيقة الأمر أن القائد
خليفة المسلمين، أمير المؤمنين، سمّه ما شئت
هو من عيّن الوالي، القاضي
صح، هذا شيء، واللي بحكي عنه شيء ثاني، يختلف تمامًا
قول لي
طبعًا القضاة هم قسم من الجهاز القضائي
المسؤول عنه هو الخليفة في البداية
وبعدين السلطان في القرون اللاحقة
هذا طبعًا القاضي لازم يكون عنده خبرة وحنكة في أشياء كثيرة
بما فيه قراءة العادات الاجتماعية مو بس قانون
لازم يعرف في الشريعة ويعرف في كثير من الأشياء
ولكن نتفرض أن هذا القاضي عُيّن من بعد ما تدرّب
يعني أحد علمه كيف يسوي هذه الشغلات، صحيح؟
بس كيف نشأ الفقه؟ هذا شيء ثاني
كيف كُتب الفقه في كتبه؟
ما له علاقة في القضاء مباشرةً
يعني كان علاقة بمعنى
أنه مرات اللي كان يكتب كان قاضي، بس مرات لا
مثلًا إحنا نعرف أن فيه بعض الفقهاء رفضوا أن يشتغلوا في سلك القضاء
رفض عن مبدأ
وكانوا محدودين، حددوا نفسهم للتصنيف، كتابة الكتب
والتعليم كشيوخ في المدارس
هي بالأساس تعليم الفقه والإفتاء
فعندك أنت أربع وظائف في القضاء مهمة جدًّا
هي القضاء والإفتاء والتصنيف، كتابة الكتب، لها أيضًا فن خاص
والمشيخة وهي تعليم الجيل الجديد
ففيه كثير منهم رفضوا أن يصيروا قضاة
والدولة آنذاك لها ارتباط بالقضاء فقط، أما الإفتاء والتعليم...
ماذا يطبق القاضي؟
يطبّق القاضي الفقه الذي أنتجه بعض
ما يسموا بأصحاب الإيمان الأوائل
لأن هي بدأت المسألة في الإيمان
أن آمنوا في الإسلام بشكل أن دخلوا فيه روحًا وجسدًا
وهذا السبب: أن دخلوا فيه روحًا وجسدًا
جعلهم يتساءلوا طيب إحنا لما نبغى نأكل ونشرب
إذا وقع الفأر في الزيت أو...
طيب أيش نسوي فيها هذه؟
فبدأوا يحاولوا يلاقوا حلول لهذه وقدموا
قال أنا بفكر أنه كذا
أنا فقيه لنفسي، فأنا أمارس ما أفكره حسب اجتهادي أنا
فإذا ودك تاخذه خذه، وإذا ما ودّك مع السلامة. حر أنت بحالك
وجاء فقيه ثاني وعمل نفس الشيء
وبديت تتكون مثل ما تقول المدارس الفقهية
التي أصبحت لاحقًا تُسمى بالمذاهب
ولكن المهم جدًّا هنا أن نفهم
طبعًا كان فيه...
وأنا بسترد أنا الخطاب الاستشراقي اللي حكينا عنه قبل شوي
لما احتلوا الأراضي الشامية والفارسية
كان هناك بالأساس حضارة في سوريا، حضارة بيزنطية
في الشرق كانت الفارسية
طبعًا كانت موجود هناك وكانت مؤثره جدًّا
ولكن هذول المؤمنين الجدد
أخذوا أيش ودهم، ورفضوا اللي ما ودهم
لم يكونوا مثل المستعمرين اليوم في العالم الإسلامي وغيره
أن يأخذوه على اضطرار
كانوا يأخذوه من موقف قوة
في عهد الخلافة الراشدة كان أكثر المؤثرين على الشريعة هم الفقهاء؟
في عهد الرسول؟
في عهد الخلافة
في عهد الخلافة الأولى الراشدة؟
إيه في عهد أبوبكر وعمر
في عهد أبوبكر وعمر كان الفقه لم ينشأ بعد
يعني كانت بعض المؤسسات مثل الدواوين
نحن نعرف الدواوين قسم من الفقه
يعني مضبوط دخلت على الإسلام من بلاد فارس بشكل كبير
وليس كليًّا، لأن الدواوين تطورت لاحقًا
وأصبح هناك فيها أشياء لم يعرفها الفرس من قبل
ولكن في البداية في عصر عمر
كانت فارسية أغلبها
وأصبحت في الآخر قسم من المواصفات الفقهية
مثلًا إذا بتشوف كل كتب الأحكام السلطانية، مثل تبعت «الماوردي»
و «أبو يعلى ابن الفراء» ولاحقًا «ابن جماعة» و«ابن تيمية»
كلهم يحكوا عن الدواوين كقسم من مواصفات الشريعة
ولكن لم يكن هناك بعد الجيل اللي أنا أحكي عنه
كانوا باقي يحاولوا يلاقوا طريقهم
فجيل الفقهاء بدأ بالأساس تحت الفترة الأولى في الدولة الأموية
قبل لا أوصل للدولة الأموية
بالنسبة للمستشرقين، ما تشوف أن من الممكن أنك تفهم
وأنه عادي أصلًا أنك تأخذ من هذه الحضارات لتشكل تشريعك الطبيعي
فمثلًا الدواوين من فارس أو غيرها
اللي أخذتها من حضارات ثانية
فوين الإشكال؟ فممكن معهم حق؟
بدون شك، المسلمين كانوا من أمهر الشعوب
أن يفتحوا عقلهم لكل جيرانهم
فدخلوا في الهند، واستجلبوا من الهند كثير
استجلبوا من فارس ومن اليونان
على الشريعة؟
على كل شيء
ليش بقول كل شيء؟
لأن لما بتقول شريعة أيضًا
معناته الشريعة فيها أصول الفقه، صحيح؟
طيب أصول الفقه فيها منطق، صحيح؟
طيب «أرسطو طاليس» ومنطقه دخلوا في أصول الفقه
معناته دخل في الشريعة
وكان في نفس الوقت الكلام فيه منطق، وكذا وكذا
فتقسيم العلوم في الإسلام هي كثيرًا تكون تقسيمات مصطنعة
لأن العلوم الإسلامية مترابطة بشكل هائل جدًّا
لدرجه أن لما تطور علم شكل كبير
وآخر بشكل آخر
يصبحان كجذور شجرتين جنب بعض
يتداخلان ويصيروا يأخذوا من نفس الأرض
ويصيروا يحكوا مع بعض أيضًا
نحن نعرف أن الشجر يتكلم مع بعضه تحت الأرض
نفس الشيء
فالإسلام
ما كان عنده حرج من هذا؟
لا، ليه؟
لأنه كان يأخذ من موقف قوة
بأخذ أيش أبغى
الإسلام كان، خلينا نقول
باصطلاح اليوم، إذا صح، الدولة الإمبريالية
فيأخذوا اللي ودهم، ويرفضوا اللي ما ودهم
ومرات واحد ياخذ والثاني لا
مثلًا كان الغزالي وابن حزم دخّلوا المنطق
بالمناسبة ابن حزم بدأ في المشروع قبل الغزالي
على عكس المفهوم السائد اليوم
ولكن الغزالي كان له أكبر تأثير بدون شك
ولكن من ناحية تاريخية وأسبقية ابن حزم بدأ قبل الغزالي
فلما الغزالي أدخل المنطق
جاء «ابن تيمية» قال له استنى شوي، فيه مشاكل
ما بتصور أنك أنت فاهم أيش تسوي 100%
أنت عبقري بدون شك، ولكن فيه مشاكل
مشاكل في المنطق
أنت بتفكر أن المنطق بريء، بأنه مجرد أداة تفكيرية
بس لا، المنطق معقد كثير
وبالآخر المنطق ينتهي في الميتافيزيقيا
يعني إذا كنت تفهم مضبوط كل تشعبات المنطق
المنطق ينتهي في الميتافيزيقيا
والميتافيزيقيا اليونانية
وهذا ما اشترك فيه الغزالي و«ابن تيمية» عليه، أن أغلبها فاسدة
معناته فيه شيء غلط في المنطق
عشان كذا كتب «الرد على المنطقيين اليونان»
550 صفحة في طبعة اليوم
وحتى لما اختصره «السيوطي»
اختصره بتقريبًا 150 أو 200 صفحة
تجريد بس في المنطق وترك الأشياء الثانية
وهذا كتاب ترجمته أنا للإنقليزية
فكان فيه صراعات، يعني صراعات مو بالمعنى السيئ
ولكن كانت فيه ديناميكية كبيرة، فكرية وحضارية في الإسلام
وتقبلوا ورفضوا الكثير من الأشياء
فأنت مثلًا تأخذ أصول الفقه
وأصول الفقه مليان من المواد اللي جاية من عدة نواحي
ولكن غير مقدمات أصول الفقه
في بعض أصول الفقه اللي هي
في القياس المنطقي البرهاني
يُسمى القياس البرهاني
غير القياس البرهاني وين تشوف أي شيء من...
بس إذا كنت تعرف أصول الفقه جيدًا
بتدخل في مداخله الدقيقة
فبتلاحظ وتقدر تصير تشم، كيف أنك تعرف
أن في الأكلة هذه حطوا كركم
أو حطوا محلب أو شيء آخر
ولكن أنت ما بتشوفه، بس شامّه
موجود
ما تعرف
ولكن موجود هناك
فأنت بتشوف فيه عندك...
بتقرأ هذا، وبتقرأ حتى لعلماء يونان أو بتقرأ لعلماء هنود
بتلقى فيه أشياء وآراء مشتركة، ليه؟
لأن كلهم أخذوا من بعض
خليني بس أقول كتتمة لهذا النقاش
لأنه مهم جدًّا جدًّا
الفرق أن المسلمين اليوم أيضًا مفتوحين لتأثيرات غربية كبيرة جدًّا
ولكن هناك فرق شاسع
اليوم المسلمين ما يأخذوا من الغرب من نقطة قوة
ولكن من نقطة ضعف، وهذا كل الفرق
أخذنا جزء من الخلافة الراشدة
الدولة الأموية وبدايتها كانت مختلفة
فكثير من المؤرخين يقول أن هي بداية...
يعني أن هذه حقبة اللي هي الخلافة الراشدة
والدولة الأموية حقبة مختلفة
هل هذا التحول أثّر على الشريعة الإسلامية وعلى التشريع؟
سؤال كثير جيد
أول شيء نأخذ شغلة صغيرة في الاستشراق
وفي التاريخ الإسلامي نفسه
مشكلة تاريخية: وهي أنه بسبب الدعوة العباسية
والثورة على الأمويين وكسرهم
أصبح هناك فيه خطاب في التاريخ الإسلامي
واللي تبنوه المؤرخون الجدد بما فيه المستشرقين
هو أن الدولة الأموية بسبب معاوية والحروب الأولية
هي دولة سيئة وعملت عمايل شنيعة
وجاؤوا العباسيين يصلحوا الأمور
ولكن هذا خطأ
طبعًا عند العباسيين كان فيه أيضًا خلفاء
يعني سجلهم مو كثير كويس
الحكم السياسي دائمًا...
تطلع مثلًا على تاريخ أمريكا ورؤساء أمريكا
شوف كم واحد صار منهم، وكم واحد منهم فاسد وعمل الكثير؟
هذا طبيعي في السياسة، السياسة هي هذا
الحقل السياسي هو الحقل الذي يمتد بين الخير والفساد
بشكل سواء، وأكثر للفساد من الخير
لأنه يتطلب...
السياسة دائمًا تتطلب كثير من الأعمال غير الأخلاقية
فهذا لا بد، إذا بنحكم على الأمويين
لازم نأخذ بعين الاعتبار أنهم هم أيضًا حكموا
وكانوا حكام مثل الناس الثانيين
فيجب أن يقاسوا بنفس المعيار، هذا واحد
الثاني، الدعاية العباسية ضدهم أثّرت عليهم كثير
وخلتهم ينزلوا في التاريخ الإسلامي بشكل سلبي
ولكن قامت الشريعة بالأساس تحت الأمويين
ولكن ليس فقط بتشجعهم
بس لأن كان هناك طريقة تفكير متعارف عليها
عادية عرفية
التي تطلبت، وهذا امتداد للحديث السابق
تطلبت أن أفراد، علماء، هم الذين يقومون بإنشاء الفقه ومبنى الشريعة
باللغة الحديثة، لم تتدخل الدولة والإمبراطورية الإسلامية
في إنشاء أي قسم أو أي جزء من السلطة التشريعية
السلطة التشريعية في الإسلام هي كانت حضارة بحد ذاتها
وهي العلماء والشريعة والحضارة التي بثوها
وهي ليست فقط بقوة السلطة التشريعية اليوم
التي هي في البرلمانات وإلى آخره
وإنما كانت الشريعة كحضارة
والشريعة هي السلطة التشريعية في نفس الوقت
أعطيك مثال بسيط عشان نفهم أيش اللي نحكي عنه
أن اليوم إذا أنت ودك تخدم في الدولة
لازم تدرس كتب وتروح على مدارس القانون التي تعلم القانون الدولي
الدولة تقول لك أيش هذه القوانين؟
فأنت لازم تصبح خادم الدولة بالمعنى الفردي والشخصي وحتى الذاتي
لكي تملأ هذه الوظيفة، وتقوم بهذه الوظيفة
ولكن في التاريخ الإسلامي
وحتى آخر يوم كان فيه خليفة أو سلطان في الإسلام
واللي قضى عليه «أتاتورك» في تركيا
كان دائمًا الخليفة ورجال الخليفة
وأولاد رجال الخليفة ونساء أولاد رجال الخليفة
وجميع الطاقم الذي يسمى بالعائلة الملكية اليوم
كان يدرس ويتشرب الحضارة الشرعية في المجتمع
فمثلًا أولاد الخلفاء والسلاطين من يعلمهم كان؟
العلماء
ماذا يعلمهم؟ القرآن والسنة والحديث
والتاريخ الإسلامي والأدب وإلى آخره
فالشريعة كانت المعلّمة للسلاطين
ولم يكن بيت السلطان والبيت الخلافي
يقرر في القوانين والشعب لازم يتبع
زي ما إحنا اليوم بنسوي
فيه عندنا طبقة تحكم
الأغنياء في أمريكا والشركات هي تقرر من هم الحكام
والكل بيتبع، وين بتقول لهم يروحوا بيروحوا، كذا الشعب
بنقرأ كتب «نعوم تشومسكي» في هذا الموضوع مهمة جدًّا
«تصنيع الموافقة» (Manufacturing Consent) وإلى آخره
فالشريعة كانت مسيطرة سيطرة تامة على السلطة التشريعية
فكانت الدولة الأموية هذا الإطار اللي هي أنه نشأت الشريعة في ضمنه؟
قامت السلطة التشريعية وزودت السلطة القضائية
بالأشخاص الذين يقومون بهذه المهام، يعني القضاة
من غير تدخل
لم يكن للدولة تدخل فيه
لأن هذه كانت ظاهرة اجتماعية دينية، لم تكن ظاهرة سياسية
طيب كيف نقدر نقرأ مثل اللي حصل مع خلق القرآن وقضيته
مع «أحمد بن حنبل» مع السجن
كيف تقرأ هذه؟
وهي أنه كان السلطان أو الخليفة له رأي في الشريعة؟
هذه تسمى المحنة
المحنة هي محاولة يائسة لبعض الخلفاء العباسيين
الذين ظنوا أنهم يستطيعون أن يتملكوا الأرض
ولكن المحنة لم تكن في الشريعة
الشريعة لم تكن موضوع نقاش في المحنة
إنما عقائد أصول الدين، خلق القرآن وإلى آخره فقط
طيب مع «ابن تيمية»؟
هذا «ابن حنبل»
إيه هذا «ابن حنبل» طيب ابن تيمية برضه سُجن على قضية فقهية
أيوه على قضية فقهية
بس «ابن حنبل» ما سجن على قضية فقهية بسبب هذه الشغلات
«ابن تيمية» حياته تشبه حياة «السهروردي» المقتول
لأن ربما أنت تسجن لشيء مثل كيف...
«ابن تيمية» رجل عظيم جدًّا
ولكن أنا بعطي مثال على الحال والوضع
أنه كيف اليوم الدولة تمسك واحد من رؤساء المافيا؟
بتلقى أنه يقتلوا، بس ما تقدر تمسك عليهم أي شيء
فيروحوا يمسكوا عليهم شيء في ضريبة الدخل، فهمت كيف؟
فـ «ابن تيمية» كان له أعداء كثير لأسباب ثانية أخرى
لأن «ابن تيمية» كان يحكي رأيه وبقوة
مثل «ابن عبدالسلام» ويهين السلطان
مع أنه كان صاحب مع بعض المماليك الكبار
ولكن كان شوي طبعه قوي «ابن تيمية»
فكان أحيانًا يحكي كلام
فتربى لديه أعداء سياسيين كثير
بس لما يجوا يحكموا عليه بشيء
طبعًا هو قسم من برنامج طويل عريض
ما بيعزلوا كل المشاكل الأخرى
ويقولوا إحنا ودنا نحكم عليك بهذي الشغلة
لا، فيه تعقيدات كثيرة
«الحلّاج» قتُل لأسباب اللي ما لها علاقة
في ليش يبغونه يختفي من المشهد
لأنه وقع في الوضع اللي سمح للوزير أنه يخلص عليه
ولكن كان عندهم أسباب أخرى ثانية للي سووه
فمسكوا عليه شيء صغير وقتلوه
فأنت ترى في كل الدول الإسلامية الأموية والعباسية والعثمانية
أنه ما كان فيه هذا التدخل نهائيًّا في الشريعة
الشريعة سادت كالسيد الأعلى فوق السلاطين
وهذه أيضًا نقطة حازمة جدًّا
أن الشريعة هي التي قررت ما هي التركيبات السياسية
والحكم في الإسلام
فيه مقولة وكنت تقول:
«أن التصوف هو الشرح الكلي للشريعة
وأن الإسلام يتّكئ على بُعدين: التصوف والشريعة»
أيش تقصد بالتصوف هنا؟
التصوف هو الاهتمام الروحي الجسدي
وهنا الروحي - الجسدي في بينهم شَرطة
يعني يجوا مع بعض في كلمة وحدة
الروحي - الجسدي لتثقيف الشخصية الشرعية
لاحظ أنه الشريعة بدأت في بعض مبادئ التصوف
إذا بتشوف التصوف، مثلًا الصوم
الصوم كان في الشريعة من البداية
مو بس في الشريعة، كان في بداية الإسلام
موجود في القرآن الكريم في كثير من الآيات، كما نعرف جميعًا
ودخل واحد من الأركان الخمسة وإلى آخره
بس أيش معنى الصوم؟
الصوم يعني إحنا اليوم..
ما بدأنا نفهم عشر معشار
ماذا تعني مسألة الصوم والجوع في تثقيف الذاتية الإنسانية
فيه كثير شغل
أنا عندي طلاب أحاول أوجههم بهذا
لدراسة ما معنى الصوم والجوع؟
وكيف لهم علاقة في خلق ذاتية خاصة؟
لأنها كثير مهمة جدًّا
فالمهم أن مثلًا الصوفية
تأخذ مثلًا التواضع والصوم والسكوت والصمت
والمقامات والأحوال جميعها كلها
تأخذها وتركبها تركيبة فعّالة فعلية
في تصرفات الشخص
الذي هو في الآخر
يكون المثال الأعلى للذات الشرعية
عشان كذا مثلًا ليش الغزالي كتب «إحياء علوم الدين»؟
أيش إحياء علوم الدين؟
إحياء علوم الدين هو خلاصة المجهود الإسلامي
من القرنين أو أكثر السابقين
لأن الغزالي توفي 505 هجرية 1111 ميلادية
بدأ التصوف في بغداد بالأساس
وانتشر في أماكن أخرى من بداية القرن الثالث الهجري
وفي نهاية القرن الثالث الهجري كان تقريبًا ملامحه واضحة
وأصبح الرابع تطور أكثر وأكثر
ولما وصل الغزالي كان التصوف صار له رجلين ويدين
وفعّال في المجتمع كثير، مو مثل لاحقًا
ولكن فيه كثير من المتصوفين والأقوياء
«أبو نصر السرّاج» وإلى آخره، كلهم أصواتهم عالية كانت
فجاء الغزالي أيش عمل في إحياء علوم الدين؟
إحياء علوم الدين هو جمع بين رِجل التصوف ورِجل الشريعة
في قالبٍ واحد
ورجل التصوف والشريعة هم الرجلين اللي بيوقف عليهم الإسلام
أكثر من أي شيء ثاني
أنا بسميهم النطاق المركزي
نطاق الشريعة والتصوف نطاقان مركزيان في الإسلام
ولكن أشياء مثل الرياضيات
كانت نطاق فرعي، ليش؟
لأن النطاق الفرعي يسند النطق المركزي ويخدم أهدافه
فمثلًا اليوم الفن هو نطاق فرعي يخدم الرأسمالية
طبعًا فيه كثير أشياء فنية وذوق فني وجمال
«الاستاطيقا» كما يقولون
طبعًا
يعني لما أنا أرسم هذه اللوحات
طبعًا أنا ما رسمتها لأسباب رأسمالية
أنا ما ودي أبيعها هذه لي، أنا رسمتهم عشان أحطهم في بيتي
وكثير من الفنانين على هذا الشكل
ولكن في الآخر قوة النطاق المركزي
يقلب أولويات النطاق الفرعي
فخليني أقول إذا توفاني الله مثلًا
وعندي أنا بنتي مثلًا تعرف كيف تسوّق هذه
ممكن زي ما يصير كثير
ممكن يقول هذه ولا مرة إحنا سمعنا فيها
والله الرسمات حلوات
فيشتروها ويصيروا يبيعوها
وبتصبح مسألة «بيكاسو» اليوم
أو من هذول الكبار اللي لوحاته وين موجودة؟
موجودة على يختات اللي البليونير الروسي اشتراه لمين؟
اشتراه لصديقته، لحبيبته
اشترى لها لوحة «بيكاسو»
فليش؟
تصور الفن
كيف «بيكاسو» رسم رسماته
في باريس وفي مدريد
وبالأساس في باريس بين 1905 لحتى ما توفي
وأيش كان يفكر؟ وكيف فنه أصبح قسم من النظام الرأسمالي؟
شركات تأمين تشتريها وبتحطها
في قاعات البنايات الضخمة في طوكيو مثلًا
أيش بيفرق لو كان الرسم يخدم بدل الرأسمالية
يخدم المركزية اللي هي مثلًا هنا الإسلام؟
أيش اللي بيفرق؟ سواءً رسم
إذا كان النطاق المركزي نطاق أخلاقي
وهنا موضوع جديد في المحادثة هذه
ممكن تأخذنا ساعات ولكن...
إذا كان النطاق المركزي هو نطاق أخلاقي
معناته لا يهمني أنا كيف ممكن النطاقات الفرعيه أنها تتحول
لأنها تخدم بالآخر نطاق أخلاقي
والنطاق الأخلاقي هو دائمًا نطاق إنساني
يهتم للإنسان الداخل من جوّا
مو جسمه، ولكن من روحه وبعدين جسمه
روحه ونفسه وجسمه
فالشريعة والتصوف هما مركزان أخلاقيان في الأساس
الشريعة ليست في الأساس جهاز قانوني بالمناسبة
لأن لما نقول إحنا جهاز قانوني اليوم
أنا استعمل كلمة حديثة
فالقانون ما كان في التراث الإسلامي موجود؟
كلمة قانون؟
لا، فيه القانون التركي كخيط ضعيف
مثل أنه يزيد عقابات الزنا والدعارة وكذا
ولكن كان جاء يثبّت المبادئ الأساسية للشريعة
وسموه القانون
ولكن ليس بالقانون اليوم
اليوم القانون هو الأحكام الشرعية التي تصدرها الدولة
هي مسائل وضعية سياسية محضة
فيه على الدولة كنت ذكرت في كتاب الشريعة
أن الدولة العثمانية هي أول دولة تختار مذهبًا لها
الحنفي
أيش أثر اختيار المذهب الواحد على الدولة وعلى التشريع؟
ليش العثمانيين مو قبلهم؟
إيه فعلًا ليش ما في أحد سواها قبلهم؟
مثلًا المماليك كانوا قبلهم في مصر وسوريا
كان عندهم أربعة، مو بس واحد أو اثنين
كان قالوا لا، الأربعة مذاهب لازم يكون لهم تمثيل
وإحنا عندنا قاضي القضاة في كل واحد، في الأربعة
جاوا العثمانيين فقالوا لا، المذهب الحنفي فقط
لكن لازم تنظر بأي نطاق قامت الدولة العثمانية
العثامنة مع الدولة الصفوية والمُغلية
ثلاث إمبراطوريات إسلامية من أقوى الإمبراطوريات في ذلك الوقت
بيسموهم إمبراطوريات البارود
لأنهم كانوا يستعملوا...
مفروض في أول مرة استوردوا واستعملوا البارود والبندقيات القديمة
ولكن هذا الاسم ليس مسألة وصف لاستعمال أسلحة فقط
وإنما وصف لإمبراطوريات إسلامية وغير إسلامية جديدة
بدأت تشتغل بشكل آخر في الحكم السياسي
فهناك مثلًا فرق من بداية الإسلام وحتى المماليك
كان فيه نوع من استمرارية معينة
وكان فيه قفزة نوعًا ما
بالمقارنة مع القرن التاسع عشر تعد صغيرة
قفزة صغيرة اللي جاء بعدها العثامنة والصفوية
ليش؟
كل هذه تطورات
صارت فيما يسمى نطاق التاريخ العالمي
هذا حقل في الدراسات
من تاريخ العالم كله
لأن المؤرخ ممكن يدرس مثلًا خلنا نقول تاريخ
قرية جنب حلب في سوريا أو حلب نفسها
أو خلاص هذا تاريخ صغير
بس ممكن يدرس الإسلام أو حتى الإسلام المملوكي، بس
أو الإسلام الأموي
ولكن عندك تاريخ العالم اللي هو بيشوف الخارطة العامة
أيش كانت كل الدول تسوي؟
وكيف تؤثر على بعضها، وكيف تتعامل مع بعضها؟
و مين أثّر على مين؟
عشان كذا اللي بيقولك أنا بدرس بس قرية معينة
أو مثلًا ممارسات الزواج في قرية كذا في شمال الصين
يقولك تمام صحتين على قلبك، الله يخليك ويوفقك
ولكن ما بتعرف كثير
لأنك أنت محصور بهذا
إلا إذا بتبدأ تقارن وتشوف
يعني لا بد دائمًا من المقارنة مع...
دراسات المقارنة هذا علم جديد في العقل البشري
يعني إذا أنا بجلس بدونه بيكون عقلي شيء
وبس أستورده لعقلي وأبدأ أقارن
عقلي بيتطور بخطوات شاسعة
مقارنة مهمة جدًّا
أنا كل مشروعي العلمي من أوله لآخره
هو دائمًا أنه كل ما أغطي منطقة
بروح على منطقة ثانية شبيهة فيها، موازية لها في حضارة ثانية
بشوف كيف صارت
عشان أعرف أيش نسبية الحقل الأول اللي درسته
اللي هو الشريعة بالنسبة لي
فالمقارنات مهمة جدًّا
السؤال كان...
عفوًا أنا فقدت الخارطة هنا
هو الاستطراد الحديث عن اختيار الدولة العثمانية للحنفية
إحنا شردنا في موضوع «ميثودولوجي» يعني منهجي
ولكن العثمانيين جاؤوا كرد فعل
قسم منه كرد فعل للتوسعات الأوربية الأولى
يعني لما قام العثمانيون، هو كان عصر النهضة في أوربا كان ماشي
واللي كان يصير بإيطاليا في هذاك الوقت
وإيطاليا جنب...
كثير قريبة على ...
اللي يصير في إيطاليا وفي أسبانيا بهذاك الوقت
كان مهم جدًّا
والعثمانيون كان دائمًا لهم رجل في أوربا ورجل في آسيا
من قبل احتلال الدول العربية
من قبل ما أخذوا مصر وفلسطين وسوريا
فلما بدأوا يطوروا...
مثلًا تتطلع على مين السلاطين العثمانيين؟
تقريبًا أغلب أمهاتهم، تقريبًا الغالبية العظمى
من أمهات السلاطين العثمانيين والذين حكموا مع أولادهم ومع أزواجهم
بشكل قوي جدًّا
يعني نساء القصر الملكي في الإسلام
لهم كان أهمية كبيرة وتأثير كبير في الحكم
فمثلًا «سليمان القانوني» مين امرأته؟
امرأته كانت أوكرانية مسيحية، تزوجها، وطبعًا أسلمت
وخلّف منها أولاد، وأصبحت شريكة فى الحكم معه
سليمان العظيم هذا «سليمان القانوني»
يعني لما تروح وتزور السليمانية في إسطنبول
تقول ما شاء الله هذا من أعظم الرجال
وهو فعلًا كان من أعظم الرجال، ولكن امرأته مهمة جدًّا أيضًا
أولاده مين أمهم؟ هي «رخصانة»
فالعثمانيين كانوا بعثوا جواسيس
يشوفوا أيش أحدث مدفع بنوه الأوربيين
عشان يبنوا زيه في إسطنبول
فإذا بتدرس التاريخ العسكري العثماني
بتلاقيه كله مليئ...
الإمبراطورية كانت مو بس كذا
كانت تشتري مهندسين نمساويين وسويديين
تجيبهم وتشتريهم وتقولهم تعالوا إسطنبول
بندفع أموال أكثر من اللي أنتوا بتربحوا في أوربا
بس ساعدونا نبني هذا النوع من المدفع
فكانت ردود فعلهم أنهم يعرفوا أيش اللي يصير في أوربا
واحد من الصفات الأساسية لدخول أوربا
في الحداثة اللي نحن نعرفها
هو مركزة السياسة
يعني أصبح كل شيء متمركز في محل واحد
اللي يسموه «المركزية» أنه كل شيء ينبني عليه
لأن التاريخ الأوربي هو نشأ من الملك
كانوا يسموه الحاكم المطلق، لأن هو يشرّع
كان الحكم الملكي
كان الملك يقول أنا بتكلم بالنيابة عن الله
هذا اللي كان يسموه الحاكم المطلق في أوربا هو كذا
كان يقول أنا ممثل الله على الأرض
فـ «القانون هو أنا» كما قال «لويس الرابع عشر»
وأنا من؟ أنا ممثل عن الله، أتكلم باسم الله
فالعثمانيين ما يقدرون يسووا هذي الشغلة، ليه؟
لأن عندك الإسلام وعندك المجتمع الإسلامي
لو تقول كذا؛ فكل الأسرة العثمانية بتُنفى
بتقوم عليها كل الشعوب الإسلامية
فأيش عملوا؟ عملوا اللي يقدروا يسووا
قالوا إحنا أربع مذاهب، وتعقيدات كثيرة ومشاكل كثيرة
هو كان فيه بعض المشاكل
لما تكون أنت عندك تعددية المذاهب، وهالقد فيه حرية في القانون
لازم تدفع سعرها
أيش كان سعرها؟
بنتكلم عنها بعد شوي
فقالوا بننزل الثلاث مذاهب الأخرى لتحت
ليس بالمعنى سلبي، ولكن بمعنى أن يُحكم عليهم
ويداروا إداريًّا من قِبل المذهب الحنفي
فمن إسطنبول يعيّن قاضي قضاة
وخلينا نقول قاضي قضاة مصر
فيذهب من إسطنبول إلى القاهرة
ومن القاهرة هو يُعيّن في القاهرة وفي الإسكندرية وإلى آخره
يعين من؟
يعين قضاة حسب من يسكن هذه البلد
فإذا كان في البلد حنابلة، وكان فيه كثير حنابلة
كان يعطيهم مثلًا أكثر من قاضي حنبلي واحد
وإذا كان فيه شافعية وإلى آخره
مو أنه اختلفوا، ولكن الإدارة الشرعية العثمانية
تمركزت في يد إسطنبول
وإسطنبول أنتجت المذهب الحنفي فقط
وقاضي القضاة يكون حنفي المذهب
قاضي القضاة دائمًا هو الناظر الذي يتفحص الأمور
وكيف كان أثر هذه الفكرة وهذا التغيير على العالم الإسلامي؟
التغيّر ليس تغيرًا كيفيًّا، وإنما تغيّر كمي
وطبعًا إذا كان الكم يزداد عن حده يصبح كيفيًّا، صحيح؟
يعني الكيف والكم هم ليسا نوعيتان مختلفتان
فإذا أنت عندك وعاء من الدهان الأبيض
تحط فيه نقطة وحدة حمراء وتدوره، يبقى أبيض
وتحط نقطتين يبقى أبيض، تحط 100 نقطة يبقى تقريبًا أبيض
بتحط فنجان بيصير زهري، بس إذا بتحط عليه عشر أضعاف أحمر
بيصير أحمر ويبطل أبيض، صحيح؟
صحيح
فالنوع والكم مربوطين مع بعض
فالإمبراطورية العثمانية كان عندها نوع من الكم الذي لم يصبح كيف
ولكن هذا الكم، لاحقًا في القرن التاسع عشر، بعد 1826 أصبح له أهمية
فالتغييرات هذه مثلًا مركزة الشريعة إداريًّا في المذهب الحنفي
وتقسيم السناجق والإمبراطورية بطريقة معينة
وجمع الضرائب بطريقة معينة
كلها هذه كانت تحاول أنها تسويها بطريقة ناجحة، عشان أيش؟
لأنها تتعلم من أوربا
مو لأنها كانت خايفة من أوربا بذلك الوقت
أوربا كانت ضعيفة جدًّا
ولكن لما تشوف جارك يخترع سلاح جديد مثلًا
حتى لو أنت أقوى منه بـ 100 مرة؛ ودك تعرف أيش يسوي جارك
من منطق قوة
فكان يأخذوا أيضًا أشياء من أوربا
وحدة منها أنهم يسهلوا إدارة الإمبراطورية عن طريقتها
ولكن في 1826 أول مرة الإمبراطورية العثمانية
وجدت نفسها في مأزق شديد جدًّا
أنه من 1770 أو 1780 إلى 1800 وشوي، وأكثر بعدين
ولكن أنا بحكي عن هذيك الفترة بس قبل 1826
روسيا القيصرية كانت تضرب العثمانيين وتكسرهم كسرة بعد كسرة
كل حرب تقريبًا الروس يفوزوا
بالأول كانوا العثمانيين يفوزوا
فأخذوا مثلًا المناطق المتنازع عليها اليوم بين أوكرانيا وروسيا
القرم وإلى آخره
بعد في هذه الفترة خسرت الإمبراطورية العثمانية
حرب بعد حرب لدرجة أنها دمرتها اقتصاديًّا
فبدأت في إصلاحات داخلية، فأصلحت الجيوش
كل الجهاز العسكري تبعها من قبل 1826
بس في 1826 انتهت المرحلة الأولى في إصلاح الجيش
مرحلة مهمة جدًّا، ولكن كان فيه هناك تغيير جذري
يدخل في الكيف وليس فقط في الكم
أن لأول مرة في التاريخ الإسلامي
تقول الدولة أن الأوقاف الإسلامية الكبيرة والمهمة
تابعه لإسطنبول للعاصمة
في التاريخ الإسلامي الأوقاف دائمًا مستقلة
هي التي لها ميزانياتها واقتصادها وإدارتها
مشرف عليها القاضي بالمناسبة
كل سنة يجي يشوف الكتب والحسابات
اللي لها فيها بيكون فيها
أيش صار 1826؟
كل الأوقاف تبعث مدخولها للعاصمة
والعاصمة بتقرر قد أيش يرجع للأوقاف
بطّل كل وقف عنده ميزانيته، أصبحت ميزانيته خاضعة لتدخل الدولة
وبديت الأمور تسوء أكثر وأكثر للشريعة من يومها
فإذا أنت أخذت الوقف من يد الشريعة؛ قتلت الشريعة
الوقف كان في هذاك الوقت مو في البداية
البداية الشريعة بنت حالها من غير وقف
ولكن لاحقًا بالقرن الخامس الهجري
فيه عندك النظاميات في بغداد
اللي أنشأها «نظام الملك» الوزير السلجوقي المشهور
من هناك أصبح شلال في التاريخ الإسلامي في بناية الأوقاف يمينًا ويسارًا
بالمناسبة لما دخلوا الصليبيين تعلموا إنشاء كلياتهم
في بولونيا وفي باريس ولندن من المسلمين
جامعات كولومبيا هي نسخة محدّثة يعني حديثة
من المدرسة النظامية في بغداد
فهذا كان أول تدخل بأنه أخذوا الأوقاف للدولة العثمانية
فسيطروا على الأوقاف
وبعد ذلك بحوالي عشرين سنة دخلت مرحلة ما يُسمى بالتنظيمات
ولكن التنظيمات برأيي أنا بدأت في 1826 مو 1856
التنظيمات اللي هي؟
التنظيمات هي بداية تغريب البنية التحتية للإمبراطورية العثمانية
التغريب بمعنى أن تصبح كالغرب
القوانين الإسلامية بدأت تُزاح على جنب
صاروا يجيبوا قوانين الجرائم والعقوبات من ألمانيا
قانون كذا من فرنسا، قانون من إيطاليا
ويحطوهم محل الشرائع الإسلامية
وبديت أولها بشكل جذري 1852 أول خطوة
ولكن الوقف ومصادرة الأوقاف بالمعنى اللي أنا حكيت عنه
وليست المصادرة التقليدية
هذا 1826؟
1826 هي كانت الخطوه الأولى اللي رطّبت الأرض كما يقال
لنسف قسم من الشريعة الإسلامية والقوانين الإسلامية
في الخمسينيات من القرن التاسع عشر
وبعدها بدأوا بإنشاء كليات حقوق على الطراز الأوربي
وإنشاء جيل جديد اللي هو له علاقة
في القانون الغربي وتطبيق القانون الغربي
وهنا حصل تقنين الشريعة في هذه الفترة؟
لا، تقنين الشريعة لم يحصل إلا لاحقًا
ولكن هذه بداية...
المجلة هي نوع من التقنين
ولكن نتكلم على التقنين ربما لاحقًا، لأنه شوي معقد أكثر من كذا
خلينا نرجع شوي لـ 1826 وأيش صار مع الأوقاف
الأوقاف كلها مدخولها ذهب لإسطنبول
فإسطنبول ترجع قسم صغير بس منه
وتأخذ الباقي تصرفه على الحروب وعلى أشياء أخرى
فالمدارس الجديدة اللي هي مدارس قانونية جديدة
أصبحت تدرب أشخاص اللي لما يتخرجوا، يأخذوا مناصب قوية
وفي نفس الحين أيش صار؟
الفلوس اللي ترجع للعلماء التقليديين اللي كانوا أصحاب الشريعة
نزلت بنسبتها الأولانية إلى 20% و 15% من اللي كانوا بيأخذوه
أنا بعطيك مثال صغير
تصوّر أن الصين تحتل أمريكا
احتلال مباشر أو احتلال يقولوا ما فيه عندك أي خيار
أنتِ بتسوي أيش ودّنا، لأن الاستعمار له طرق عديدة
وتشوف الآن مين اللي بينتج في أمريكا خصبة ورغوة القانون؟
المدربين الأساسيين هم مثلًا كليات الحقوق المعروفة
في «هارفرد» «ييل» «كولومبيا» وأربعة أو خمسة أخرى
تشوف الحين مثلًا على «ييل» و«هارفرد»
أيش يعملوا الأساتذة هناك؟
خلينا نقول بين 300 و 500 ألف دولار اليوم
معاشاتهم هذه
بين الصغير والكبير، خلينا نقول معدل بين 300 و 500 ألف
تصور الصين تقول إحنا نخلق
مدارس قانونية جديدة في أمريكا
وبنخليها هي الفعّالة وتقرر
أيش بيصير في السوق القانوني والشرعي في المحاكم
وندفع لهذول 300 - 500 ألف
بس «ييل» و«هارفرد» بننزل معاشاتهم لخمسين ألف
هذا بالضبط اللي صار في القرن التاسع عشر في الإسلام
إذا بتأخذ أستاذ في كلية الحقوق في «هارفرد»
اللي كان مبسوط ومرفّه وبيعمل فلوس منيح وله اسم كبير
هذا الشخص يبعث أو تبعث أولاده أو ولادها لنفس هذا؟
لا، مستحيل
لا، بيقول خلاص إحنا نازلين في الهوة
بيبعثها وين؟ يبعثها للمدارس الجديدة
لأن أولادك ضلعك، فلذة كبدك
ودّك تبعثه لأحسن شيء
فتصور تدهورت المدارس الفقهية وبدأت في التلاشي
لدرجة أنه بـ 1860 و 1870 إن كثّرت
آخر الناس كتبوا على الطريقة الفقهية القديمة
والأسلوب القديم والطريقة الجدلية القديمة؛ توقفوا
وبدأت كتابة جديدة ضحلة غير عميقة
ولا تعرف شيء عن الماضي
فلما صار فيه قضاة في مصر بـ 1900 و 1920
صار عندهم مشكلة أن يقرأوا الفقه
أصبح عندهم صعوبة في قراءة الفقه وفهمه
أعطيك مثال شوي مبالغ فيه
أنا تكلمت مرة في صغري، لما كنت أستاذ صغير
اجتمعت..
من غير ذكر أسماء
اجتمعت حينها مع القاضي الرئيسي
في المحكمة العليا الدستورية في مصر
في لندن، كنا نتكلم في الشارع
فبيقول لي الشريعة...
يعني أنا فاهم عليك
بس أيش الشريعة؟
هذولا الجماعة يكتبوا طلاسم
أنا مو فاهم كيف يكتبوا وأيش الفقه
عنده صعوبة، وبالنسبة له تعتبر طلاسم
قلت له مو لي، أنا بالنسبة لي مو طلاسم
بالنسبة لي منطق باهر
كيف التركيب الجدلي الفقهي
يعني زي ما نقول في فلسطين «بيمخول العقل»
فهذا اللي أثّر عليه باللي صار في الدولة العثمانية؟
هذه خطوة نوعية من الدرجة الأولى
هذه غيّرت ليس فقط الجهاز القانوني والشرعي في الإمبراطورية
وأصبح قانوني، الآن يصبح جهاز قانوني وليس شرعي
بالرغم من كل التزييفات والمصادرات من الشريعة
في قانون الأحوال الشخصية
والتي ليست لها علاقة كبيرة بالفقه الإسلامي
لأنهم غيّروا كثير وركبوا، اللي يسموه تلفيق
ما هو التلفيق؟
التلفيق من أحد أهم الأدوات للإصلاح الحديث
اللي بدأ بالأساس من 1917 في الإمبراطورية العثمانية
1917 في قانون العائلة
فصاروا يجيبوا لك حتى من الفقه الشيعي
ويحطوه مع الفقه المالكي
وربع من هنا وثلث من هنا، ويحطوه مع بعض
ويقول لك هذا هو القانون
مين اللي قرر كذا؟ على أي أساس؟
أي فقيه جاب كل هذول وحطهم مع بعض بهذا الشكل؟
لا مو مهم، المهم إحنا الدولة
وإحنا بنقرر أيش هو الفقه
فلما أنت بتجيب من هنا ومن هنا
وتقول هذا هو، من غير تفسير ومن غير تفنيد
الفقه كله مفند، كل قول له تفنيد
والتفنيد أحيانًا يكون عالمًا في فن التفكير
لما تقرأ أنت النووي
وتشوف لما اعترض على الشافعي حتى
في أنه مضبوط النتيجة لقال الشافعي
نتيجتك هنا مضبوطة، صحيحة
ولكن طريقة تفنيدك خطأ
أو أنها مو كاملة، أو أن فيها نقص
فيدخل في كل التفسير
ليش الشافعي لم يكمل هذا التمرين الرياضي في الفقه
الذي يُنتج هذه النتيجة في المسألة؟
تصوّر!
فهذا كله اختفى، ما في تفنيد ولا فيه شيء
خلاص أن المرأة يحق لها كذا، في العقد كذا
لأن إحنا قلنا كذا
طيب أيش التركيبة المنطقية تبعتها؟
مو مهم، لا فيه اجتهاد أو ترجيح
أو تخريج، ولا فيه أي شيء
هذا لأن إحنا قلنا «إحنا دولة»
عشان كذا أنت تقول أن القرن التاسع عشر
كان قرن مفصلي في تاريخ الشريعة
أصبحت الدولة العثمانية في آخر القرن التاسع عشر
وبداية العشرين
دولة حديثة وليست دولة إسلامية
ولما أقول دولة حديثة، أنا أول شيء ما أمدح
ولكن في نفس الوقت أنا لا أقول الدولة الحديثة
بالمعنى الزمني أنه حديثة
لا، حديثة يعني تعبير عن الحداثة التي هي ظاهرة نوعية خاصة
فلذلك فيه فرق شاسع بين ما يسمى بالحكم الإسلامي
وما يسمى بالدولة الحديثة
وهذا موضوع كتاب «الدولة المستحيلة»
وأنت تشوف أنه لا يمكن أن تكون دولة حديثة دولة إسلامية
معنى الحديثة أنه تركيبة حداثية أوربية
لأن الدولة الحديثة هي دولة أوربية
حتى في الصين اليوم اللي هي أكثر المبدعة
في خلق مجالات سياسية واجتماعية
بالبداية من لا شيء
وبعدين من معطيات داخلية وخاصة في الصين
لن تهرب من تركيبات الدولة الحديثة
عن الحداثة، ودام أنه دخلنا على الحداثة أو الدولة الحديثة
ودي آخذ مفهوم الحداثة. فكنت تقول
«أن الحل لمشكلة الحداثة هو فهم علاقة كل شيء بكل شيء
لأن كل شيء متصل ببعض»
صحيح
أيش تقصد ودي تعطيني شرح أفضل
خليني أسألك هذا السؤال
أيش أهم طرق الحكم إذا بتدخل على بلد فيه قبائل؟
خلينا نقول مثلًا لما الأنقليز راحوا على أمريكا
أيش كان أهم سلاح عندهم عشان يسيطروا على الأرض؟
فصاروا بيعملوا حلف مع قبائل
يغروهم بشيء عشان يساعدهم
أو عشان يقوموا في حرب على إخوانهم في قبائل أخرى
اللي أيش اسمها؟ «فرّق تسد»
«فرّق تسد»
التفريق هو سلاح من أقوى الأسلحة في السيطرة على شيء
إذا كان تبغى تواجه عشرين شخص
طبعًا واضح جدًّا بس بعطيك مثال عشان نفهم أهميته
بيتغلبوا عليك، بس إذا كنت بتعزلهم
وتأخذهم واحد وراء واحد
خلاص إذا كنت قوي كفاية
تقتلهم كلهم أو بتخلّص عليهم كلهم
صحيح
الحداثة هدفها الأساسي بدأت واستمرت ومازالت تستمر
حسب منطق السيطرة
السيطرة على كل شيء، وأهم شيء السيطرة على الطبيعة
ولكن بما أن الإنسان قسم من الطبيعة
فهو سيطرة الإنسان على الإنسان
أنا كما قلت في «قصور الاستشراق»
أن أوربا استعمرت نفسها قبل ما تستعمر العالم
كيف؟
دخلت في مشروع تحويل الذات الأوربية من ذات دينية
طبعًا أوربا عندها كان مشاكل أكثر من أي محل آخر في العالم
لأن المسيحية في أوربا كانت معفنة
كانت فاسدة وكانت قاسي وليست صحيح بالدين
الدين يجب أن يكون متسامح وعطوف
المسيحية في أوربا كانت عنيفة جدًّا
أنا لا ألوم الأوربيين
لأنهم كانوا يريدون أن يخرجوا من العصر المسيحي والعصر القيصري
أو العصر الملكي المطلق
لأنهم عانوا كثيرًا
أنا ليس عندي اعتراض
لأن المسيحية الأوربية ليس لها مشروعية
وكان يجب أن تقم من البداية
أنا لا أقول المسيحية بشكل عام، ولكن المسيحية الأوربية
لأن مثلًا أنا أعرف بشكل جيد
كيف تمارس المسيحية مثلًا في البلاد العربية؟
مسيحية البلاد الإسلامية هي شيء
والمسيحية في أوربا شيء آخر
فهناك ذاتية تختلف اختلافًا تامًّا
الأوربي قد جلب التقاليد والأعراف القديمة الأوربية
إلى المسيحية في أوربا وخربها
ولكن لا نستطيع أن نقول ذلك
على المسيحيين في العالم الإسلامي
لأن المسيحيين في العالم الإسلامي تشربوا القيم الإسلامية أيضًا
فكان عندهم نظرة تختلف للدين
المسيحية في العالم الإسلامي برغم مسيحيتها
هي أقرب في النظر إلى الوجود إلى الإسلام من مسيحية أوربا
وهذا الشيء قليل من الأشخاص يفهمونه، ليه؟
لأنه تسهلت، التعميم سهل
مسيحي مسيحي، سهل الواحد يقول مسيحي
ولكن مسيحي أي مسيحي؟
فكانوا يبغوا يخرجوا، ولكن لما خرجوا
حاولوا في البداية وبعدين نجحوا بأنهم خرجوا من...
وقعوا في نفس الورطات التي تركوها
فأصبحت الابتزازات والشناعات المسيحية الكاثوليكية في أوربا
أصبحت معلمنة ودخلت في حيز الدولة
ومارست نفس الاضطهاد ضد المواطن كما مارسته المسيحية
كما قال «كارل شميت» فيلسوف ألماني شهير
برغم انتماءه للنازية، ولكن أفكاره وعقله باهر جدًّا
قال «أن كل مفهوم سياسي مهم في الحداثة اليوم
هو مفهوم محوّل من الكاثوليكية إلى اللغة العلمانية»
مثلًا كان الله في المسيحية هو الحاكم الأعلى
فحوّلوا الله إلى الدولة
كان الله هو الله، فاصبح الإنسان هو الله
يحكم باسم الله في البداية
ولاحقًا يقول ليس أنا، لا أحكم باسم الله
ولكن أنا المرجع الأخير في الحكم
أي الإنسان تقصد هنا؟
الإنسان اللي...
هنا ندخل في مسألة أخرى
كيف يستعمر شعب نفسه؟
مثلًا من أشهر الفلسفات في النظام الفلسفي في «ماركس»
الفيلسوف الشهير، وبغض النظر عن كيف فسروه
ولكن «ماركس» فيلسوف محترم مثل الفلاسفة الآخرين
فيه عندهم آراء تناسبك، وفيه آراء ما تناسبك
أنت بتاخذ اللي ودك إياه، وما تأخذ اللي ما ودك إياه
ما زال أنت لا تقع في تناقض، هذا الشرط الأساسي
«ماركس» بيقول أن في كل مجتمع لازم يكون فيه عندك الناس
اللي يسيطروا على ثانيين في...
فهو عرّف السيطرة عن طريق المادية
فاللي معه فلوس
هو اللي بيقدر يتحكم في جهاز الاجتماعي
والسياسي، فيصبح القائد
مثلًا خذ أكبر برهان عليه
أيش يصير في الولايات المتحدة
اللي اليوم المفروض تكون المثال الأعلى للديمقراطية في العالم
عندك حزبين تقريبًا يشبهون بعض في أغلب...
يعني يختلفون على أشياء بالنسبة للعالم الآخر تافهة
على الإجهاض وإلى آخره
بالنسبة لهم هذه كأنها كل مشاكل العالم، ليش؟
لأن النظام السياسي الخاص بهم وحدوي
أيش تقصد؟ لأنه يظهر لي أنهم...
يعني حزبين يشبهوا بعض
كأنك أنت بتقرر بين واحد وأخوه التوأم
يظهر لي أنهم يختلفون، بس يتشابهون
يختلفون على الأشياء اللي لا تعد في أغلب الدول الأخرى
مسائل مركزية
لأن الدول الأخرى عندهم مشاكل كثير أكبر
بس المهم هو الجدل اللي أحاول أسوقه هنا
أنه في أمريكا..
لأن أنا ذكرت «ماركس»
أنه في أمريكا مين اللي يحكم؟
مين؟
بيحكم واحد من الحزبين، يشبهون بعض كثير
ومين اللي يقرر أنه هذا هو الممثل للحزب يدخل في الانتخابات؟
هو قد أيش معهم فلوس
ومن وين يجيبون الفلوس؟
من «لجنة الشؤون العامة الأمريكية الإسرائيلية»
ومن الشركات وإلى آخره
عشان كذا مثلًا إسرائيل عندها دعم مخيف
لأنها مسيطرة على «لجنة الشؤون العامة الأمريكية الإسرائيلية»
في البيت الأبيض
كل السياسة الأمريكية تعتمد اعتمادًا رئيسًا وساحقًا
على مسألة القوى السياسية والقوى الاقتصادية
من اللي معه الفلوس واللي معه الأسلحة السياسية
كيف أثر هذا على أنه يستعمر الشعب نفسه؟
معناته أيش؟ معناته أن فيه عندك طبقة...
مثلًا ما بتلقى في أمريكا شخص عادي
اللي بالآخر يصير الرئيس الأمريكي من غير ما تتبناه الشركات
أنه هو يصير لحاله، أن يصوتوا له؛ لأن عنده تعبير دقيق وصحيح
ومخلص لأماني وآمال الشعب الأمريكي
هذا لم يحصل إلى الآن
وطبعًا كل ما يمرق الوقت، كل ما تسوء القصة
فهذا إثبات على كلام «ماركس»
فيعني هنا في عندك طبقة اللي تستعمل قانون
لتغيّر الشعب الذي يصبح لاحقًا قسم منه هو الحاكم
و هذه الدائرة تستمر في الدوران
تقول «أن من عام 1950 إلى 1970 شُكّل الإنسان كموضوع حداثي»
نفسيًّا ومعرفيًّا وذهنيًّا وروحيًّا
صحيح
أنا ودي أعرف كيف كان الإنسان قبل 1950؟
بيتوقف وين؟ بس كان فيه أشياء كثيرة مشتركة
قبل ذلك الإنسان كان، حتى في أوربا
الإنسان قبل القرن السابع عشر في أوربا
وقبل الثامن عشر والتاسع عشر، في جميع أنحاء العالم
يتوقف وين
الإنسان كان له علاقة في تربيته ونشأته وتكوين ذاتيته، من هو؟
السؤال من أنت كإنسان؟
كان له علاقة في القيم الأخلاقية
ولكن ما حدث في أوربا بعد القرن السابع عشر
كان له تأثيرًا على العالم أجمع لاحقًا
والآن وصلنا لمرحلة خطيرة جدًّا
في أن حتى الشعوب الغير أوربية
حتى في الصين واليابان وأفريقيا وآسيا، تقريبًا جميعها
بسبب التواصل الاجتماعي والعولمة
أصبح هناك نوع من النسق الواحد للتركيب الذاتي
الآن تقريبًا إذا بتروح تزور، خلينا نقول «جاكرتا»
أنا من زوار جاكرتا من آخر ثلاثين سنة دائمًا
فأنا أراقبها عن كثب وأشوف التغييرات
فلما زرتها في سنة 1992 أول مرة
و«جاكرتا» اليوم، ليس لهم تقريبًا علاقة بعضهم
كان ف جاكرتا مركزين تجاريين
«Malls» مركز تجارة مو كذا؟
مجمع تجاري
كان فيه مجمعين، وكان واحد صغير وواحد أكبر
والناس تشتري وتروح
خمس عشرة سنة لاحقًا
كان فيه عندك يمكن عشرين مجمع تجاري
كبار، كل واحد بحجم بلد
وأصبح الجيل الصغير بين الـ 13 و 18 و 19 يعيشون هناك
يعني يروحون من الصبح إلي الليل
هذا كل همهم، ودخلت عليهم بعدين التواصل الاجتماعي
فكل اللي يهم الأشخاص اليوم هو ليس تنمية النفس من الداخل
وإنما من الخارج فقط
ليس هناك اعتناء في الداخل
ليست هناك التقنيات التي يمارسها الشخص على نفسه
في تكوين شخصية ذاتية أخلاقية
فهنا أهمية الصوفية في الشريعة
أنها كانت تهتم للداخل كثير، أكثر مما الشريعة اهتمت
وقد اهتمت الشريعة، ولكن لم تكفي، فدخلوا عليها الصوفية
اليوم مافيه اهتمام، فلاحظ أنت أيش الشاب المثالي؟
هو اللي بيتمرن على عضلات
وقصة شعر على آخر طراز
وبيلبس «سليم فيت»
وما فيه اهتمام للداخل تمامًا، بالمرة
وعايش وين؟ عايش بين المطعم والحفلات
وربما على أغلب الأحوال مشروبات كحولية
وزيارات الشواطئ وإلى آخره
أنا ليس عندي اعتراضات على هذا كله
تقدر تروح على الشاطئ مثل ما ودّك، وتزور وتلبس حلو
ما فيه أي شيء غلط
ولكن هذا يكون قسم من موازنة كبيرة
تبدأ بالاعتناء في الداخل أولًا
عشان كذا «فوكو» الفيلسوف الفرنسي المشهور
الناس أساءت فهم فوكو
قضى حياته أنه يدرس
ما هي العوامل والظروف التي تنتج ذاتيات مختلفة؟
فدرس مثلًا السجن الحديث
كيف السجن الحديث ينتج ذاتية معينة؟
ولكن قضى أكثر سنين حياته يدرس أيش؟
يدرس التاريخ اليوناني والروماني
حتى في أباطرة الرومان
في كيف اهتموا لتطوير الإنسان من الداخل
ما سماه هو (Technologies Of The Self) «تقنيات الذات»
فتقنيات الذات هذا مو الشيء اللي يجيك من برا ويفرض عليك
لا، هذا شيء اختياري
هذا شيء اختياري، أنت بتختار أنه أنا أبغى أصلي وأصوم
وأبغى أصمت، وما أتفلسف كثير
وما أتكلم وكأنه أنا الوحيد اللي في الغرفة
هذه كلها قيم اللي تصنع الذات
«تقنيات الذات»
هو سؤاله أن هذه توقفت تمامًا في القرن الثامن عشر
اضمحلت، كما قال
وأنا أُترجم أنا من الفرنسية، اضمحلت
والآن لا نعرفها، وبمرور الوقت
تتلاشى أكثر وأكثر لدرجة أنها أصبحت عندنا قصة غامضة
ولكن في تقنيات الذات هذه التي مارسها المسلمون
وغيرهم اليونان والهنود والصينيون
هناك، نرجع لأول دقائق من هذه المقابلة
هناك نوع من الحرية التي لا نعرفها اليوم
وقد نسيناها نسيانًا كاملًا
وأثّرت على الإنسان اليوم؟
طبعًا لأنها خلقت إنسانًا لا يعرف أي معنًى للحرية
إلا الحرية الاقتصادية والسياسية
والحرية السياسية هنا بين قوسين
لأنها مو حرية مضبوطة
يعني أنك تروح تصوّت مو بداية ونهاية القصة
تصوّت لمين؟ تصوّت لـ «دونالد ترامب»؟
اللي هو وليد العنف الاقتصادي الأمريكي، والنصب والاحتيال وإلى آخره
ويصبح رئيسًا في أمريكا
طيب أنا مارست حقي في التصويت
بس لأيش؟ لأي هدف؟
طيب، بس مع ذلك اليوم نقدر نشوف
وأعتقد أنك على اطلاع بظهور فكرة التأمل
والبوذية في الداخل الأمريكي، خل عنك العالم
طبعًا والتصوف
فيه نيويورك عندنا مركز اسمه «مركز التصوّف»
وهو بعيد عن الإسلام
كل البُعد
فالحضور الروحي أصبح حاضرًا اليوم في العالم كله
أنا سعيد أنك أثرت هذه النقطة
لأنها نقطة مشكلجية
مثل ما بنقول إحنا في الشرق، مليانة مشاكل
نأخذ الطب كقياس تمثيلي
فيه عندك طريقتين في التعامل مع الجسم
الجسم كمادة، انسى الروح شوي
فيه عندك الطريقة الغربية أن تأكل وتشرب أيش ودك
و كل الصناعات اللي بتصنعها شركات الأكل الكبيرة
لأن هذا اللي ودهم إياه، ودهم يبيعونك
أنت بالنسبة لهم مو مهم إلا كأداة اقتصادية، تدفع
تشتغل وتدفع، وتخلي هالعجلة تدور
وبعدين لما تمرض بتروح على المستشفى وبيعالجك الدكتور
فمثلًا إذا لما بتأكل الأكل بيصير عندك مسألة حوامض في المعدة
تروح يعطوك دواء للحوامض، بتخمد الحوامض
وأنت مبسوط
تروح تأكل، أيش ودّك أكثر؟
بتأكل أكثر لأن ما عندك حوامض
راحت الحوامض من المعدة
بس أيش جاء؟ جاء السرطان في الأمعاء الغليظة
بتروح على المستشفى، فأيش سوت فيك الشركة؟
باعتك الأكل وأكلت أيش ودك، ودفّعوك فيها
ومرّضوك ورحت المستشفى ودفعت أكثر عشان تتعالج
هذا المنطق الرأسمالي الاقتصادي
وهذا منطق الطب اليوم
ما فيه اهتمام أن الشخص يعتني...
مثلًا خذ الحكمة الصينية
الحكمة الصينية تختلف تمامًا في الطب
الحكمة الصينية مو حكمة معالجة، إنما حكمة وقاية
بيقول لك أن أحسن حل للمرض
أنك ما تمرض
فعشان كذا لازم تأكل كذا، وتشرب كذا
وكله مفيد وهائل للجسم
ولازم تلعب رياضة وكذا
ومو رياضة عنيفة، مثل اليوم اللي بيسووها
حتى الرياضات بسيطة
يعني ليش الفضيع مثلًا في الكاراتية و...
لأنك أنت مو بحاجة ولا أن تشتري أي شيء
لا أثقال ولا أي شيء
كله بجسمك بتعمل المعجزات
خذ اللي أنت حكيت عنه
فيه فرق كبير بين الوقاية والعلاج
العلاج اللي هو بيسموه (Therapy) في الغرب
واحد مشهور جدًّا، وهذا من أهم الكتب التي كُتبت برأيي
في القرن العشرين
هو من قِبل كاتب اسمه «فيليب ريف»
اسمه «انتصار العلاجية» (The Triumph Of The Therapeutic)
إحنا حضارتنا اليوم حضارة أنك تمرض
وعندك كل المساعدات أنك تمرض نفسيًّا وجسمانيًّا
وبعدين، بعد ما تمرض، بتروح تشوف دكتور نفسي
تروح تعمل يوقا
بتروح تدخل وتصير عضو في المركز الصوفي في نيويورك
هذا كله من بعد ما كل شيء تدهور
فأيش بيصير؟
بيصير التصوف...
خلينا نبقى في التصوف، لأن زيّه زي اليوقا وأي شيء ثاني
فلما تروح أنت على المركز الصوفي هنا في نيويورك
أيش تسوي؟
أنت تحاول تسوّي زي ما تسوّي باليوقا
فأيش الوضع هنا؟
أنك أنت مريض
بعيد عنك..
أن الواحد مريض، وبيروح على...
مريض نفسيًّا، مريض جسمانيًّا، مريض الاثنين مع بعض
بيلقى علاج عن طريق الهدوء والسكينة
وطمأنينة النفس التي تجلبها له
اللحظات القليلة في المركز الصوفي
ولكن لما بيترك المركز الصوفي
وحتى لما بيترك بيته، من بعد التأمل في بيته
خمسة عشر أو عشرون دقيقة هو يواجه جهاز عالمي
جهاز في العالم، خارج البيت الذي يوقعه في مشكلة
وفي صدمة، في كل ساعة
ترجع البيت تقول أبغى يوقا
فهذه ليست قسم من...
رجوع هذه الديانات القديمة إلى الحداثة
هو رجوع علاجي، وليست وقاية
بينما الصوفية في الأول واليوقا
وحتى الرياضات، ما يُسمى بالفنون القتالية
الرياضات العسكرية
يعني الكاراتية والجودو والتايكوندو وكل هذه الأنواع
هذه كلها استصدرت الآن وتستعمل بشكل زائف
وبشكل بس علاج
لأن الواحد من بعد ما يشتغل عشر ساعات
في مكتب محاماة أو في بنك أو شيء
بيكون ملّ، ووده يطلع يسوي شيء ثاني
فيروح بالليل إلى نادي أو مركز
ويعمل له ساعة كاراتيه
يرفِّه عن نفسه ويروح على البيت شوي مبسوط أكثر
بس ما حلت..
بالأول الكاراتيه، زي ما تعرف في الكنق فو
هي قسم من ممارسات دينية وفلسفية عميقة جدًّا
إلى اليوم إذا بتروح على الصين في مراكز الكنق فو في الجبال
قليلة جدًّا، لأن أغلقتهم الحكومة الصينية
ولكن إذا بتلاقيهم بتشوفهم
وممكن تشوف وتأخذ نظرة من خلال يوتيوب أيش يسوّوا
هذا الكنق فو قسم من الممارسات الدينية
فالاعتناء في الجسم كينونة دينية
أنت مولود الله
وأنت تعتني في الجسم لأنك أنت الحارس
والمعتني
جسمك مو لك، هذه النظرة الدينية
لها قيمة كبيرة جدًّا، نحن نسيناها اليوم
فالاعتناء في الداخل هو نوع من العبادة
يعني لما إحنا نقول أن التصوف هو عبادة
إذا بتقول التصوف هو عبادة
بيقول لك الناس أنت أيش تحكي؟
طبعًا هو عبادة، ما في حاجة للحكي
طيب ليش التصوف هو عبادة، بس لما ندخّل اليوقا بطّلت عبادة؟
أصبحت لشفاء مرض
مثلًا الشخص القوي والذي ليس له حاجة
وليس عنده مشكلة الإحباط واليأس
طبعًا يواجه مشاكل كثيرة في الحياة، ولكنه قوي
يتحمل، وعايش الحياة بشكل ما، وهو مبسوط بشكل عام
ويعرف كيف يعزل السيئ عن الجيد
فليس بحاجة لهذه الشغلات، لماذا؟
لأنه قد طوّر من الداخل قلعة
ما سماه «بيير أدو» اللي هو أثّر على تفكير «فوكو»
سمَّاه القلعة الداخلية
إذا عندك أنت القلعة الداخلية من جوّا ما بحاجة لها
اليوقا بالنسبة لك مجرد شيء سطحي
وما هي القلعة؟
القلعة هي تقنيات النفس التي أساسها الأخلاق
فلما أنت تقول جوع وصوم، أنت تصوم كالصوفي
طيب، تصوَّر أنت عندك قدرة السيطرة على النفس
لأنه من لم يسيطر على نفسه، لا يسيطر على أي شيء
أول شيء في الدنيا لازم، إذا ودك تحكم
كل حاكم في المنطق الإسلامي
احكم نفسك قبل ما تحكم غيرك
عشان كذا لما الغزالي وغيره لما كتبوا كلهم
من «الماوردي» و«ابن جماعة»
أهم نصيحة للسلطان وللخليفة
لما الغزالي يقول: «اعلم يا سلطان العالم»
«ملك الشرق والغرب، إن لله عليك»
«نِعم ظاهرةٌ وآلاءٌ متكاثرةٌ»
وبيدخل في عشر صفحات أن كيف أنت تظهر شكرك للمُنعم، لله
وهذا أساس الحكم
والصوم أحدها
نظام الصوم إحنا بنسويه مثلًا في رمضان
لأنه...
ولكن هدفه أكبر من أيش نفهم اليوم
أنا برأيي القيم الدينية برغم ممارساتها اليوم، وبعد ممارستها
ضعفت في مفهومها الأساسي، مفهومها الفلسفي
فمثلًا المسلم القديم قبل ألف سنة، لما كان يصوم
في نفس درجة التعليم والوعي، إذا بنأخذ واحد
عنده كان فهم لفلسفة الصوم مثلًا في رمضان أكبر وأعمق
مما يوازيه المسلم في القرن الواحد والعشرين
ليه؟ لأن الفلسفة التي تبطّن وتكون أساس لتقنيات الذات
وهي تقنيات صوفية، قد ضاعت لا نعرفها اليوم
طيب، بالنسبة للإنسان
كيف ينظر الإنسان الحداثي للعالم اليوم؟
كساحة لهو ومرح
(Fun) «مرح»
تلاحظ بالإنقليزي أكثر كلمة تستعمل بين الناس هي كلمة «مرح»
المهم الواحد يكون مبسوط
بس نلاحظ كل ما يكونوا مبسوطين أكثر
بمعنى أنه كل ما يكون معهم فلوس أكثر، وعندهم سيارات أكثر
وعندهم مدخول اللي ما عمله أحد في التاريخ البشري
في هذا المستوى
اليوم شباب صغار بعمر ثلاثين سنة
في صناعة التكنولوجيا والكمبيوتر
يعملوا لهم أموال هائلة
فيصبحوا في سن الثلاثين والخمس وثلاثين، مليونيرية
وعندهم كل شيء، اشتروا بيوت وحتى اشتروا جزر
وبنوا بيوت فخمة على جزر جميلة
عندهم كل شيء في الدنيا
وكل الإمكانيات موجودة عندهم
ولكن يركبهم اليأس والإحباط
والاكتئاب
والاكتئاب والحزن أكثر من أي شعب في تاريخ البشرية
الفقير أسعد من الغني حتى اليوم
ولكن الفقير القديم أسعد مليون مرة من أغنى غني اليوم
القانون هو واحد كل ما تغنى أكثر في الحداثة
كل ما أنك كنت بتيأس أكثر وبتكون حزين
وما كان هذا ما قبل الحداثة؟
ليش؟
من الداخل
أليس نفس الموضوع هو نفسه اللي...
على المعدل لا، إذا بنأخذ على المعدل
طبعًا أنا ليش أقول معدل، لأن دائمًا فيه عندك استثناءات
يعني ممكن من ألف شخص بتلاقي واحد
اللي يستثنى من القاعدة اللي أنت بتقول عنها
ولكن لما تشوف أغنياء المسلمين، أيش عملوا؟
أغنياء المسلمين ولا قسم من الجهاز العرفي والعادي
يعني من العادة
العادي في النظام الإسلامي هو أن المال يجب أن يدور
فمن بنى المباني الضخمة في الإسلام؟
من كل المساجد والمدارس
وآبار المياه في الشوارع والجسور، من بناها؟
المسلمون الأثرياء
السلاطين والوزراء والباشوات والتجار الكبار
مع صنع الخير والحسنات، كلها كانت قيمة داخلية
لأن المسألة مو مسألة أنه أنا بس ودي استعرض
وكثير من المسلمين، طبعًا
ودهم يعملوا عشان يستعرضوا اللي عندهم
وأنهم يعملوا عشان يصير عندهم مركز أعلى في المجتمع
هذه طبيعة إنسانية تقريبًا شاملة
فيه أشخاص ما يهتموا لها، ولكن على الغالب
ولكن عندهم اقتناع داخلي
أنه مثلًا الممارسات التي مصدرها الدين
والتي تصر على نوع من ممارسات أخلاقية وأعمال أخلاقية
كانت قسم من الدين
ولذلك كانت تُفعل كطريقة للخلاص الشخصي
اليوم أغلب الناس لا تؤمن في الغرب
وليست عندها هذه الدوافع
وحتى لو آمنت وكانت تروح الكنيسة
عندهم أشياء غريبه جدًّا بصراحة
يروح الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة كبيرة
على الكنيسة مع زوجته وأولاده
ويعملوا كل الفروض الدينية
وحتى يمكن يتبرع في 100 دولار مثلًا للفقراء
ويوم الاثنين الصبح يكون قاعد في مكتبه بالشركة الكبيرة
اللي تبتز وتسرق أموال الناس، وتعمل شنائع
وخذ «وول مارت» كمثال
إذا نعرف أيش «وول مارت» تسوي
و«أمازون» كيف يعاملوا عمالهم
كيف يصنعوا الأكل الخاص بهم
كم واحد دفع أسعار باهظة بس عشان الطبقة العليا
في مثلًا «أمازون» أنها تصير غنية بهذا الشكل
لأن ما فيه روادع ودوافع دينية
ما فيه تقنيات الذات
الداخل للشخص الحداثي هو داخلٌ فارغ
متى انفصلت الأخلاق عن الإنسان والدولة والشركات؟
بدأت في القرن السابع عشر في أوربا
طبعًا، ليس هناك أي شيء يبدأ في نقطة معينة من الزمن
ويبدأ من لا شيء
غير خلق الله «كُنْ فَيَكونُ»
ولكن كل شيء آخر في الظاهرة الإنسانية
لما نقول أنه بالسابع عشر
بيكون فيه أشياء قبلها غير واضحة
وعامة، قبل ذلك بقليل
أنا بقول أنه مثلًا ممكن السادس عشر
وممكن حتى الخامس عشر شوي
ولكن في السابع عشر ظهرت ملامحه الأساسية
وهي بدأت في أوربا بمفاهيم جديدة
ففيه حركات كبيرة في العلوم
ما سمي بالحركات الميكانيكية
مثلًا الفلاسفة الميكانيكيين
وما يسمى في الإنقليزية حركات أخرى فلسفية
تُسمى...
لا أعرف المصطلح العربي لأنه لم يوجد في العربية
وهو (Deism) «الربوبية»
ما تقول هذه الحركات؟
تقول نحن المسيحيين ونعترف بوجود الله
إحنا مو مسويين شيء غلط
الله خلق الأرض و إحنا نؤمن به
ما في غلط
ولكن خلق الأرض وشغّلها كالساعة
وأعطى الإنسان حرية السيطرة على هذه الساعة
وترك المشهد
فبالنسبة للفلاسفة الميكانيكيين، الله خلق الأرض واختفى
وهذا بالمناسبة له علاقة في الفلسفة اليونانية القديمة
التي اعترض عليها الغزالي وابن تيمية وجميع المسلمين
وهي هل يعرف الله الجزئيات أم لا؟
وهي مشكلة ومسألة لاهوتية، كلامية، فلسفية كبيرة جدًّا
بدأت من العصر اليوناني واستمرت
وزادت في النقاش في الإسلام
لأن هذا ليس فقط سؤالًا فلسفيًّا، هو سؤال سياسي محض وقانوني
لأن إذا كان الله لا يعرف الجزئيات
معناته أنت تقدر تسوي اللي تبغى
وإذا عرف الجزئيات، معناته يعرف
إذا كنت أنت حتى فكرت فكرة سلبية عن شيء
مو لازم تسويه
حتى مثلًا خلينا نقول اشتهيت امرأة لا يجب أن تشتهيها
معناه أن الله عرف عنك
فهذه تكتب في الكتاب، في سجلك
إلى يوم القيامة عندما تُحاسب عليها
إلا إذا عملت أفعال خير أكثر، حينا سوف يسامحك الله
ولكن القضية هنا، ماذا؟ أن الله يعرف كل شيء
هذا له أهمية سياسية
لأن معناه أن القانون والشريعة وإلى آخره
وكل عمل يعمله الإنسان ليس فقط له عقاب في الأرض
له عقاب بعدين
فالشخص الذي ينمو ويربو على وجود عقاب واحد هنا
إذا نفذت منه، نفذت
وإذا ما نفذت فيه تُعاقب هنا فقط
ولكن في الإسلام
وعندما يكون الله يراقب كل شيء
ولم يغلق العالم ببوابة وأخذ المفتاح وترك
الشخص الذي يفعل شيء هو يُعاقب عليه اليوم
ويُعاقب عليه بأضعاف لاحقًا
فهنا خلق لذات مطيعة، شخصية مطيعة
التي ربما تمارس النظام الأخلاقي، الشريعة في هذه الحالة
حتى لو لم يكن أحد يحاسبك عليه هنا في الأرض
فإذا كان هناك فيه شرطة أو ما فيه قدامك
فيه أبوك أو أمك أو مو قدامك
فيه مراقب أو مو مراقب، مو مهم فيه مراقب أعلى
فهنا عندك أنت شخصيتين
ذاتان تختلفان عن بعض كل الاختلاف
فقط بسبب هذا الافتراض الثيولوجي
شايف كيف؟
خلينا نكمل قصة أوربا
لما قامت هذه الحركة، هي كانت انتقال
من الكنيسة الكاثوليكية إلى المرحلة الوسطى التي هي الميكانيكية
التي تعترف بالله
ولكن لا تعترف بمقدرته على إدارة الشؤون الإنسانية
فأصبح الله في المسيحية، في أوربا، خسر قوة التشريع
وقوه المحاسبة على مخالفة الشرائع والقوانين
هذه مرحلة
هذا في القرن السابع عشر؟
هذا السابع عشر والثامن عشر
بعدين بدأت حركات جديدة تقول
أنه إحنا مو ملزمين بالدين أبدًا
الله مو بس ترك
كل المفاهيم الدينية ليست لنا من هذه اللحظة
فلازم نبدأ نفكر...
فحتى لو فيه دين
الدين ماله علاقة في الأمور السياسية والمجتمعية
وهذا الفرق بين الزندقة وبين العلمانية
الزندقة هي عدم اعتراف بالله، كفر
فأنت تقول أن الله مو موجود
ولكن العلمنة هي أن تعترف بوجود الله
يوم الأحد الصبح لازم تكون بالكنيسة
ولكن صبح يوم الاثنين تقدر تروح
وتقترف في الجرائم اللي تبغاها
هذه علمنة، هذه نتيجة العلمانية
لأن الآن ليس هناك علاقة بين الدين كنظام أخلاقي ليوم الأحد
وباقي الوقت في المسيحية
بينما الإسلام ما فيه هذا الفرق
أنت لما تكون على الطريقة الإسلامية في أربعة عشر قرنًا
أو على الأقل، الحديث الجديد
بعض المسلمين يسوّوا تقريبًا مثل ما المسيحيين يسوّوا
يعني عندهم بعض الشعائر الدينية
ولكن لا ينظرون إلى ماهي أبعاد أعمالهم
لما يبدأ يوم الاثنين الصبح يشتغل
المسؤولية العامة تجاه المجتمع
هذه مسؤولية أخلاقية
ليس هناك أي اهتمام في أي شخص آخر
إلا اللهم عائلتك الأساسية، بدون الدوافع الأخلاقية
وكلما تضمحل الأخلاق، كلما تصبح أنت غير مسؤول
تجاه المجتمع ومشاكله وغيرك
كما قال «طه عبدالرحمن»
«ليس هناك إنسان بغير أخلاق»
الأخلاق تصنع الإنسان
وأن أي إنسان بدون أخلاق هو مينة
بدون روح، غير مسؤول
وممكن أن يقترف أي جريمة من غير ما يعرف
فاهم كيف؟
نعم
ففي أوربا صار فيه عزل أو فصل بين الأخلاق وبين كل شيء
عشان كذا جاء «ديفيد هيوم» الفيلسوف الأسكتلندي المشهور
وقال أن هناك فصل تام
بين ما هو كائن وبين ما يجب أن يكون
ما هو كائن، الأشياء الموجودة
وما يجب أن يكون هو الأخلاق
أنا بقول هذا جبل، هذه حقيقة
هذا جبل موجود قدام الكل
ولكن أيش معنى الجبل بالنسبة لك ولي؟
أنت بالنسبة لك الجبل
والله هذا الجبل مناسب أبني عليه بيوت
وأعمل استثمارات
وأعمل فيه برك وسباحة ومحلات صيد
وواحد ثاني يتأمل الجبل ويقول سبحان الله، بجماله
هذا جبل التأمل فيه فقط بركة لي
أحب أروح أزوره وأمشي فيه وأرجع
أتمتّع في هوائه الصافي
هذول شخصين يختلفان تمامًا
ليش الأول هو تبع ما يكون
ولكن الثاني رجل أخلاق، يعترف بجمال الجبل
لأجل الجبل نفسه، لأجل خالق الجبل
لأجل علاقة الجبل بالإنسانية التي خلقها الله
ولا يمنع عمارته؟ لا يتعارض
لا إلى حد معين، الاستغلال لازم يكون له حد
لا تستطيع بكل جبل تروح تبني عليه 2000 بيت
مو هذا دمار الأرض، وهذا اللي بيصير معنا إحنا
جالسين نعمّر
أنت تعرف والناس يعرفون كفاية
في أي شاطئ إذا بنيت عليه
أكثر من ثلاث أو أربع طوابق
يغيّر كل مجرى الهواء والطبيعة في تلك المنطقة تمامًا
بس مجرد أنك بنيت بناية عالية
من غير ما تعمل مصانع ولا أي شيء ثاني مدمر
بس مجرد بنيت
لأن لو أن مفروض يكون على الشاطئ عمارات عالية
كان خلق الله عليها عمارات عالية من الأول
من قبل ما إحنا...
مو بحاجة أنه إحنا نبنيها
كل شيء له سبب
ولما يكون فيه عندنا سبب
أن فيه عندنا أسماك في البحر من أنواع عديدة
كل شيء له بسبب، الله خلق كل شيء
لم يُخلق أي شيء عبثًا، كل شيء له بسبب
فإحنا بالنسبة لنا لا نعرف أن فيه نظام أخلاقي يربط كل شيء بكل شيء
وأن اللعب بوحدة منها، تؤثر على كلها
الأخلاق هي ليست فقط التصرفات بشكل جيد ولطيف مع الناس
وأن الواحد يساعد
الأخلاق أكثر من كذا
الأخلاق هو معرفة أنك أنت مو لازم تبحث في أسرار الكون
لأنك ما بتفهمها
العلم له أهدافه
العلم اليوم سيطرة، بس السيطرة
الهدف أننا كيف إحنا نعيش أيضًا 200 سنة، أو نعيش للأبد
كيف أننا نخلق بني آدم مثلنا
(Cloning) «الاستنساخ»
الاستنساخ
اللي يفكر بهذه الطريقة من أغبى الأغبياء
برجع لك لأنها نقطة مهمة
بس عندي سؤالين على الكلام اللي قلته قبل شوي
عشان أبغى أستوضح
هل كل إنسان اليوم هو بالضرورة حداثي؟ أو فيه ناس وناس؟
الحداثة ظاهرة مستمرة في التكوين
لأن مثلًا خلينا نقول في الغرب قمة الذات الحداثية
كانت موجوده في الغرب في 1990، مضبوط؟
ولكن الذات الحداثية في 1990 قبل التواصل الاجتماعي
فأنت ربطت 1990 بـ...
لا، كقسم من الظواهر الحداثية، مثلًا التواصل الاجتماعي، مضبوط؟
وفيه أشياء كثيرة ثانية
الذاتية في الحداثة كانت على قمتها في الغرب في 1990
فبتلاقي أن هذه كانت أعلى درجات الحداثة
لأن هم في الغرب قائدين بهذه الشغلة، وهذه مشكلة
ولكن إذا بنتظر الآن
انزل خمس وعشرين سنة لاحقًا، ثلاثين سنة لاحقًا
تقريبًا أكثر من ثلاثين سنة من 1990
تجد أن الذات الحداثية تغيّرت
اليوم الشخص قبل التواصل الاجتماعي كان شيء
وبعد التواصل الاجتماعي صار شيء ثاني
لاحظ في التصرفات، في النظرة إلى الجسد والروح الإنسانية
كيف الناس تلبس؟ كيف الشباب والشابات عم يلبسوا؟
أيش معنى الجنس في كل هذا؟
ما يُسمى بالحرية الجنسية
كله تغيَّر تغيُّرًا هائلًا، حتى في آخر خمس أو عشر سنوات
فكل هذه التغييرات، هذه ليست فقط تغييرات
عندما أقول تغييرات، أنا أقول أيضًا أن هذه التغييرات
تدخل في صميم تغيير الذات الحداثية
فالشخص الحداثي اليوم في الغرب
الذي في قمة الحداثة 2023
يختلف اختلاف جذري عن الجيل الذي وصل إلى هذه المرحلة
في 1990 فقط
ليس فقط 1950، 1930، 1880
فالحداثة هذه كلها تتطور
فعشان كذا لا نستطيع أن نقول أن الكل
يصل إلى نفس درجة الحداثة في العالم بنفس المرحلة
ولكن الكل دخل في الحداثة
ولكن بدرجات متفاوتة
متفاوتة
والتواصل الاجتماعي جعل التفاوت أقل في العالم
طبعًا مثلًا في قرى في الصين والهند
ربما عندهم شوي أقل منا نحن، ليش؟
لأن عندهم التلفون، ويشوفوا كل اللي يصير في العالم
ولكن ليس عندهم الوسائل اللي يبرمجوا أنفسهم
يعني ينحتوا حالهم ويكوّنوا ذاتيتهم
بالشكل اللي مثلًا واحد بنفس الجيل ونفس الاهتمام
خلينا نقول نيويورك أو في تورنتو أو في باريس، يختلف
ولكن عقليًّا، على الأقل، دخلوا في الحداثة حتى في القرية هذه
ما في قرية في العالم اليوم، أعرفها أنا
إلا إذا كان نُسيت من خريطة العالم
اللي ما في عندهم آيفون
وإذا عندك آيفون الآن، أنت حداثي
هل نقيض الحداثة أو الإنسان الحداثي هو الرجعي بالضرورة؟
اللي ما عنده تقنية؟
لربطك بها بالتقنية الآن
كما نقف اليوم في هذا المفترق، أي نقيض حداثي
هو من أكثر الأشياء الإيجابية التي يمكن أن نجدها
حتى لو كان يُظن أنه رجعي، الرجعي أحسن من الحداثي اليوم
ليش؟
لأن إحنا في مأزق كبير جدًّا
بخلال ثلاثين سنة بندمر حالنا بيئيًّا
من ناحية الطقس والفيضانات
في الثلاثين سنة إذا ما بنأخذ خطوات جامدة لتحسين الوضع
كل بنقلاديش وقسم من الهند
وجزر كبيرة في العالم، وهولندا
تنزل تحت البحر مثلًا
اليوم كل سنة عندك 100 ألف شخص صغير
عمره من 15 إلى 30 سنة ينتحر
زيادة عن السنة اللي فاتت
فبسأل أنا طلابي
كم شاب...
من 15 إلى 30 شاب صحيح؟
15 إلى 30 أو 35 شباب
كم شاب في العالم ينتحر في السنة؟
أسأل طلابي
ما أحد يعرف
شباب ما عندهم أي سبب للإنتحار، هذولا كل الحياة قدامهم
مليون و200 ألف شاب كل سنة ينتحرون في العالم
أبغاك تحط مليون و200 ألف شخص في ميدان كبير
وشوف كم واحد بيكون
هذول ينتحروا كل سنة
الأمراض طبعًا
هذا من الشباب؟
هذا بس من الشباب
الأمراض النفسية تقريبًا أستطيع أن أقول
أن العالم داخل في مرحلة جديدة
مثل كيف إحنا دخلنا في التواصل الاجتماعي؟
وكيف دخلنا في العصر التكنولوجي وعصر الكمبيوتر؟
وعصر هذا وعصر هذاك
إحنا دخلنا في عصر الجنون
الجنون؟
الجنون
الآن الأمراض النفسية تقريبًا تهجم على العالم بشكل كبير جدًّا
لدرجة أن كل الجيل الصغير الذي لم يعهد...
لأن اللي تكوّن قبل، مثلي أنا تكوّنت
كان فيه عائلة كانت قوية جدًّا
عندي ستة خالات وأمي وستي
وستي الثانية وأعمام وأخوال
كلهم أحبوني، وكلهم أخذوني كابن
اليوم تصوّر الأمور كيف اختلفت
اليوم في جامعة كولومبيا اللي بعلِّم فيها
واحد من أربع طلاب على الدرجة العليا، يعني بعد البكالوريوس
يعاني من أمراض نفسية جديّة
كيف تعرّف الأمراض النفسية الجديّة؟
فيها اعتبارات الانتحار
في كولومبيا؟
واحد من خمسة في كولومبيا
الإحصائيات موجودة، أنا ما أقول لك شيء مني
واحد من خمسة اللي في درجة البكالوريوس يعاني من نفس المشاكل
هذا بافتراض أنهم في جامعة
كل فصل عندنا، على المعدل
طالب واحد ينتحر في «كولومبيا»
كل فصل، كل سنة
ومرة اثنين بالسنة
لجامعة فيها ثلاثين ألف واحد هذا كثير
وكثير على مستوى العالم حتى
أن ينتحر شاب أو شابة
ليش؟
الأمراض النفسية تطغى علينا أكثر
وأبنائنا الجيل الصغير هو الضحية الكبرى
وأنا برأيي أن الصغار اليوم
إذا كان فعلًا يفكروا مضبوط بالوضع
لازم يبدأوا يفكروا بشكل...
لأن هم اللي يدفعوا الأسعار
إحنا كنا عديمي مسؤولية، تركنا لهم وضع مزري جدًّا
و هم اللي يدفعوا السعر وأولادهم
وهم يحق لهم الثورة على هذا الوضع
أنا أقول ثورة بالمعنى الثقافي
أنا لا أدعي إلى العنف أبدًا
ولكن هناك يجب أن تكون ثورة ثقافية
يجب أن يبدأوا ويسألوا الأسئلة الكبيرة والمهمة
ماذا يحصل لنا؟ من نحن؟
ما كوّنا بهذه الطريقة لنعيث في الأرض فسادًا
يعني إذا كان فيه شعب في كل التاريخ البشري
عاث في الأرض فسادًا، فهو الحداثي
ما من حاجة أعطيك المعلومات
كل اللي بحاجة له أنك تطلع على قوقل
وبس تأخذ كم فصيلة تختفي في العالم كل يوم، فصيلة حيوانية؟
ممكن أسألك؟
يعني أعرف أنها كثير
110 يوميًا
بينما المعدل العلمي لاختفاء الفصائل في العالم
حسب تقدير العلماء بشكل عام هو خمسة بالسنة
لنقل خمسين بالسنة، ولكن اليوم...
كل يوم إحنا بنخسر فوق الـ 100 فصيلة من الحيوانات في العالم
نحن دمرنا كل شيء لمسناه
يمديك تقول كذا، نأخذ نظارة ثانية
فهذه نظارة متشائمة ممكن
أعطيك نظارة ثانية، تقول لك أن اليوم إحنا
صحيح أنه تجي أمراض جديدة مثلًا السرطان
أو الاكتئاب، أو غيره من الأمراض النفسية
أو غيره من الأمراض الدقيقة التي اكتُشفت مؤخرًا
لكن قدرنا نحل أمراض كان يعاني منها الإنسان القديم
فصار عمره أطول
اليوم متوسط عمر الإنسان كان قبل 100 سنة
مثلًا في السعودية وفي الجزيرة العربية خمسين سنة
الآن أصبح سبعين سنة
في أمريكا جالس يزيد
فمتوسط عمر الإنسان في العالم ارتفع
وهذا يعني أن صحته صارت أفضل
ومع أنه تطلع أمراض جديدة
ولكن كل مالهم يكتشفون حلول لهذه الأمراض
فهذا بالنسبة للأمراض
بالنسبة للحروب
الآن نعيش في عصر هو أقل الحروب في تاريخ البشرية
تأخذ بالنسبة للحروب
تأخذ بالنسبة للغنى والفقر، نسبة الفقر أقل
نأخذ وحدة بوحدة؟
بس أنت تقدر تشوف كيف أن الفقر هو الأقل اليوم في التاريخ
صحيح
فعندك عوامل إيجابية أحدثتها الحداثة
خليني أقول لك جواب
فمو لازم نأخذ نظرة سلبية
لا، مو نظرة سلبية
أنا نظرتي إيجابية أكثر من اللي أنت بتدافع عنه
أبد
لأن هناك تفسير سيئ للنظرة الإيجابية والسلبية
مرات النظرة السلبية هي التي تؤمن بالإيجابيات
أكثر من النظرة الإيجابية
لأن النظرة الإيجابية ممكن أن تُتهم بعدم الاهتمام وعدم المسؤولية
كل شيء جيد، كل شيء حلو، كل شيء ممتاز
وبتقوم القيامة، وإحنا كل شيء حلو، وكل شيء ممتاز
وبتقوم القيامة ونفس الشيء
النظرة السلبية...
أنا نظرتي مو سلبية، أنا لا أعتبر وجهة نظري سلبية
ولا تسمى تفاؤلية أو تشاؤمية
فيه ناس يقولوا لي هذا فيه تشاؤم
بالعكس، أنا نقدي...
مشروعي مشروع نقد
نقدي هو إيجابي إلى أكبر حد، ليه؟
لأن أنا أفكر بأنه يجب أن نسترجع مفهوم المسؤولية
لما أكون أنا أنتقد، لمين أنتقد؟
أنا من زمان كنت أقدر أتقاعد
ومو بحاجة أني اشتغل
بس أتقاعد لأيش؟
أنا شغلي تعبّدي
تعبدي
وسبب وجودي طبعًا عندي عائلتي، أحبهم
ولكن السبب الآخر في الوجود هو أن فيه شغل
فيه مسؤولية لازم تقوم فيها
ليه؟
لأن زي أغلب الناس
لما يصيرو ثلاثين أو أربعين يصير عندهم أولاد
مع أنه بتتلاشى هذه الظاهرة
بس كثير في ناس عندهم أولاد
هذه الأجيال الجديدة أي عالم بنترك لهم؟
إذا ما كنا بنوعيّهم أن فيه عندنا مشاكل
لما يجوا، نقول أنتم ولا يهمكم سووا أيش ودكم وانبسطوا
النوادي موجودة، روحوا اشربوا وارقصوا
واطلعوا كيف ما ودّكم
والدنيا حلوة جميلة
وروح اشتري اللي ودك
وأرمي اللي ودك، واستهلك نصف اللي تشتريه
مو مهم، الدنيا حلوة
هذه كارثة
ولكن إذا تسمع أنا أيش أقول مضبوط
وأيش جوهر قولي
أنا اللي أقوله لازم نكون حذرين
أن ممكن الواحد يتمتع في الحياة
وأنا برغم كل حذري أيضًا، لست زاهدًا
أنا عندي حياتي وانبسط في حياتي
ولكن انبسط بشكل مسؤول
أول شيء في حياتي اليومية أمارس النقد
لأن الناس لازم تفهم
ولازم يكون عندها وعي أيش يسووا
طلابي يقولوا لي إحنا من بعد ما نأخذ دوّراتك
تغيرت حياتنا
ما في عندنا مرح مثل ما كنا بالأول
ليه؟
لأن الآن لما يشتروا علبة كوكاكولا
يشربونها ويرمونها
الآن كل طالب بيأخذ عندي صف
وقفّ يعملها تقريبًا
أو إذا عملها يكون عنده تأنيب ضمير
من كل اللي سمعه
أيش معنى هذه الحركة البسيطة
هو فعل بسيط
تروح تشتري علبة كوكاكولا
تدفع حقها دولارين وتروَّح
تشربها وتتركها، فيها شيء؟ لا، ما فيها شيء
لا، هذا فعل حرام
في شريعة الحداثة يجب أن يكون حرام
ولكن بما أن الحداثة ليس فيها أخلاق
فليست فيها شريعة
فأنت أثرت نقاط مثل مثلًا...
أنا لا أريد أن أُتهم أنه أني أتفادى اللي أنت حكيت
لا، واضح
مثلًا مسألة الطب والتعمير
الطب زي ما أنا لمّحت لك قبل شوي
الطب كله هدفه أنه...
صحيح لما الواحد يعمل شيء
دائمًا فيه له التأثيرات الجانبية
التأثيرات الجانبية للطب
هو أن إحنا بنعيش أكثر وأكثر
وهذا اللي إحنا بنركز عليه
أوه ممتاز، إحنا بنكون مرضى وبنروح نتعالج
أيش تبغى أحسن من كذا؟
نشكر ربنا على الجهاز الطبي
مضبوط إلى حد معين، نشكر ربنا على الجهاز الطبي
ولكن ما نظرنا للجنيولوجية تبع الظاهرة كلها
الجينولوجية هي إحنا ليش في المستشفى؟
ليش في المستشفى؟
لأن إحنا أمراضنا القديمة اللي قبل الحداثة
تقريبًا قليلة جدًّا ومو موجودة
أغلب الأمراض اللي إحنا نعانيها اليوم
هي أمراض حداثية، أغلبها
لما نقول أن واحد من أربعة أشخاص
لازم يعاني من السرطان بحياته
هذا المعدل
واحد من أربعة أشخاص أيضًا لازم يعاني من أمراض القلب
ويموت من مرض القلب
هذه كلها السرطان وأمراض القلب وكل الأشياء الثانية
وهذه أغلب الأمراض، هذه من وين جت؟
هذه جت من طريقتنا في الحياة اليوم
إما من المأكولات أو من تلوث الجو
أو من الضغوط اللي علينا
لأن الزعل والحزن بيولّد أمراض أيضًا
كل العوامل اللي موجودة اليوم في الحداثة
في حياتنا العادية هي التي تولّد ثمانين بالمئة أو تسعين بالمئة من الأمراض
لما يجي الجهاز الطبي
ويقول لك اسمع أنا عمليًّا...
وهنا لازم تتخيل
أن الجهاز الطبي يتكلم مع الشركات الكبيرة
فأيش بيقول لهم؟
الجهاز الطبي يقول للشركات الكبيرة أنت أيش ودّك؟
أنتوا أعطونا أموال
وإحنا بنطور الطب عشان نشفي الناس
عشان يظلوا يستهلكوا مأكولاتكم وإلى آخره
يعني فيه تحالف بين المستشفيات والجهاز الطبي اليوم
تقريبًا في كل دولة، وخصوصًا في الولايات المتحدة
مع الشركات الكبيرة
حتى الآن المستشفيات بالمناسبة، أصبحت شركات
كان في الأول عندك الأطباء يمارسون الطب
من خلال عياداتهم الخاصة
كل واحد عنده عيادته، وربما يجتمع طبيبين أو ثلاثة
ويفتحوا عيادة مع بعض
ولكن الآن المستشفيات تشتري هذول الأطباء
وبتدخلهم في سلكها وتدفع لهم معاش
فأيش هذا المعاش؟
المعاش هو الفلوس اللي يدفعه الواحد
عشان يسترق إنسان آخر
فأصبحوا الأطباء اليوم، رِق للشركات
بينما كانوا مستقلين من قبل
وكان يشتغلون بكرامتهم
ولكن الآن أصبحوا مجرد عاملين في الشركات الكبيرة
ويُستغلوا من قبل هذه الشركات
ليه؟
لأن هذه الشركات هي نفس الشركات
كل شركة بالمناسبة لها اهتمام خاص ومصلحة خاصة
بأنها تتعاون مع الشركات الأخرى
لأنهم كلهم، كيفما هي الذئاب؟
الذئاب يجتمعون مع بعض عشان يصيدوا فريسة أكبر
الشركات ذئاب تجتمع مع بعض
وتشتغل مع بعض، لأنها من نفس النوع
بينما الشركة ما بتشتغل معي بشكل جيّد أنا كشخص
مثلًا أنا أدعوا إلى الأخلاق
بيقولون لي أنت بتخرب الشغل علينا
أنت عدونا بالأساس
أنا أقول أحسن طريقة لتغيير النظام اليوم
هي في الثقافة وإلى آخره
ولكن أيضًا في أن نبدأ بمقاطعة الشركات
إذا قاطعت الشركات؛ قلّ انتاجها واستغلالها للأرض
خذ أنت
خلينا نقول، اللحم الأحمر لحم البقر
هو يسبب الأمراض السرطانية معروف
ما في حاجة أصر عليها أكثر من كذا
البقر يأكل العلف
والعلف يُزرع في أراضٍ شاسعة كبيرة
لدرجة أن الغابات كلها تقص وتهدم
من أجل زراعة العلف للبقر
ومن يفعل ذلك؟ الشركات
فلما الشركات تفعل هذا...
أول شيء، لصحتي
لازم آكل خُمس ما آكله من اللحم الأحمر، يكفي
إحنا نستهلك أكثر من حاجتنا
عشان كذا فيه مشكلة السمنة
أغلب أمريكا عندها مشكلة مخيفة في البدانة
واليوم داخلة تقريبًا على كل الدول
في بريطانيا ودول الخليج وإلى آخره
صارت معروفة
هذه كلها بسبب هذه الشغلات
فأنت إذا اشتريت بقر أقل
الشركات ما بيكون عندها سوق
بتضطر تنتج أقل
بيصير فيه استغلال أقل للأراضي
تدمير أقل للغابات
ولما تضعف الشركة، وتقصها على حجمها
وقتها بنقول نبغى شركات صغيرة
تغطّي احتياجاتنا
بس مو العمالقة، احتلوا العالم
احتلوا العالم
ما تشوف أن اليوم برضه نفس أدوات الحداثة والحداثة نفسها
جالسة تخلق هذه الشركات الجديدة
والحركات اللي تساعد في هذه الثقافة الجديدة اللي أنت تطلبها
فتجد أن اليوم إعادة تدوير في نمو
أنا لما أقول أن إعادة تدوير في نمو
اللي هو ثقافة إعادة التدوير
أو الأكل المصنوع...
سواءً اللحوم الحمراء وغيره
كيف أنه جالس يقل استخدامها
البلاستيك واستخدامه
ففيه حركة ضخمة أحس أنك تقدر تراها وتلمسها
في تقليل..
تحسين، تقليل
فيه تقليل وتحسين وهذا من ضمن أدوات الحداثة نفسها
مضبوط، كلامك صحيح
فممكن تصلَح نفسها بنفسها؟
بدون أخلاق
حسب السرعة الزمنية اليوم؟
لا، لأن إحنا اللي نسويه قليل جدًّا
لازم يكون أكثر بكثير، هذه أول شيء
ولكن أيضًا أنت انظر للتحسينات هذه
كثير من التحسينات هذه هي قسم من نفس المنطق
100%
اللي ولّدت المشكلة من البداية
لما مثلًا أجي أقول طيب ما يحتاج نستعمل البترول
خلينا نلقى مصادر أخرى، من الهواء
فأنا أجي أعمل شركة كبيرة بملايين الدولارات
وببنيها عشان أيش؟
ولكن دوافعي كلها استغلال، نفس المنطق الرأسمالي
في النقطة التي لا يكون هناك
جلب فلوس من التكنولوجيا، خضراء
تقف
إيه قطعًا
وهذا يرجع لأيش أصل الكمبيوتر
وأنه جاء من الحرب والعنف
خلينا نرجع نهاجم الموضوع من باب آخر
لا يمكن أن تحل مشكلة من خلال حل
أُنتج من نفس المنطق الذي أنتج المشكلة
قانون رقم واحد
مستحيل، والحداثة أثبتت هذا القانون
لم نكن نعرف هذا القانون في التاريخ البشري
حتى ما حدث في القرنين الماضية
لأن الحداثة هذا هو منطقها
أنه تحاول تخلق حل من داخل...
خلينا نرجع للحوامض في الجسم
إذا بتطِّلع
أيش الحل للحوامض في الجسم اللي لازم يكون؟
أنك تعدل طريقة حياتك
تعمل نوع من الرياضة، تأكل مأكولات ثانية
بس مستحيل على الحداثة أن المنطق الرأسمالي يقولك...
ساعتها هو بيكون مدمر للنفس
فهم أيش بيسووا؟ بيعطوك «بانتوبرازول»
«بانتوبرازول» هذا دواء مشهور جدًّا
يُنتج بالملايين، تأخذه بتسكّن الحوامض
ولكنه يعيث فسادًا في الجسم
وبنعرف أن هذا معناته بعد كم سنة
البني آدم بيبدأ يطوّر سرطان معين
«بانتوبرازول» هو الحل الحداثي لمشكلة حداثية
فأنت تخلّصت من الحرقة، بس إحنا أعطينا السرطان للمريض
طيب لا، اتركني خليني بالحرقة على الأقل
لا، بعطيك «بانتوبرازول» عشان يعملك سرطان
بعدين بتروح المستشفى بتدفع 450 ألف دولار للعملية
وأنا بحكيك عن حالات حقيقية
بس لو رحت للحركة بيجيني «عبدالوهاب المسيري»
بيقول تسليع الحركة وجعلها جزء من المنظومة الحداثية
المنظومة، صحيح
يعني ما بسلم لا ما من هنا ولا من هنا
طبعًا إحنا في مأزق
يجب أن نفهم أننا في مأزق
أنا جيلي وحتى جيلك، يعني كبرنا شوي
مع أنك أنت بعدك شاب صغير
ولكن عندك أطفال، عنده أطفال، عندهم أطفال
أيش نعمل؟
أبرياء لا يستحقون ما نفعل بهم
طيب، لما نقول الأخلاق
هذا السؤال عودةً على بعض النقاط اللي تكلمنا فيها
تشير لها، ونفس الإشارة «طه عبدالرحمن» أشار لها
هل الأخلاق بالضرورة تساوي الدين؟
هذا نقاش هو عايش فيه
بصراحه أنا بالنسبة لي هذا ليس سؤالًا مهمًّا
هو له مهم، لأن عنده ظروفه الخاصة
لا، بس حتى أنت في ذكرك قبل شوي قدرت أني أفهم كذا
وهذا اللي استنتجته، أنه لما مثلًا في القرن السابع عشر
أنهم فصلوا الدين، فبالضرورة انزاحت الأخلاق
فأنت حطيت أن في القرن السابع عشر كان مفصلي في الأخلاق لإزاحة الدين
هذا يتوقف بأيش تعني بالدين؟
المشكلة اليوم لما تقول دين
بالإنقليزي (Religion)
بيترجموا «دين» في الإسلام كـ (Religion)
بس إذا بتأخذ مثلًا أيش الدين في الإسلام
والمسلمين بالنسبة لهم الدين شيء
والأوربيين بشكل عام بالنسبة لهم (Religion) شيء ثاني
فأنت لما تقول هل هناك علاقة بين الدين والأخلاق؟
لازم تقول لي بالأول أيش تعني بالدين؟
إذا كان أنت بالنسبة لك أن الدين لازم يكون دائمًا سماوي
بالمعنى، خلينا نقول، الإسلامي
أنا بقول أنه مو بالضرورة
لأن فيه عندك أنت أنواع مثلًا مثل البوذية والهندوسية وإلى آخره
اللي ممكن يخلقوا سجيّات أخلاقية
أنا برأيي الشخصي، أنا بفكر أن الإسلام أكثر واحد نجح في هذا المشروع
برأيي الشخصي
ولكن لا أريد أن أقول أن كل الآخرين فشلوا تمامًا
فممكن أن يكون فيه عندك دين بالمعنى اللي أنا أقدر أعرّفه
لأن طبعًا الدين بتمده لدرجة معينة
وما بتقدر تمده للكل
وعلى الآخر بيكون فيه أشياء مثلًا مو دينية
بحسب مفهومي أنا، إذا بتمد الدين بأكثر مدى ممكن
فهناك علاقة مباشرة بين الأخلاق والدين
لأن صعب القيام بنظام أخلاقي متين
بنظام أخلاقي متماسك، بنظام أخلاقي منطقي
ونظام أخلاقي الذي يستطيع أن يكوّن الذات الإنسانية
بشكل فعّال على المستوى الفردي وعلى المستوى الاجتماعي
إذا لم يكن مربوطًا بحركة «كوزمولوجية» و«ميتافيزيقية»
لأن إحنا قسم من الكون
وإذا كنا بنتظاهر أن إحنا عايشين هنا
وأن الله موجود، أو حتى مو موجود أعوذ بالله
هذا كله كلام فاضي
إحنا موجودين، مجرد أنه أعرف
كما أدهشني لما عرفته قبل عشرين سنة
أن إحنا خلقنا من نفس المواد
اللي عُمِلَت منها الأحجار اللي سقطت من الفلك «المتيورايت»
حلّلوا أيش المعادن في «المتيورايت»
لقوا أن تقريبًا ثمانية وتسعين بالمئة أو تسعة وتسعين بالمئة من المعادن اللي بـ«المتيورايت»
هي موجودة في الجسم الإنساني، وهو جاي من الفلك
فمجرد أعرف هذا الشيء، مجرد أعرف أن إحنا في كوكب صغير
بين بلايين وبلايين من الكواكب التي لا نعرف وين بدايتها ولا نهايتها
ولا نستطيع أن نعرف عنها أي شيء
غير هالاثنين أو الثلاثة اللي حولنا هنا، وحتى ما نعرف كفاية
هذا كله الكون أيش؟ ودّه يكون فيه شيء؟
إحنا مو موجودين عبثًا هنا
كل شيء مترابط مع بعضه
نحن أولاد عم القرود
والقرود أولاد عم الحيوان اللي بعده
والفيل مربوط مع الزرافة
كلنا من الأرض وللأرض نعود
فهذا كله دين
الدين مو حسب كيف العقول الصغيرة تفكر
الله فيه لحية قاعد في محل، مثل ما كيف بعض المسيحيين فكروا
الله فيه لحية، وقاعد بده يجرب تجارب في...
الله موجود وين ما كان
في الجبال والأشجار، في الحيوانات وفي الإنسان
في الضوء وفي الرياح، في النار
موجود وين ما كان، نحن واحد
نحن كلنا واحد
ولما نقول نحن جميعنا بترابنا، بجبالنا، بأفلاكنا
بحيواناتنا، أخواتنا على الأرض
طيب ودي أعرف بعض الأشياء، لأن اليوم مع الحداثة
أصبحت كثير من المفاهيم نأخذها على أنها مسلّمات
وأن هذا هو المفهوم
وأنت عرّجت في بداية حديثنا يمكن على الحرية
ودي أعرف الحرية هل كانت حاضرة في التراث الإسلامي؟
طبعًا
كيف كان مفهوم الحرية عند...
أنا ذكرت أن الحرية ليست نوعًا واحدًا، الحرية أنواع
ولكن نعرف عن نوع ثاني، اللي هو بنفس القوة والجدارة
وأكثر جدارة بكثير حتى، من الحرية التي نعرفها اليوم
حرية اليوم هي حرية التصرف من غير عوائق
من الدولة
إذا ودي أدخن، بدخن
وإذا ما ودي، ما بدخّن
ولا أحد يفرض علي كذا أو كذا
ولكن فكر أنت، ما في عندك حرية أنك تقول
أنا ما أبغى هذا القانون، أنا أبغى قانون ثاني
صحيح؟
فالحرية مو معناها حرية شاملة في اليوم
هي حرية سماها «إسحاق برلين» سماها «الحرية السلبية»
وهي حرية أن تتصرف من غير العوائق
التي تطيح بحقوقك كمواطن
هذه الحريات هي مصنوعه بالأساس...
هي تظهر أنها حريات سياسية
ولكن هي مصنوعه في الأساس لتكون حريات اقتصادية مادية
الهدف الأساسي للدولة هو دائمًا الاقتصاد
لأن الاقتصاد يجلب الأموال، والأموال تصنع الجنود والجيوش
والقوة وإلى آخره، عجلة أو دائرة
فهناك تعاون مخيف بين الرأسمالية والدولة
والرأسمالية والدولة هما أكبر مشروعين قامت فيها الحداثة بالمناسبة
هما النطاقان المركزيان الأساسيان في الحياة الحداثية
إحنا قلنا في الإسلام أن النطاقين المركزيين هما الشريعة والتصوف
اليوم النطاقان المركزيان هما الدولة والعالم المادي
بما فيه الشركات والرأسمالية وإلى آخره
لأن لما نقول الماديات هي أكبر من الرأسمالية
لأن الرأسمالية هي ليست فقط ممارسة بل أيضًا فلسفة
وفلسفة للحياة كلها
هذه تُسمى جميعها...
يعني أنت تشتري أيش ما ودك
وما تشتري أيش ما ودك
هذا أساسه اقتصادي
ولكن إذا بتجي إلى أشياء كثيرة أخرى
الدولة تتحكم فيك وتملكك في الأساس، تملكك حرفيًّا
مثلًا اليوم لما تقول لك الدولة أنت بتروح على الجيش
تحارب في فيتنام، أو تحارب في أفغانستان أو اللي هو
في أمريكا مجبور تروح، وإذا ما رحت تعاقب
ولا أحد ثاني يقدر يسيطر على هذا القرار
خذ الإسلام، لما كان فيه نفير للجهاد
أول فيه ناس اللي ودّهم يرحوا
بس حتى اللي قرروا يروحوا
إذا كان ولد ودّه يروح، أبوه أو أمه قالوا لا، خلاص ما يقدر يروح
إذا كان مديون لواحد، إذا الدائن قال له
أنت ما تقدر تروح، ما يقدر يروح على الجهاد
شايف الفرق بين النظام الإسلامي في الحكم والدولة اليوم
هذه الحرية الموجودة توجد في مساحات كبيرة جدًّا
ولكن مقبوضة في نواحي أخرى وتسمى حرية
ولكن الحرية اللي أنا أحكي عنها
اللي سماها «إسحاق برلين» من غير ما يعرف أيش هي بالضبط
لأن ما عنده فكرة واضحة عنها
«فوكو» كان يعرف عنها كثير
«فوكو» هو الفيلسوف الوحيد اللي في الحداثة
اللي يعرف عنها أكثر من أي شخص آخر
كتب عنها خمسة عشر كتاب
هذه الحداثة هي الحرية «مِن» وليست الحرية «إلى»
الحرية الأولى، الحرية السلبية هي الحرية «إلى»
أنا حر بأن أفعل ما أريد، أن أشتري ما أريد في نطاق القانون
ولكن الحرية «مِن» هو أني إذا كنت وصلت في داخلي
إلى القناعة بالسعادة والفرح؛ حتى الاهتياج الصوفي
من غير أن أشتري هذه السيارة، أو آكل هذا الكيلو اللحم الصافي
أن أنا مقتنع ذاتيًّا من غير حاجة للماديات، هذه الحرية الصحيحة
أنا حر «مِن»
لماذا نسميها في العربية حر؟
لأنك أنت حررتها «مِن»
عندما تحرر قطعة من اللحم من جسم الحيوان
يقول حرر الضلع، يعني قطعته
التحرير هو أنك أنت تلاقي وين حدود الشيء
وتأخذه من محله وتقول هذا هو
كتحرير الكتب، نفس الشيء، نفس المبدأ
فالحرية هي أن تكون حرًّا من داخلك
من غير ما أن تكون بحاجة لشيء
ولما تعتمد كل مشاعرك وكل كيانك
على أنك لن تكون كاملًا إلا بأن تشتري سيارة المرسيدس
فأنت أصبحت عبدًا لها
فالحرية «من» الأولى هي حرية عبودية
والحرية «إلى» هي الحرية الخالصة، لن يستطيع أحد أن يكسرك
العكس تقصد
العكس
الحرية «من» هي الحرية الخالصة
أنا أستطيع أن أكون إنسانًا كامل في داخلي، قوي
عندي القلعة الداخلية القوية التي حكينا عنها
قلعة قوية في الداخل، من غير ما أكون أنا بحاجة لأن أكتمل
يجب أن يكون عندي هذا البيت الفخم
أو أنه أتدين فلوس ليوم القيامة عشان أيش؟
عشان أشتري سيارة فخمة عشان أعرضها لجاري أو لصاحبي
هذه عبودية
ونحن كما كتب الكثيرون
وخصوصًا في نطاق الكتابة عن الدَين، ما هو الدَين؟
قالوا أننا اليوم نحن عبيدًا للرأسمالية
حتى لو كنا نظن أننا أحرار
ودي آخذ بعض المفاهيم الثانية
مثل المساواة، كيف كان هذا المفهوم قبل الحداثة؟
هل كان حاضرًا؟
ترى كل هذه المفاهيم...
لأن يجي في بالي كذا، عندك المساواة، الظلم، العدل
أيوه
هل هذه المفاهيم اللي حاضرة اليوم، بزخم
كانت حاضرة ما قبل الحداثة؟
كل مجتمع عنده طريقة أن يخلق الشروط الضرورية
في أن يستمر في الحياة
مرات يعاني من بعض الأزمات، كل مجتمع، نزولات وطلوعات
ولكن في هذه الأُطر دائمًا المجتمع عنده الوسائل
التي تمكّن الأشياء لتمشي بهذه العجلة
فالمساواة هي طريقة حل لبعض المشاكل
لكي يستمر المجتمع بحياته العادية
فلا نستطيع أن نقول أن إحنا ظروفنا
لأنها تتطلب نوع من المساواة
لازم تكون موجودة في أي مجتمع ثاني
ونبدأ نقول كان عندهم مساواة أو ما كان عندهم
فالسؤال بحد ذاته شوي مشكلجي
بس هل كانت حاضرة هذه المعضلة؟
لا، ما كان فيه مشكلة
لأن كان فيه الشريعة من قبل القرن التاسع عشر
كانت قد نظمت الحياة، وبسبب أهميتها للمجتمع وحتى قدسيتها
المجتمع تقبّل أحكام الشريعة تقريبًا، زي ما بيقولوا، طبيعة ثانية لهم
فالمساواة ما كانت مهمة لهم بالمعنى اللي إحنا بنفسره
لأن المساواة معناته أيش؟
خلينا نقول من ناحية رجل وامرأة
أن الرجل يعمل مثل المرأة
والمرأة بيكون لها نفس الحقوق مثل الرجل
ولكن أيش معناه هذا؟
معناته أن أيضًا المرأة تقدر تشتغل
ومعناه أن أيضًا المرأة تقدر تشتغل
الأولاد يكونوا في البيت
وبيكون في أحد ثاني غير الأم يربي الأولاد
أيش المشاكل اللي بتخلق من الأولاد؟
ووين الأب موجود؟
هل هو حاضر في حياة الأولاد أو لا؟
لأن هو عنده مساواة أيضًا، إذا امرأته تشتغل
وبتروح محلات عديدة، هو أيضًا يحق له
طيب وين الأولاد؟ وين العائلة؟
ليش أنا بجيب هذا الوضع بالذات؟
لأن ليش المرأة لازم يكون عندها حق أنها تشتغل؟
لأن إحنا مجتمع رأسمالي يقيس كل شيء بالفلوس
فتصبح مساواة الرجل للمرأة، والمرأة للرجل
هي أن المرأة لكي تساوي الرجل
يجب أن تفعل بالضبط أيش الرجل يسوي أو يعمل
فإذا الرجل يعمل بالمعدل 100 ألف دولار
لازم المرأة، عشان تكون متساوية معه
تعمل 100 ألف دولار على الأقل أو أكثر
فأصبحت المساواة، مساواة مادية
ولكن هل الرجل والمرأة نفس الشيء؟
المرأة بتخلف أولاد، الرجل ما يخلف أولاد
طيب مين اللي لما بتخلف أولاد...
فيه مسؤولية عليها وعليه
وعليها شوي أكثر
مو لأن هي مفروض أن تسويه من ناحية...
لأن الطبيعة تتطلب منها
الرجل ما يقدر يرضّع أولاده
بحب أسوي هذه الشغلة لو قدرت، بس ما أقدر
الأم الوحيدة اللي بالدنيا تقدر ترضع
يعني فيه قوانين طبيعية لا يمكن أن نتجاهلها
وتدخل في مشكلجة المساواة
هنا أنا برأيي أن المرأة الغربية، والمرأة بشكل عام
كلما تتحرّر؛ كلما تُستعبد أكثر
خذ مثال بسيط
تتحرر المرأة وتذهب إلى السوق؛ لتعمل وتجلب فلوس كزوجها
وأحيانًا أكثر
ترجع إلى البيت هي التي تطبخ
لأن زوجها يتابع تلفزيون لمباراة كرة قدم
أو ربما يشرب له شيء، وهي قاعدة...
اشتغلت طول النهار، وتجي...
والأولاد يعتمدوا عليها
وينادون الأب أقل
صحيح؟
حالات معينة موجودة، ولكن بالمعدل هي التي تطبخ
هي التي...
قليل من الرجال اليوم اللي يساووا نسائهم في الأشغال الداخلية
فمين اللي يطلع دافع السعر الكبير؟ المرأة
أنا لا أقول لا يجب أن تشتغل، تشتغل
ولكن فيه عندك اعتبارات كثيرة أخرى في قضية المساواة
المسلمين عرفوا كل واحد عنده دوره
وكل واحد يلعب هذا الدور، زي ما قال «الماوردي»
«الاجتماع هو تعاون»
وكل واحد له أهميته
تكونين أنتِ أم بيت
اللي يقول أن هذه الوظيفة أقل احترام
من واحد يروح يجيب نص مليون ومليون دولار على البيت
هو أعمى لا يرى الحقائق
أو أنه غبي أو شيء من هالنوع
أنا برأيي الأمومة
بشرط طبعًا أنا بالنسبة لي المرأة
لازم تتعلم دائمًا، وزي الرجل وكل شيء
ولكن لما تقع في موقع الأمومة في فترة في حياتها
أنا برأيي لازم تُقدّر أكثر مما يُقدّر الرجل
حتى لو يجيب مليون دولار لبيته
ولكن هذا مو موجود، ليش؟
لأن الأم عندما تخلّف، ليست مثمرة للرأسمالية
فالرأسمالية لا تكافئها، شايف؟
فمثلًا قليل من الشركات اللي تعطي حقوق جيدة
وتتحسن الأمور تدريجيًا الآن، أكيد لا أنكر ذلك
ولكن لفترات، من 100 سنة وأكثر استُعبدت النساء
لأنهم كانوا ييغونهم يشتغلوا ويخلفوا أيضًا، من غير أي شيء
لا، المرأة يجب أن تكون في البيت
ويجب أن يُدفع لها مرتب عالي جدًّا بسبب أنها أم
ولكن هل هذا من الرأسمالية؟
لا
قانون الرأسمالية هو المال، ليس هناك اهتمام
كل شيء آخر يُحترم، هو يُحترم في نهاية المطاف، ليه؟
عشانه بالآخر يجيب فلوس أكثر
فإذا شركة بتعطي التبرعات لمتحف أو لمؤسسة خيرية
كله بينزل من الضرائب ويحطوا اسمهم
«روك فيلر» تعطي فلوس كثير، بس ليه؟
عشان الاقتناع الأخلاقي والروحي واللاهوتي؟
لا، لأنه بيعطيه اسم كبير
والناس بتصير تألهه، وتحبه أكثر
وهذا معناته يجيب فلوس أكثر، كله فلوس
كله فلوس
فالمساواة هي مسألة ماديات في الأساس
وليس فيها احترام جوهري بالضرورة لا للرجل ولا للمرأة
الإنسان الحداثي هو إنسان مُهان
غير أنه فارغ من الداخل
طيب
الدولة الحداثية في أطروحتك في «الدولة المستحيلة»
ملخصها أنك تقول أن أي تعريف لدولة إسلامية حديثة
متناقض ذاتيًّا بصورة جوهرية
ومنطقيًّا طبعًا
بس معليش، كل الدول هي دول حديثة
أعيش في دولة حديثة، أصلي وأصوم وأزكّي
أمارس كل ممارساتي الإسلامية
فوين التناقض؟
معليش ودي تشرح لي
الدولة الحديثة نشأت على أساس فصل الأخلاق من أي شيء آخر
ممكن أقف الآن فقط، وأقول لك حلّل هذه الجملة
تحليل صحيح وكبير وعميق، وستجد الأجوبة هناك تمامًا
لن ندخل في متاهات طويلة عريضة، فقط من هذا
الدولة الحديثة ليس في اهتمامها إنشاء ذات أخلاقية
والذات الأخلاقية هي عمدة المجتمع المسؤول
لا تستطيع أن تنتج مجتمعًا مسؤولًا من غير ذات أخلاقية
خليني أعطيك مثال صغير، ولكن مهم
الآن نحن نعرف...
ناخذها من الآخر زي ما نقول في فلسطين
تقولوها في السعودية؟
إلا نقولها
نأخذها من الآخر
نحن نعرف الآن تقريبًا الأسرة انحلت وتفكفكت في الغرب
وتلحقنا في جميع البلدان، بالسعودية وفلسطين وجميع الأنحاء
وبأندونيسيا
بتفكك الأسر
الرجال ما ودّهم يتزوجوا أكثر من النساء اليوم
لأن بالنسبة لهم يوقعوا في ورطة عريضة ومشاكل كبيرة
يقولك اعفيني من هالشغلة
النساء تقريبًا ما ودّهم
الاثنين ما يرغبون بالأولاد تقريبًا
مؤسسة الزواج تنحل تمامًا
طيب الواحد يقول ليش؟
المفروض نسأل السؤال ليش؟
صدق
إذا بنبدأ من 1804، بنأخذها من أولها الآن
ممتاز
من 1804 الأستاذ الشريف «نابليون بونابرت»
عمل قانون اسمه (Code Napoléon) «القانون النابليوني المقنّن»
وهذا غيّر العالم
لأنه كان أول قانون مقنّن بهذه الطريقة
يستجلب كل الصلاحيات والقوه للدولة
وبدأ في قسم من هذا القانون، قوانين كثيرة تحته بالنسبة للعائلة
فأصبحت الدولة تشرّع قوانين لكي تصمم العائلة من جديد
فلما نقول أن فيه تشريع، طبعًا على المستوى الأول والساذج تقريبًا
هو عندهم أن تشريع قانون جاء من الدولة
وبيسري على الجميع، وخلاص فيه نظام
هذا مفهوم صحيح، ولكنه ساذج
التفسير غير الساذج هو أن تسأل السؤال
طيب أيش بيسوّي هذا القانون في المجتمع؟
فإذا بتمشي من 1804 إلى اليوم
قوانين الدول جميعًا هي قوانين لإفساد الأسرة
ليس بهدف إفساد الأسرة
ولكن تأثيراتها وعواقبها كانت إفساد الأسرة
فانحلال الأسرة اليوم هو مربوط ربطًا تامًا
بالقوانين وبالنظام الرأسمالي
ما في أي شيء ثاني يقدر يفسرهم
الرأسمالية وقوانين الدولة
شوف كيف الرأسمالية تشتغل مع الدولة مع بعض
فالأسرة تفككت لأنها عبارة عن قسم صغير
من الصورة الكبيرة التي بها الدولة
تحلل المجتمع وتفرقه إلى أقسام
فهدف الدولة دائمًا أن تقضي على المجموعات الكبيرة
التي لها نظامها الداخلي وأخلاقها الداخلية
مثلًا أعطيك مثال بسيط
إذا أطّلعت على دول الشرق الأوسط، غير السعودية
ولكن مثلًا مصر وإسرائيل
طبعًا إسرائيل عندها مخطط استعماري
ولكن عندها شيء يشترك مع مصر، في أيش؟
أن الاثنين ودّهم يقعّدوا السكان البدو
في منطقة مركزية واحدة
ويخلونهم ما يدوروا في خيامهم
ولكن يأخذوا محل ويبنوا بيوت فيه
ويوطنوهم مع مدارسهم وإلى آخره
ليه؟
لأن البدو، كما نعرفه، القبائل عندها إخلاص
واحترام فقط لقوانينها هي
هي لا تعترف، تودّ أن تدور
وعندهم عرفهم وعاداتهم، ومستقلين
بدو أحرار
أكبر أحرار على وجه الأرض
في القرن الأخير هم البدو، في العالم
لأنهم عايشين حياتهم كيف ما ودهم
ولكن هم يواجهوا معارضة الدولة وين ما كان
الدولة ودها توطّنهم ليش؟
لأنه ودها تفكّكهم
بتعلمهم في مدارسها
ويتفككوا، وتقرر قوانين زواجهم
بيتفككوا ويصبحوا أفراد منفردين، فتستطيع السيطرة عليهم
هي والجهاز الرأسمالي
هذا هدف الدولة
لا، أنا برجع للي حكيته
أنت سألتني كيف أن الدولة الحديثة مو ممكن تكون إسلامية
أنت تفكر أنه بمجرد أن أنا أقدر أصلي وأصوم
معناه أنا مسلم، وعايش في دولة حديثة
لا، الدولة الحديثة تفكك المجتمع تحت أقدامك
فأنت، أولادك، وربما على الأرجح
مو أنت بشخصك، أعني الجيل اللي من جيل أولادك
بيواجه نفس المشاكل، ما فيه عائلة
ما فيه أعمام ولا خالات، ولا حب من العائلة الكبيرة
بيكونوا وحيدين في العالم وتعيسين في العالم
وهذا مصير الجميع
وأثبتوه ملايين وملايين من الأشخاص قبلي وقبلك
هل تفكك الأسرة وخسارة جميع أقاربك
ويصبحوا غرباء عليك، قسم من الإسلام؟
الإسلام يعتمد على الجماعة بالأساس
ليس هناك إسلام من غير جماعة
ليس هناك خير من غير جماعة
ليس هناك أعمال خيرات وتعاون ومودة
وحب وصداقة في الإسلام من غير جماعة
الدولة تفكك الجماعات
وربما في منطقتنا الحركة شوي أبطأ
ولكن في آخر المطاف هذا اللي بيصير
هل بفعل الدولة أو بفعل العولمة؟
لا، ما هو العولمة هي جهة من جهات الحداثة
وجهة من جهات الدولة والنظام الرأسمالي
يعني أنت تتطلع على الحداثة
كأنها كرة قدم، اللي إحنا نحبها في الشرق الأوسط
فيها مسدّسات أو مثمّنات، مخيطات مع بعض وبيعملوا...
كل واحد منهم تدخل في تشكيل الكرة، ولها محتواها، تخيلها كذا
وهذه الحداثة، في عندك أنت العولمة
فيه عندك العلم الحديث وله قصة خاصة
ما دخلنا فيه اليوم بالمرة
العلم وقداسته، وإلى آخره
فيه عندك الشركات والاقتصاد والبنوك والرأسمالية
وعندك الدولة والجهاز...
فكل واحد بيدخل ويكوّن هذه الظاهرة
فالعولمة ليست شيئًا مختلفًا، العولمة هي فقط جهة من جهات
أو قسم ديناميكي من الأقسام التي نتكلم عنها
فأنا عندما أتكلم عن الدولة وعن الرأسمالية
أنا أتكلم عن العولمة بنفس الوقت
ولكن ما أذكرها
أو أقول لك أنا عندي طبخة ملوخية لذيذة
ما أحكي عن اللحم اللي حطيتها في الملوخية
بس أنت عارف أنه فيها
إذا تعرف كيف الملوخية تنعمل، فأكيد فيها لحم، صحيح؟
صح
لما بقول أنا كلمة تضبط
زي ما يقولوا المنطقيين «دلالة تضمنية»
يعني لما أقول أنا هذه أمٌ، أنا قلت أيش؟
أن إذا هذه أم، معناته أن في الجملة فيه أولاد
من غير ما أذكر الأولاد، بطبيعة الحال
لما نتكلم عن الحداثة، وهذا الصعوبة في التعليم
أنه يحكي الواحد، مثلًا عن الدولة
بالآخر يجي طالب يسألك ويقول ماذا عن كذا؟
طيب أيش بنسوي؟
بتروح من باب ثاني من الـ...
كل شيء، كل ظاهرة تحتاج تفسير
هي مدينة لها سبعة أبواب على الأقل
وتدخلها من باب واحد، تعرف قسم من المدينة
فالشرح الكامل هو أنك أنت تدخل السبع أبواب على المدار
فدائمًا أنا أقول أن العلم هو جبلٌ ونحن العلماء
ولكي تفهم ما هو الجبل، يجب أن تدور حوله كله
لأن الجبل من جهة يمكن يبيّن لك أنه عالي، ولكن ضيق
إذا تدور من الجهة الثانية بتقول
ما شاء الله، هذا طوله خمسين ميل الجبل
فيصبح شيء آخر تمامًا
تدور حوله عشان تفهم أيش الجبل
فهذا شرح الحداثة لا يتم إلا بأن تدور حواليها، وتشرح كل أقسامها
طيب معليش، وخذني على قدر فهمي
الآن
صحيح أنه لو بدينا نعطي أمثلة بيبدأ الحرج في...
لكن فيه برضه في العالم العربي فيه دول إسلامية كثيرة
وحتى غير العربي، مثلًا لما تأخذ إيران هي جمهورية إسلامية
ففيه تجارب إسلامية
وإذا قلنا أن الدولة الحديثة هي منتج أوروبي
ففي بداية الحديث برضه كنا نتكلم
كيف أن سواءً عمر بن الخطاب أو غيره من الخلفاء
اللي أخذ من...
بما أنه عنصر من هذا العالم أخذ ما أخذ، وترك ما ترك
صحيح أنك قلت أنه كان مصدر قوة، ومصدر ضعف
بس لا يمنع اليوم أنك أنت كدولة حديثة
أنك تأخذ هذا النظام اللي هو الدولة الحديثة
وتصنع فيه كل قيمك وأخلاقك تزرعها فيه
ليكون دولة إسلامية أخلاقية
عزيزي
الفيل لا يستطيع أن يتسلق على الشجر
هذا شغل القرد، القرد يفعل ذلك والنمر
المنشار تقص الخشب
أنت لا تستطيع أن تستعمل المنشار لتصيغ خاتمًا من ألماس، صحيح؟
كل جهاز له وظيفة، وله طريقة في العمل
وله هدف وله جينيولوجية، وله خلفية
الدولة ليست مصنوعة بأي شكل من الأشكال
لتنمية وتربية وإنشاء ودعم القيم الأخلاقية
لأن إذا فعلت ذلك، لن تكون دولة بعد ذلك
الدولة بحد ذاتها كما قال «نيتشه»
بحد ذاتها هي ظاهرة غير أخلاقية، نشأت على أنقاض موت الأخلاق
يعني زي ما تقول هالحيوان مات
وأعطى سماد للأرض، وأثرى الأرض
عشان تظهر فيه شجرة اللي ما لها علاقة بالحيوان
على ركام هذا الحيوان
فالدولة الحديثة ممكن أنها تعطيك زاوية صغيرة
وهذا قسم من تعريف العلمانية
العلمانية هي ماذا؟
أنك أنت ودك تصلي وتصوم؟
بنعطيك زاوية بالغرفة، روح صلِّ وصوم
بس لما تطلع من الزاوية هذه
ما تقدر تحكي أي شيء عن الدين، ليه؟
لأن ما بتقدر تباشِّر بأي قيم اللي تعارض قيم الدولة
وعندما تصبح قيمتك شوي لها شعبية وأهمية
ستصبح خطر على الدولة
فالزاوية في الغرفة تتقلص ويأخذونها
أعطني مثال على أمريكا
أمريكا تزعم أنها دولة حريات، وأنها تعطي الأديان
حرياتها في تعبير عن مشاعرهم وشعائرهم
ولكن ليس لكل هذه المجالات الدينية تأثير في...
أو حقوق في صياغة الكيان السياسي الجمهوري
«عام»
فيه فرق، مو فرق ولكن
فيه عزل بين العام والخاص
الدين ينتمي إلى الشخصي، الزاوية الصغيرة اللي لا أحد يشوفك فيها
أنت تروح في بيتك بتسوي اللي ودّك
ولكن لا نستطيع أن نفرض الأخلاق الدينية
للدولة حتى للأكثرية على السياسة العامة
لأن هذا يعادي سياسة الدولة
هي أصلًا نشأت لكي تعزل الدين والأخلاق عن كل شيء آخر
هذا سببها، هي بالأساس نشأت لتحل مشكلة عويصة في أوربا
اللي هي الحروب الدينية
الدولة كانت حل للحروب الدينية
فاليوم ما تقدر أنت تتوقع من الدولة أنها تتبنى أي...
الدولة تأخذ المعدل الوسط لما هو الجمهور
الذي عنده القدرة على تغيير نظام السياسي، وتشتغل حسبه
لأنه إذا لا، بتتدهور هي
ولكن لا تستطيع الدولة أن تمارس الأخلاق
لأن بتخلق نوع من السياسة اللي الأخلاق تصبح...
زي في أوربا، تصبح مصدر للمشاكل
المشكلة هي أساسها هي مو أوربا الحديثة
هي مشكلة أساسها، برأيي أنا، هي المسيحية الأوروبية
هي أصل الكوارث، هي اللي خلقت الحداثة
لأن الحداثة كانت محاوله لإنقاذ أوربا من الحياة البائسة التي عاشتها
والظلم الشنيع الذي عاشته في قرون وقرون
هل ممكن نقول أن هذه قدرة الإنسان في التطور وصناعة كوكب
أو حياة أفضل، في أنه قدر أنه يخلق كيانات جديدة؟
ليس بالضرورة لها دين، ولكنها قادرة على أنها تجمع ناس
باختلاف أديانهم، باختلاف مشاربهم في أنهم يقدرون يعيشون مع بعض
فخلقت كيان مثل الدولة، فأصبح كيان مستقل
وكذلك مثلًا عندك الشركات برضه كيان ذو مسؤولية محدودة
وهذه ساهمت في أن نصل إلى ما وصلنا إليه اليوم
صحيح اتفقنا، وناقشناها إذا كان سلبي أو إيجابي
بس متفقين على المكان اللي وصلنا له اليوم
من هذا التطور التقني والمعرفي
لا، كل مجتمع بالأول والآخر
بيقدر يجمع كل فئاته
طيب خذ الحكم الإسلامي
المسلمين كان عندهم، زي ما قلت لك قبل شوي
أن المسلمين كانوا حاكمين أقليات أكبر منهم عددًا
طيب كيف جمعوهم كلهم
والكل عاش بشكل أفضل من أقليات اليوم؟
اليوم الأقليات مضطهدة
انظر على المسلمين في أوربا
المسلمين في أوربا يعانون معاناة شديدة
في ألمانيا وفرنسا، وفي فرنسا بالذات
في ألمانيا حتى لا يستطيعوا أن ينشئوا مساجدهم
أغلب المسلمين في أوربا يصلوا في شقق
ويحكوا على التاريخ الإسلامي أنه كان فيه تحديد، نوعًا ما، لبناء الكنائس
يعني منافقه شنيعة جدًّا
الأقليات اليوم، مو كلها، هي ظاهرة غريبة جدًّا
بس في نفس الوقت مو وحيدة وفريدة من نوعها
أن فيه عندك مرات الأقليات، مثلًا في إندونيسيا
هذه الثلاثة بالمئة الصينيين، وهم عادةً مسيحيين بالمناسبة
هم يملكون الموارد الطبيعية للبلد
صحيح؟
ولكن أقليات في الغرب مثلًا هنا
وإذا كانت حتى أقليات سوداء أو أقليات أسبانية
أو أقليات يابانية أو صينية أو كورية
مثلًا تستطيع أن تتذكر خلال كورونا
كم من الآسيويين تعرضوا للعنف في أمريكا
اليابانيين نفسهم، كما ذكرت لك، في الحرب العالمية الثانية
انظر ما حدث لهم. كانوا أبرياء تمامًا، وما لهم علاقة
وأُثبت بعدين أن ولا مرة كان عندهم علاقة
مع حكومة اليابان في الحرب العالمية الثانية
ولكن دفعوا الثمن باهظًا
الأقليات في الغرب مو...
تطلّع على المسلمين هنا في أمريكا، اليوم في نيويورك هنا
العرب والمسلمين مضطهدين
وحاطين عليهم سلوك تجسس وإلى آخره
لا أتقبّل أنا أن الأقليات اليوم مبسوطة
أنا برأيي حتى لو الوضع مثالي، وكانت مبسوطة
السؤال الأول والأخير بالنسبة لي
هو يرجع إلى تقريبًا كل موضوع بحثناه اليوم
هو ما سعر هذا المشروع؟
هل سعره أن إحنا ندمر الأرض؟
أنا كل شيء بيدمر القارب أو السفينة
اللي أنا بسافر عليها في البحر، ما بتقبّله
لأن بالآخر فيه فنائي
فإحنا اللي نسويه أننا نبني وعندنا الرؤساء مبسوطين
وعندنا فلوس كثيرة، ونأكل أيش اللي ودنا
ونشتري اللي ودنا وإلى آخره
الحمد لله
طيب أيش سعر هذا كله؟
أهم شيء نسأل هذا السؤال، أيش سعره؟ وليش نسويه؟
أيش حاجتنا أن نسوي هذا الشيء؟
ليش بحاجة أنا أني آكل ثلاثة كيلو لحم كل يوم؟
هذه الأسئلة ولا أحد يسألها
إن شاء الله الناس تبدأ تفكر شوي أكثر في الشيء اللي تسويه
وكل واحد من هو؟ من أنت من الداخل؟
هذا السؤال اللي لازم يسأله الواحد
من أنا من الداخل؟
أي نوع إنسان أنا؟
هل أنا إنسان أستحق وجودي في مجموعة الأشخاص اللي حولي؟
هل أنا أستحق حبهم واحترامهم؟
ماذا أستطيع أن أفعل لأسد هذا الدَين؟
ماذا أستطيع أن أفعل لأكون مسؤولًا تجاه الآخرين
وتجاه الحياة بشكل عام، الكوكب بأجمعه؟
هذا كله يبدأ من الداخل، ما في شيء من الخارج من هذه الناحية
الأخلاق تبدأ من الداخل
طيب تقول: «إذا كنتم تريدون أن تقيموا حكمًا إسلاميًّا صحيحًا
ينسجم مع تاريخ الحكم الإسلامي
فيجب أن نعطي النظام السياسي طابعًا أخلاقيًّا»
هل أفهم من هذا الكلام أن فيه طريقة لجعل الدولة الحديثة
لحكم إسلامي إذا أضفنا الطابع الأخلاقي؟
فيه حلّين. يا أن إحنا نقضي على حالنا وخلاص نخلّص
وربما هذا ما نستحق
أو أن نفيق على حالنا، ونبدأ نغيّر الأمور
إذا كان إحنا رحنا الطريقة الثانية
فلا بد للحداثة أن تندرس، ضروري أنها تندرس
لأنها مشروع مدمر
يجب أن نخلق من الحداثة، إذا كنا شاطرين وأذكياء
وحكماء أهم من كل هذا، لأن الحداثة كثير شاطرة وكثير ذكية
ولكنها ليست حكيمة
هناك فرق شاسع بين الذكي والحكيم
الذكي ممكن يكون مخرّب ومدمر ومريض عقليًّا حتى، كثير بتصير
ولكن الحكيم لا يستطيع أن يفعل أفعالًا سيئة
حتى لو أخطأ، يصلّح حاله ويكمّل
ويرجع على الطريق المستقيم، هذا الحكيم
إذا كنا حكماء نستطيع أن نطلع من هذا الموضوع
وهذا المأزق لا ينحل إلا عن طريق التربية
يجب أن نربي أولاد وبنات صغار، من السن الصغير
زي ما نقول من يفتحوا أعينهم على العالم
أن فيه قيم لازم يتقيدوا فيها
ولكن نحن بحاجة إلى نظام يستطيع أن يؤهل الشروط الضرورية
يعطينا الشروط الضرورية أن ننشئ هذه الأجيال
كيف تصير؟ لا تسألني
لأن أنا بصراحة أقول لك أنا تعبت مرات من هذه الشغلات
والله؟
نعم. الوضع مزعج
دكتور «طه عبدالرحمن» يقول أنه ممكن
ممكن، بس كثير صعب
أنا مو يائس، ولكن تعبان
لأن حتى لما الناس بتفهم، ما بتفعل شيء
مو مستعدين يتنازلوا عن أي شيء
حتى لو عرف الواحد، بيجلس
أنا عارف أن إحنا...
زي لما تقول خليني مدمن على المخدرات
وأموت وأنا مدمن ومو واعي بنفسي
هذا تصرفنا اليوم
هل لأن ما فيه حل، ما في بديل؟
لا، فيه بس..
هل ممكن يكون فيه بديل للحداثة؟
لا بد أن يكون فيه بديل
خليني أقولك شيء. أوربا كانت في ورطة عويصة كبيرة، جهنم
حتى القرن الرابع عشر والخامس عشر
دخلت في الحداثة
كيف دخلت في الحداثة؟ كذا بدون مجهود؟
اشتغلوا وانتظروا كثير حتى دخلوا في الحداثة
المحاولة وبدون شك أنا أقول لك بصراحة
أنا أفكر أن المحاولة كانت عن نية حسنة
هم كان ودهم يحلوا مشاكلهم
كل واحد لأجل البقاء يحاول يحسّن حاله
وحاولوا، وبعطيهم أنا هذا الحق
فشلوا فشل ذريع
ويجب أن نعترف بهم، ولكن هم حاولوا في البداية
ولكن تصور قد أيش أخذت منهم عشان يدخلوا في الحداثة
من عصور كنيسة قاسية وعقل مقفل، وعدم فهم
وأشياء عنيفة وسيئة جدًّا
دخلوا في عصر التنوير، وطوروا أشياء
طوروا أكثر من اللازم
أصبح علمهم استعماري، ويقتل ناس ثانيين
ولكن في البداية على الأقل...
طيب كيف دخلوا في هذا؟
اشتغلوا قرنين أو ثلاثة قبل ما يبدأوا يشوفوا نتائج هذه الأعمال
ولكن تغيّروا كثير
من نواحي معينة، تغيروا كثير
طيب كيف ممكن أنهم تركوا ما قبل الحداثة
ودخلوا في الحداثة؟
مثل ما دخلنا في الحداثة، بنطلع منها
هل نقدر نطلع منها؟
هل المفترض أن العرب والمسلمين يشتغلون على مشروع خاص فيهم؟
أو هل المفترض أن نشتغل مع الغرب
على مشروع جديد للبشرية؟
الاثنان معًا، يجب أن يكون لنا مشروعنا، نشتغل عليه
باستقلال وبجراءة وشجاعة
لأن اليوم المشاكل اللي إحنا موجودين فيها
تتطلّب شجاعة على أعلى حد، بدون شجاعة وجرأة
لن نستطيع أن نفعل أي شيء
يجب أن يكون لدينا شجاعة وجرأة
شجاعة ثقافية، شجاعة علمية
لنبدأ بالتفكير على طريقتنا الخاصة
نستحضر كل المفاهيم الإسلامية المهمة
والتي كانت عاملًا إيجابيًّا في التاريخ البشري
التجربة الإسلامية في العالم، بشكل عام
كانت تجربة إيجابية جدًّا
بنوا حضارة رائعة، مليئة بالأخلاق والعلوم
كله من غير تناقض، وأشياء جديدة أخرى لا نعرفها
وتعارض كل المفاهيم...
مثلًا أنظمة الحكم الإسلامي
كانت متفوقة على كثير مما نراه اليوم
وأنا الآن، بالمناسبة، أشتغل على كتاب طويل ومعقد في هذا الموضوع
في الحكم الإسلامي الذي هو تقريبًا شرح واسع
للفصل الثالث من «الدولة المستحيلة»
يمكن يوصل إلى 500 أو 600 صفحة، ما أعرف
وين وصلت؟
وصلت تقريبًا 300 صفحة، بس لا زلت في المنتصف
فكل هذه الإنجازات كانت إنجازات إسلامية
ولا نستطيع أن نستحضر الماضي كله
لأن ما فات مات ولكن أشياء كثيرة في الإسلام لم تمت
وممكن أن نسترجعها، وممكن أن نبني عليها
وممكن أن ندمجها ونخلطها مع الأشياء
المناسبة للعصر اللي عايشين فيه
من أجل الخروج من الحداثة
يجب أن نخرج من الحداثة، إذا كنا نريد أن نبقى على قيد الحياة
إذا كنا نستمر في الحداثة ونصر عليها
أنا بوعدك وعد شرف، زي ما يقولوا
أنه كلنا بنروح في الداهية
بتشوف، وإحنا فعلًا داخلين فيها
شوف التدهور الطبيعي والبيئي والجسمي والعقلي
والعائلي والجماعي
طيب، فيه واحد من لقاءاتك أتذكر أنك قلت
أن فيه حركات هندية وصينية
في محاولة لاستعادة تاريخهم
في الصين
في الصين؟
مثلًا فيه عندهم مفهوم يسمى (Circle History) «التاريخ الدائري»
وهذا مشروع هائل جدًّا ومهم
وهناك نموذج ثالث بالمناسبة، يعني ثاني وثالث
عندك النموذج الصيني اللي هو الدائري
عندك النموذج الغربي، الذي نتبناه اليوم جميعًا
وهو النموذج الذي يصبو إلى المستقبل
وعندك النموذج الإسلامي، الذي يصبو إلى الماضي
فهذه ثلاثة نماذج في رؤية الحياة الإنسانية، مهمة جدًّا جدًّا
لأنها تكوّن الفلسفة التي يستطيع الإنسان أن يعيش على حسبها
فخلينا نأخذ الأشياء القريبة علينا في الأول
لأن النموذج الصيني يصبح قسم من هذه الحلول
ولكن إذا بنتطلع على الأشياء والظواهر اللي مناسبة لنا أكثر
لأن إحنا من العالم الإسلامي، ونتكلم عن الإسلام وعن الغرب
لأن هو اللي أثّر علينا اكثر شيء
صحيح
الحديث اليوم عن الصين مالها الوقعة هذه
سوف تصبح، ولكن حتى الآن لم يحصل
بتشوف كيف المسار التاريخي
في الصين بالنسبة لهم أنه دائرة
أشياء كأنها تولد وتفنى
أن المسألة مسألة الحياة دائمًا في حركة دائرية في الكون
يعني اللي بيجيك بيرجع لك، شايف كيف؟
فلما تعرف أنت أن هذا الشيء بيرجع لك
أنت ما بتعمل شيء عاطل، لأنه بيرجع لك
هذا واحد من المبادئ هذه
في الغرب اليوم واللي هو مفهوم مسيحي أصلًا
كما قلت لك، المفاهيم الأساسية الكبيرة مسيحية
هو نظرية (Progress) «التقدم»
نظرية التقدم هذه من أكبر النظريات المؤثرة
في تفكير وتصرف الإنسان الحديث، ليس في الغرب فقط
نحن نؤمن أننا دائمًا في تقدم
يعني خرّبنا الدنيا، وبرضه إحنا في تقدم، ليش؟
لأن عندنا سيارة أحسن الآن، عندنا كمبيوتر يعمل شيء أحسن
هذا تقدم
مو مهم أن إحنا نازلين في البأس واليأس والحزن والانتحار
هذا كله على جنب، بس إحنا في تقدم
أصله أيش؟ الخلاص المسيحي
أنه بالأول والآخر بنوصل للخلاص
معيار الأخلاق في نظرية التقدم
هي ما سنحقّقه في المستقبل
مع أننا لا نعرف ما سيحدث في المستقبل
هذه التناقضات
ولكن إذا تتطلّع على الإسلام
التاريخ هو أعلى نقطة فيه هو الخلق والرسالة
خلق الله أول شيء، ورسالة محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم.
أعلى شيء
وبعده فيه فساد الزمان
كل ما تبعد عن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يفسد الزمان أكثر
هذا فيه ناس بيقول لك أيش هالشغلة هذه؟
مو مضبوطة كذا، بتيأسونا
لا، هذا بالعكس هذا من أكثر الأشياء الإيجابية، ليش؟
لأن لما إحنا بننظر لعصر الرسول
وللرسول نفسه، صلى الله عليه وسلم، كالمنظار الأعلى
يصبح هو الإنسان الكامل كما يقول الصوفية
فإذا كان هو الإنسان الكامل، إحنا أيش الواجب علينا؟
أن نحتذي به، ونقلده طبعًا بشكل عقلي
مو نقلده على العمى. نقلده، ونصبح قد ما هو ممكن، نصبح مثله
يعني تصبح مسألة النظر إلى الخلف، يصبح تقدم أخلاقي
هذا غير موجود في نظرية التقدم الجديدة
لأن نظرية التقدم الجديدة هي أن إحنا
نتقدم أكثر وأكثر، بس حسب معايير معينة
ولكن ليس الأخلاق واحد منها، الأخلاق ليست منها
حتى لما نقول مساواة، هذه لا تعني أنها أخلاق
المساواة هي معادلة سياسية واقتصادية
ولكنها ليست معادلة أخلاقية
فالصينيين أتوا بتاريخهم، زي ما أنا أدعو المسلمين
أن يسترجعوا تاريخهم من ناحية...
التركيبة التاريخية، زي ما سردت لك إياها
الصينيين يحاولوا يعملوا نفس الشيء
يشوفوا «الكونفوشيوسية» والتقاليد الصينية تدعو
وهم يسترجعونها على أساس ساس يعطوا للمنظار الحداثي، وللواقع الحداثي
نوع من الإنسانية والأخلاق
لأن الحداثة هي تعارض تام للإنسانية
الحداثة قتلت الإنسان
ليس كظاهرة، نحن لسنا فقط لحم وشحم وعظم
أهم من لحم وشحم وعظم، هي الروح والنفسية
ومثل ما يقول الصوفية: النفس هي باب الروح
هي المصفاة التي تقرر ماذا يدخل من شر وسوء وخير
وتقرر، حسب ما أنت أيش ودك
ومن هنا تدخل تقنيات النفس، تقنيات النفس تتحكم في مصفاة النفس
فتقرر. النفس هي حسب المفهوم العام
النفس هي زي الوعاء، أنت لما بتملي وعاء ماء
بتحط نقطة بيسيل
فهذا الوعاء محدود، إذا بتحط فيه خير، بيطلع الشر
بتحط فيه أكثر خير، بيطلع أكثر شر
بتحط فيه شر، بيطلع الخير
فأنت تغذّي نفسك بطرق عديدة
منها الصلاة والصيام وإلى آخره
والهنود عندهم طرقهم، والصينيين عندهم طرقهم
والمسلمين عندهم عدة طرق هي الشرعية والصوفية وإلى آخره
لأن الطرق الصوفية تختلف نوعًا ما عن الطرق الشرعية وتتعداها
عدة طرق. وتقنيات النفس عديدة جدًّا
ولكن المهم أيش هي بالأساس؟
أنها تنتج هالنتيجة الواحدة
أن هالوعاء هذا، وعاء نفس
أنه يمتلئ بأشياء في حسنة
وعندما تمتلئ؛ تصبح غلافًا للروح
التي هي تفسد فقط بفساد...
«كل إنسان وُلد على الفطرة» يعني مسلم
ولكن أيش اللي يخرب هالأمور؟
أن في حواليه الناس مو مضبوطين
معناته أيش؟
معناته أن النفس سمحت لنفسها
أن تُدخل أشياء التي خرّبت على الفطرة
مو خرّبت الفطرة، خرّبت على الفطرة
فإذا كان للنفس أن تتحسن، فتتحسن
وهذه النفس هي كل شيء نحن نملكه له قيمة
وفيه نمارس تقنيات النفس
الله يعطيك العافية
يزيدك عافية
شكرًا جزيلًا
أهلًا وسهلًا فيك
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لأيمن الحمادي منتج فنجان
والشكر كذلك لعبدالمجيد العطاس في التلوين
والتحرير محمد نور شمت
وخلف الكاميرات آدم الشهراني
والإنتاج أصيل بافرط
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
والهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
وفي إدارة تحرير فنجان أسيل باعبدالله
وهذا فنجان
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل، ألقاكم
دخلت أنا «مِت»
عفوًا؟
متحف «مِت»
ولما تلقى أشياء مسروقة وكذا، كيف يبررونها الغرب؟
تلقى في بريطانيا كلها يعني واضح أصلًا
هي تنسب للمسلمين أو تنسب...
لا طبعًا واضحة جدًّا، مثل قسم من الآثار الفرعونية
والمصحف
طبعًا
النظرة الغربية الاستعمارية
أن الحقيقة تتكون من مشاهِد ومشاهَد
المشاهِد هو الأوربي الذي ينظر إلى المشاهَد
والمشاهَد هو المتحف
فنحن متحف بالنسبة للأوربيين
حتى مثلًا خلينا نقول
في الحفلات الارستقراطية في إنقلترا في القرن التاسع عشر
لما كانوا مستعمرين الهند
كانوا يجيبوا خدام من أفريقيا ولونهم بني وأسود
ومن آسيا، صينيين ومو عارف أيش
ويخليهم يخدموا ويقدموا العشاء والأكل
للأنقليز اللي على الطاولة، ليه؟
عشان يتطلعوا عليهم، كأنهم متحف دائر، شايف كيف؟
يعني كأنهم قرود ودببة ونمور وزرافات، تأتي لكي ننظر إليها
فالاستعمار ليس فقط يحتل الأرض
ولكن يخلق من المواطن الأصلي موضوع متاحفه
فنحن الآسيويين والأفريقيين، نحن متاحف الغرب
والمتاحف يعني مشروع حداثي؟
طبعًا، طبعًا
الحداثة هذه مشكلة
مشكلة عويصة